bonjour à tous salut Sami bien cette 4e
ronde du tata style on est revenu
normalement plus fort mieux équipé on
espère vous proposer une bonne qualité
audio on va attendre vos retours en ce
sens dans le chat nésitez pas à nous
dire onespère que tout va bien et en
attendant on va faire une petite
présentation des parties du jour euh je
peux m n nous dire les les principaux
chque alors donc on va on va avoir table
1 donc je crois que c'est la c'est la
caméra que marque qui marchera pas je
crois non ah non c'était carwana non
c'est carwana qui pas les beau yeux de
carwana donc on va voir chanclan contre
rapport donc chanlan qui qui qui fait
enfin le début T qui fait qui vraiment
un excellent jeu positionnel moi j'aime
beaucoup comment il joue mais il a un
peu de mal à finir cette partie il
contre rapport char rapport qui est
toujours à laffu des des ouvertures un
petit peu comment
dire spécial mais en tout cas il a trois
parties décisives sur trois rapports
donc premier du spectacle chaque jour
donc c'est plutôt cool il gagn avec les
Noirs déjà donc il est capable avec les
deux coup on aller chercher le
point on espère clairement en tout cas
une partie décisive ici ouais deè quiier
donc très intéressant aussi on voit donc
franda donc le jeune indien de 16 ans
qui joue contre Nils grandelius grandus
qui a un demi point sur
TR qui c'est pas un bon tournoi il joue
pas très très bien dans ce
tournoity
tournoi gr pourra avoir zé se nul il
était
foutu belle opportunité pour le petit
prodige indien de rebondir avec les
blanc peut-être c'est ça on espère voirf
cas moi j'espère
voir mon petit Poulin marquer son
premier point aujourd'hui sa première
victoire ensuite on va voir les
blancs
salut fa salut à toi alors du coup on a
bonjour yes donc on a carlen qui joue
contre son second un second V forest
donc ça va être aussi intéressant hein
après car blanc donc il a quand même un
bon avantage enfin il est quand même
beaucoup plus fort ouais mais de mémoire
il me semble qu'il avait eu du mal
contre for
justement Mme il fail perdre avec les
Blancs il me semble si si j'ai la bonne
référence euh non car avait les Noirs
noir dernier tu es sûr mais il est fa
per en tout cas sûr parce que je su même
l'ouverture on demandera une
vérification salut Go boss non c'était
italienne avec cavalier
G5 cavalier G5 D5 il avait eu je me sui
un très tout àur et V forest ça Ava les
blanc et euh et c'était très très très
chaud et ça a fait nul mais
euh mais ok là car blanc c'est quand
même autre chose oui oui puis ascendant
psychologique quand même c'est pas trop
contre contre son second mais mais bon
on sait jamais forme moi je vois bien
jouer un truc tranquille ESS de gagner
avec une petite finale pas forcément le
point fort du du jeune nlandais mais on
verra 200 € sur car pas peut vraiment
parier tu as trouvé un site pour parier
sur sur les parties
d'éche il avait avant il y avait un site
anglais je sais pas si marchecore ouais
ça existe ouais
ouais ça existait
ouais donc ensuite on
a on a ouais of Doua c'est c'est hyper
intéressant les deux les deux joueurs
qui ont qui ont un style vraiment pour
gagner joue pour gagner tous les deux
vraiment hyper intéressant côas 171 sur
car ah ouais c'est pas mal
hein 171 c'est correct après bon faut
quand même gagner mais il a l'air plutôt
chaud avec les Blancs il a l'air bien
dans son tournoi je trouve Caren il a
fait de Bones partie les noir en vrai
moi j'ai moi je un gambleur mais ça me
paraît risqué quand même bah en même
temps je ça me semble assez juste bon ok
ensuite on va finir du PE près les
présentations on a Kia kingiry donc ça
par contre je sais pas quelle est la
côte du nul mais mais je pense qu'on
faut pas hésiter à miser votre maison
ici car il a
kingir vu l'état d'esprit de deux
joueurs deput du tournoir parce qu'akin
vient de perdre donc il va sûrement
vouloir bah solidifier consolider
tranquille jour le repos a peu de chance
qu'il n cherche des histoires donc on
verra
ouais ensuite le leader vidit qui cré
quandme la petite surprise depuis le
début du tnoi
ouais
1en alors Penko qui qui aussi qui fait
aussi des belles surprises heinenko qui
a fait nul contre SC n contre MOV et
ensuite qui a battu kam c'est qui un
très très bon début de
tournoi donc là c'est vraiment le le le
match des des leaders en ce moment ouais
puis très solide il perd vraiment pas
beaucoup de parties à part contre max
Lagarde du coup quand il avait trop on
se souvient mais sinon c'est un joueur
qui fait beaucoup de N je crois que je
de réussi il avait fait une Dorfman il
avait fait que des nul 100 %. donc c'est
dur de le passer déjà même sil est
encore jeune c'est un pe une muraille
donc on va voir VI les blanc sil essaie
d'accentuer son avance en
tête et enfin on a carwana doub là c'est
la caméra Bier donc c'est peut-être deux
JS on n'aura pas forcément toujours
leurs images mais pare c'est une belle
affiche un doub qui vient de perd une
partie dououloureuse hier alors qu'il av
plutôt une position prometteuse TR donc
dire carwana avec les Noirs c'est pas
forcément la chose facile mais mon car
pour l'instant il a du mal il a fait que
des nuls mais peine avoir un avantage il
a poussé contre chanland très longtemps
d'ailleurs on vous a quitté avant la fin
de la partieou on vous a pas menti on a
vu qu'il y avait
nul donc voilà pour les les affiches du
jour et puis on a juste on faire bah
qu'à commencer par là par le challengers
si tu veux pour aller voir notre petit
français au passage salut g tram salut
François et et donc Marc Andrea qui a
0,5 sur 3 donc un début très difficile
et là il a les blancs il joue contre la
joueuse chinoise
ginerzu la joueuseage est-ce qu'elle a
zé point ou est-ce qu'elle a finalement
sauvé alors est-ce qu'elle a sauvé hier
je crois pas mais on peut check ouais
c'est sûrement la Lanter de Ros donc il
a les il est mieux classé d'ailleurs
c'est
peut-être seul adversaire qui sera mieux
classé il y a de jouur
ou avec les Blancs c'est quand même
c'est quand même marquer le point une
partie intéressante il peut essayer de
tirer sur l'épingle du jeu ouais pour la
confiance serait quand même le bon
moment ici de scorer av la journée de
repos demain ser la première journée de
repos histoire de partir avec l'esprit
un petit peu plus
satisfait donc elle a perdu hein je
confirme bien qu'elle a perdu donc elle
elle a zé sur TR elle a zé sur dur pour
on ne serit pas non plus lac tout ces
parties mais ça pouvit que à la r su ça
vous
arrangit c'est clair donc du coup donc
il a les blancs donc au début bon là
c'est là c'est une ouverture dire
standard c'est il va dans son répertoire
c'est la même tu vois c'est la même
partie qu'on a qu'on a eu face à c'était
quoi c'était douuda pranda douuda ouais
qu'on a qu'on avait vu avec Kevin donc
avec AV3 a PR les deux prend prend et
cetera
ou en fait voilà blanc on un bon
avantage d'espace et puis et puis voir
un peu ce qui se passe au fur et à
mesure et c'est une verture qui a qui
qui est peu ambitieuse pour les Noirs
quand
même réperto
mais mais du coup euh bon on peut faire
confiance quand même il est plutôt bien
préparé Mar avec les blanc il devrait au
moins la
pression il jou assez vite t B1 t ça pas
une tête de coup principale mais en je
conis vraiment pas bien la ici je sais
pas
si bah je sais que cavalier F3 c'est le
coup que
généralement cavalier F3 prise prise fou
B4 échec mais là l'idée en fait l'idée
je pense que to c'est cavalier F3
normement le principal et à la place de
jouer de jouer là et puis on prend puis
on prend fou B4 et là on va si tu veux
jouer hein prise prise fou B4 fou D2
sous prend d'AM prend petit rock ou C4
euh ça c'est la partie de
de de Prague de de Prague contre Douda
et en fait du coup donc làav D7 et
cetera et en gros euh euh tour B1 l'idée
c'est d'empêcher F B4
j'imagine en fait il il y a eu F7 et
peut-être maintenant il va jouer
cavalier F3 et essayer de d'empêcher du
coup euh B il y a plus CD CD fa b4er
davantage de pièces pour garder case
noir ok mais j'ai vu tourb ça reste un
coup principal effectivement tu as
raison C F3 c'est la ligne numéro 1 mais
tourb c'est quand même un coup aussi
très joué très
connu et merci beaucoup à à à Kevin pour
pour le raid donc on va te faire on va
te faire un petit un petit saut alors
les gars si vous connaissez pas la
chaîne de Kevin n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs
vous allez retrouver ce weekend pour
commmenter le tournoi
avec yes hop donc allez J un à sa chaîne
lcher un petit follow il est hyper sympa
hyper pédagogue et
euh très actif il stream quasiment tous
les jours donc ouais il stream 5 jours
par semaine voilà pour progresser 5
jours par semaine c'est ça yes donc
allez le voir
franchement salut P métal salut Arnaud
salutertal salut à tous alors du coup
bienvenue ouais je te propose qu'on
repasse sur le ouais donc là il se passe
pas grand chose pour l'instant princip
puis oneviendra voir un petit peu
comment évolue cette partie de de
marondria allez on va aller voir
directement on va commencer par champion
du monde car blan contre V
forest alors on va revenir au début il
il a choisi le petit cavalier F3 tout en
souplesse Caren il aime bien puis en
plus comme il joue contre un joueur qui
connaî bien c'est toujours intéressant
de de finter de retomber dans des
schémas on sa pas exactement quand
comment
mais ah mon son est fa peut-être je sais
pas nésitez pas à nous
dire nésitez pas à nous
dire Mo je suis équipé d'un micro donc
le son devrait être
meilleur donc
cali5 répon
principale regarder la
suite tranquillement
yes donc G6 fou G2 fou G7
D46 finalement D4
ouais donc en fait ou il va jouer une
sorte de de petit rock petit
rock de slave avec
g63 en fait penseil veut juste jouer aux
échecs et éviter la théorie il sait que
Van forest c'est un grand spécialiste de
la théorie
et
et et puis en plus c'est un joueur qui
l'a quand même pas mal soutenu et
préparé pendant le Championnat du Monde
et autres donc partage beaucoup d'idées
théoriques ensemble donc je pense c'est
normal d'essayer d'éviter un peu la
théorie contre un joueur euh contre un
joueur comme CELI ils se connaissent
très bien donc pu sa qu'il est plus
fortéchec donc s joue une partie d'échec
d'ailleurs ça va faire une espèce de
doubleet il a joué B3 voilà mais il a
raison he Carlsen doit jouer dans dans
l'optique d'avoir une position avec des
possibilités il cherche pas forcément
l'avantage enfin mais bien sûr tu peux
avoir l'avantage tu le prends mais
l'idée c'est que c'est difficile à ce
niveaulà de prendre avantage même avec
les Blancs euh contre un joueur qui est
bien préparé et du coup en fait il veut
une position avec plein de possibilités
et euh et euh donc voilà donc c'est
c'est l'idée hein
ok du coup à niveau sur il quelque chose
à
faire si je coupe ça je pense est-ce que
ça change quelque chose est-ce qu'on
m'entend déjà là je pense que c'est
pareil fa quand même tester pour voir je
crois que mon son est assez faible ici
et malheureusement j'ai pas de moyen de
l'augmenter là
est-ce que est-ce que déjà il y a un
changement en terme de qualité déco
n'hésitez pas à N
dire alors lae parler je regarde je peux
faire avoir un
petit je voir un petit on va aller voir
pr
avec
on va aller
voir il est
debout c'est ahér j'avais ça c'est une
GRF avec 3 donc peutreu le début pour
voir alors moi je joue ça ni AC les noir
donc je suis pas s connaître en tout cas
j'ai pas de connaissance très profonde
là-dessus mais j'avais vu un M de de
speed chess il y a quelques années euh
entre Nakamura et mvl et Nakamura ne
faisait faisait que de répéter cette
ligne sans arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt
avec les Blancs ouais contre mvl et
euh et dame à 3 alors pourquoi pourquoi
met la dame
à3 ça bah en fait je pense qu'il va
empêcher C5 C5 c'est la réaction c'est
la réaction normale en fait des des
noirs et j'imagine
que bon est-ce que c'est sera si bon
imaginons c'est 5
estce tu ouvres le F tu fais des doubl
ouais ça voir je sais pas ça
paraî c'est pe-être pas ça la raison
alors je ne sais pas je suis pas encore
une fois
[Musique]
euh donc Tama 3 ça empêche aussi les
idées avec cavalier B6 peutêtre
éventuellement ou les A6 B5 alors je
sais que souvent tu peux jouer aussi des
A6 B5 avec avec G de tempo sur la dame
ok après dans ma 3 aussi fou G5 taper
sur7 je pense qu'il y a plein d'idé de
ce type là donc ça peut empêcher C5 F
qui VI en G5 pour taper sur E7 ça
empêche les cavaliers B G tempo sur la
dame
sêche eff non c'est un coup qui qui qui
fait prophylactique qui a plusieurs
petites idées oua et là on voit
queand pourstant 100 % de
précision ce que j'avais jamais vu je
crois jusque là bah c'est la théorie
donc c'est pas un 99,7 6 5 100
[Musique]
% marrant donc ok après grandellux c'est
c'est un grand spécialiste de de de la
théorie Thor de manière générale les
ouvertures donc je pense pas que ça
vraiment étonné de voir ce de position
donc ça je CIS que la partie elle a elle
a continué hein ouais ouais on va aller
voir voir ce qui pass après après la C5
é joué quand même tu vois donc donc il y
a eu C5 voilà et maintenant il y a eu F
2 donc tranquillement
voilà et donc C5 oui c'est5 généralement
c'est un coup qui peut jou avant ro
ouais dans Maral après je ne sais pas
quelles sont vraiment les les subtilités
euh oui on c que ça pas être un problème
de le faire après l'urope finalement
puisque c'était pas une vraie une vraie
idée de manger hein parce que fa
beaucoup trop pas ouais non mais il do
il doit y avoir des oui des petites
subtilités
dans transpose peut-être tout simplement
ici
ouais malheureusement là je peux pas
vraiment vous expliquer pourquoi je suis
pas vraiment spécialiste C ouverture
mais je sais que les deux se joue c'est
clair mais après je pense pas qu'il a
une grande différence
ouais et je regarde un petit peu alors
on
voit je regarder un petit
peu c'est quoi ce bruit bizarre non
c'était moi qui faisais un peu n'importe
quoi
ok alors oui on a aussi kakin c'est une
grfelder unu parti on va all voir bah le
leader peut-être vidit non ouais ouais
on peut aller voir vidit on va aller
voir
et là ça c'est italienne standard ouais
ouais donc avec H6 vas-y vas-y je te
laiss voir yes du classique on a vu déjà
la ronde précédente la première ronde
aussi C3 donc toujours dans dans
l'optique de jouer des4 de se battre
pour le centre D6 VO c'est des
ouvertures vraiment bah en tout cas en
apparence on est plus simple mais en
réalité c'est bien sûr il y a des
subtilités mais justeon sort ces pièces
on essaie de se battre pour le centre ce
qu'on apprend des
but et ici peut-re ça peut être
intéressant de noter qu'en fait par
exemple on n pas vraiment peur de se
faire clouer le cavalier avec les Noir
et parfois ça peut être un problème dans
certaines parties alors la première
chose c'est parce qu'on a pas roquet
donc déjà on pourra facilement faire H6
G5 si on veut pour chasser le fou sans
affaiblir notre Ro et puis en plus il y
a pas de cavalier qui menace d'aller en
D5 pour faire une pression surage parce
que il y a leoption qui est venu ici
donc pour ces deux raisons voilà c'est
pas un danger on n pas peur de c ouais
et eu kry petitrock et maintenant il a
joué donc à donc histoire d'essayer de
me contredire un petit peu mais c'est
certainement parce que justement il veut
roquer à terme et donc c'est prophyl
après il y a après bon il il y a
clairement l'idée de de d'empêcher fou
G5 et de jouer un autre schéma mais il y
a aussi bien sûr un coup he qui qui est
hyper intéressant quand tu jou pour le
gain avec G5 ouais évidemment euh voilà
alors après euh bon d'ailleurs dans la
partie hier la partie de de doubof
contre vidit justement c'est joué avec
il y a eu un il y a eu un fou G5 H6 fou
H4 il y a eu G5 le fou par G3 les Noirs
ont perdu le P les blancs les noir ont
le P 4 et une partie compliquée hier
entre entre doubbu et vidit vidit
victorieux hein cette parti qui très
compliqué et d'ailleurs j'ai vu après
les les les interviews de doubof euh de
il disait que c'était il pensait que
c'était une de ses meilleures parties
qui joué de sa vie mais en fait il il
avait regardé sur son petit ordinateur
tu vois il av pas branché la grosse
turbine et ça disait qu'il avait joué
tous les meilleurs coups de défense donc
il était très heureux il attendait la
confirmation de savoir si effectivement
c'était bien le cas mais je crois que
oui à priori elle a vraiment dépendu
comme une machine ouais et euh et du
coup euh et du coup euh du coup voilà
donc
euh
je sais pas je pense pas que en fait
iipenko je je pense pas que ce soit le
genre de la maison à faire H6
G5 en fait c'est un joueur très
classique très solide école russe ouais
et je le vois pas trop bancer G5 mais
après bon s'il a une idée s'il est
préparé c'est possible ouiis d'accord
aveci son style c'est plutôt de faire
nul avec les Noirs ici mais non c'est
pas forcément de faire nul c'est de
jouer plus aux échecs plus classiqu
c'est pas le genre à s'envoyer en l'air
c'est pas un doubbof ou un il il a un
style plus classique et euh moi je pense
oui petit Rock Tour 6 il va jouer
standard un moment donné peut-être un 5
enfin voyez comme comme d'habitude un
petit peu euh donc je pense ça va être
vraiment une une partie assez classique
dans dans l'italienne je vois pas un
gros combat avec G5 je le vois pas
arriver ouais on sait jamais mais mais
effectivement on aura la réponse bientôt
pour le son bah j'ai rapproché le micro
donc du coup j'espère que ça va suffire
sinon là ce qu'on peut faire peut-être à
la pause h on va continuer le petit tour
des stades on va aller voir ouais un
match qui a l'air sympa c'est mamedia of
douuda alors je vois qu'il y a déjà eu
énormément de de pièces qui ont disparu
de les chiquers ils ont joué très vite
euh alors on va essayer
de de
revenir au début voir comment on arrivit
là
ouais la mur BC les pièces blanches fa
trois pour l'instant même s'il aurait pu
faire une trois parties décisives
peut-être dans de sens
d'ailleurs bdac a quand même énormément
Boussé les ouvertures cette année il a
explosé et il a beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé ce secteur qui éit son point
faible il est bien mieux préparé
qu'avant et donc C5 donc là
immédiatement c'est la grosse grosse
tension au centre donc avec la
possibilité pere de faire des échanges
de Dam si la flèche n'est pas à moitié
livre voil ce qui s'est passé non mais
ça c'est sa partie il a joué il a la
même partie là je sais plus contre il a
jou une partie comme ça récemment a
c'est encore une fois théorique
évidemment déjà vu et donc4 pour pour
jouer un petit peu sur sur ce clouage
aveidé peut-être de dérroquer
potentiellement et de profiter des
lignes qui vont s'ouvrir pour pe-êre
embêter ce roi s'il arrive au centre on
va le voir je pense que qui s'est passé
dans la partie il y a eu despr 4
sacrifice detion hein alors c'est
peut-être un pseudo sacrifice on va voir
s récupre ce pion8 et cavalier G5 ça pas
l'air d'être vraiment sacrifice on va
récupérer un pion a priori oui c'est la
partie merci Méal et salut au
passagechang
g5ci même si les dames ont disparu on a
les
blanctitive une fourch la priorité et
récupérer le après je pas ce que tu en
penses mais à mon avis récupérer le P
c'est pas la priorité c'est pas
l'objectif premier ce qu'on veut c'est
essayer de se développer très vite
peut-être pour vraiment mettre la
pression sur roi qui qui est quand même
mal placé il est au milieu de colonne
ouvertees h donc en fait il peut y avoir
un avantage de développement assez euh
assez conséent assez rapide avec F C4 F
F4 comme tu le montres AC grand rock
ouais et euh d'ailleurs juste pour le
pour la petite histoire euh j'avais j'ai
bon malgré moi des fois ça m'est arrivé
de travailler un peu les échecs et en
fait euh cette position fait penser à
une partie de doretski où en fait le
grand rock était un mauvais coup pour
les blancs parce que du coup le roi noir
pouvait se cacher sur la colonne C et du
coup comme il avait le roi blanc en C1
ben je peis pas attaquer ça faisait
beaucoup penser à une par il avait dit
une fois que les fous étaient sortis le
petit était de bon coup pour mettre les
tours sur le colon CD pour vraiment
coincer le roi donc juste une idée comme
ça que qui me passait par la tête
effectivement c'est
peut mais alors que grand ro peut
paraître très très bien bah je mets mon
roi à laab je je me développe je mets
une Tourche je fais échec tout en même
temps mais au final euh c'est pas
forcément tout le temps bon parce que du
coup euh bah le roi sur la colonne C des
fois en des fois tu veux mettre la tour
sur la colonne C en fait et du coup
après grand rock le roi noir ira en C8
ou en C7 et la tour tu pourra plus venir
sur la colonne petit rock tu perds un
peu de temps mais après tu mets les deux
tour sur deux colonnes ouvert paraître
aussi plus sympa mais en tout cas c'est
clair comme tu le dis là bah d'ailleurs
là il y a eu F6 et on voit bien en fait
que sur F 6 et ben les blancs parfait
qu'elle fallit prend le 4 juste pour
revenir ce que tu disais c'est sûrement
une question vous vous posez beaucoup
dans vos parties nous aussi à chaque
fois quel tour mettre quel tour mettre
en D1 quel tour mettre en C1 souvent
quand on a les deux possibilités c'est
dur de trouver la bonne réponse alors
parfois c'est assez kiif kif faut pas
non plus forcément passer trop de temps
à prendre sa décision essayer d'aller au
plus simple et le meilleur moyen moi je
trouve pour vous conseiller c'est quand
vous savez pas quel tour mettre sur
quelle case dites-vous juste bah à
quelle case appartient l'autre tour en
fait vous êtes sûr que vous voulez
mettre une tour dans la colonne D là ça
fait aucun doute c'est la bonne colonne
du coup l'autre où on veut la mettre
plutôt en C plutôt en E et en fonction
vous aurez votre réponse c'est très
souvent cette façon de réfléchir bah ça
vous donne vraiment la solution de quel
tour choisir il y a toujours des
exceptions mais moi je trouve que c'est
le plus simple euh donc dans la partie
voilà comme on disait il a pas mangé le
pion ça n'intéresse pas il s'est plutôt
précipité sur le fou on disant bon bah
j'ai certains pions de moins mais des
pions doublés ils sont dégueulasses ils
sont faibles j'ai la paire de fou les
liges s'ouvre euh moi je serai pas sur
un avec les noir ici position non
clairement après bon ben les joueurs
connaissent sont
th a pas de doute mais sans connaître tu
prends pas les noir non non donc 5 qui
est
naturel pours le développement H6 h
réaction immédiate le petit coin
intermédiaire le Grand surch qui fait
toujours
plaisir il se cach en le7 ok alors
plutôt en C7 ou en C8 parce que comme on
l'a dit alors en C7 tu Auris un en C7 tu
ais un cavalier B5 peut-être mais en C8
ça peut être possible mais du coup la
Tour Noire en8 pourrait pas bouger là ce
qu'il veut faire avec les noir il ve
mettre le RO en F7 en fait le roi il va7
donc bien sûr je bloque le fou et soit
je fais G5 il fou G7 soit je fais roi F7
et le fou pourra sortir sur la diagonale
en fait tu vas vouloir se ranger ce roi
il va être un peu au soutien aussi de ce
pioni ce qui est faible par que on peut
voir que si je fais tomber le micro
moins bien m'entendre on peut voir que
sur roi C8 eu le pion E6 va devenir bon
faud bien sûr régler ce problèmes de
fond he c'est juste pour illustrer euh
le pion le 6 va être très faible donc
avoir le roi à la défense ça peut être
quand même très utile donc dans la
partie le pion le 7 là il a décidé
d'échanger donc de donner la pare de fou
pour récupérer son pion
immédiatement pour F6 donc bien sûr g
prend F6 on n pas le
choix et euh cavalier prend le 4 éé joué
récupère son pion et c'est vrai que la
position a l'air pas si dramatique pour
les Noirs en fait non non ça va F5
F5 G3 on prend on prend la diagonale et
les B en G3 alors je pense que c'est
pour peut-être des fois embêter le fou
ou quand on va se
développer mettre la pression sur de
mais c'est un petit peu dommage enfin
moi non ok c'est peutêtre très
bien3 ben en fait j'ai l'impression que
le cavalier en fait en G3 il a pas grand
chose à faire à part attaquer F5 donc
moi un jour je je bougerai mon roi mon
fou et puis ton cavalier il a pas trop
de case après des
foiséployer comme ça il peut ouais tu
peux mettre en en H5 et F4 essayer de le
mettre ailleurs ça pe être pas mal en
fait avec le F en C4 la tour en1 pour
sur 6 mais mais il est vrai que moi
j'aurais je pense que de manière
automatique je serais allé en en
C3 pour aller en B5
parce que en C3 bon la case B5
finalement il y aura rien au C7
mais je suis pas trop d'accord avec toi
C3 je VO pas trop l'avenir le jeu la
cible des blancs c'est vraiment ces deux
pions qui sont faibles on veut taper
là-dessus j'ai l'impression qu' C3 tu
t'éloignes de l'action un peu c'est plus
difficile d'agir sur ce pion là ouais en
fait il faut trouver une case pour
vraiment rebondir donc peut-être C5 comm
peutêtre C5 c'est bien mais C5 ça me
plisait pas trop d'être sous la
diagonale du fou tu peux gagner un ou
parce que B6 alors B6 c'est un
affaiblissement là je suis d'accord que
B6 c'est pasent une bonne nouvelle pour
les Noirs parce que vous voyez euh les
cases blanche s'ouvre donc là peut-être
même regardez hein c'est rigolo on
pourrait
mêmeutêre mais on pourrait même se faire
un coup comme G3 par exemple même G3 ça
pourrait être jouable dans l'idée en
fait que s'il prend j'ai fou G2 alors
peut-être que c'est débile j'en sais
rien peut-être qu'il y a un coup mais
juste pour vous dire à quel point c'est
affblissant au niveau des case blanche
et comme les Noirs en plus n'ont plus le
foot case blanche et ben ça peut être
dangereux donc ça c'est juste pour
montrer à quel point c'est c'est faible
j'ai pas dit que je CIS c'est le bon
coup hein mais juste vous montre à quel
point c'est c'est c'est dangereux donc
B6 c'est pas un coup si vous avez pas
cass blanche essayez de pas trop ouvrir
ces c blanchees comme ça c'est c'est des
affissement un petit peu pour rien du
coup ici on pourit s en disant prendre
B7 ça sera extrêmement dangereux parce
que maintenant les Noirs vont avoir une
vraie attaque ils vont avoir le leurs
quatre pièces mineurs qui vont être
braqué parce que celui-là il va arriver
hein braqué sur le sur le roi blanc et
avec les colonnes ouvertes euh là c'est
extrêmement dangereux autant dire qu'ici
il y a des compensations plus que
suffisantees pour le pion je pense que
prendre B7 ce serait extrêmement long
moment et de toute façon c'est un choix
qui n'a pas été fait par pi qui a mis
son C G3 pour viser plutôt les cases un
peu autour du roi et ici je P c'est un
très bon coup de de bac a jouer H5 H5
qui empêche cavalier H5 lui-même qui euh
donc menace H4 pour chasser le cavalier
et aussi éventuellement fou H6 pour se
développer donc c'est ça a l'air d'être
vraiment très bien joué en tout cas ce
cou H5 c'est très précis fallait pas se
laisser visser justement
peut-être
donc4
logiqueener les piè au
centre bon maintenant quand même falloir
trouver un moyen de défendre sur 6
facile
jou comment on défense
ou et là ça va être bon pire j'ai t TR
H6 mais bon il a l'air de de connaître
très vite he il a joué cavalier D7
ok le Caval en C5 probablement
ouais hein c'est on menace quand même de
cou sur
tour a l'air de faire une double menace
embêante il a tour
C8 h donc là faut bien calculer parce
que même si on mange
ici on va bouger le roi tout simplement
et au final ce trou va être perdu parce
que si on le défend il y aura juste B5
on joue sur le clouage et on n pas le
temps de contre-attaquer sur ce cavalier
hein parce que les les cas sont
contrôlés par le F euh donc on va juste
gagner une pièce avec les Noirs ce qui
fait que la prise en réussi c'est pas
vraiment possible et la prise en F5 sur
échec hein pour jouer sur on va
simplement bouger le roi j'imagine ici
et maintenant on se retouve avec deux
pièces en prise et comme tout à l'heure
si jamais le cabalier vient défendre il
y aura simplement l'avancé pion et on
gagnera le fond donc ici avec les avec
les Blancs il doit à tout prix on est
dans cette situation il doit à tout prix
anticiper sur C8 il va certainement je
sais pas ce que tu en penses mais jouer
ro B dans des tir ouais et ça ça c'est
drôle parce que tout à l'heure on
parlait du fait de de jouer grand rock
avec gain de temps échec et cetera et au
final maintenant et ben on se rend
compte que finalement B le roi est mal
placé ENCI et que on perd le temps qu'on
a gagné en devant jouer ro B1 quoi ouais
mais tu vois en fait dans la V tu as
montré à voir avec Caval pr B7 par
exemple là on voit clairement que ça
peut être très dangereux en fait à cause
du RO quiut mal plac donc comme quoi des
fois faire attention on a l'impression
que grand c'est très très bien ça gag un
temp mais des fois faut quand même
vérifier bon ok il y a pas de sou ouais
mais il faut se méfier un petit peu de
tout ça en tout cas bon c'est une partie
assez intéressante c'est une finale
certes mais c'est une fin assez actif il
quand Mme pas mal de pièces encore ouis
et puis il y a des faiblesses chacun
c'est pas symétrique ça joue donc on
peut s'attendre encore encore à une à
des à des choses dans cette partie je
pense c'est intéressant de de voir ce
qui se passe alors est-ce qu'on a une
autre partie intéressante qui pourrait
nousre ouais alors on a déjà vu car on a
vu Douda on a vu un peu VP euh je
regarde un petit peu une d en B2 dans la
GU de rapport si tu veux encher après on
va voir les les dernières d'accord on va
regarder rapidement de rapport
peut-être qui pas forcément l' d'êre la
parti pourant
plusc à la mode depuis Championnat du
Monde etis surtout le mat j'ai envie
d'annoncer j'ai envie j'ai envie
d'annoncer excuse-moi j'ai envie
d'annoncer la nul de Guir et kakin dans
quelques secondes déjà
oke on va voir mais bon on s'y attendait
pour le coup c'est pas une surprise et
ouais ça fait nul ils vont serrer la
main dans quelques
secondes
vraiment on l'avait dit mais bon là en
vrai je pensais pas que ça allait jouer
une
demi-heure d'Illes son aucun des deux et
nul voilà signé quel champion bon la
côte était à 134 je crois ça é annoncé
dans le chat finalement 134 ça valait le
coup de mettre de l'argent dessus
ouis mais pas eu trop de de stress
c'était c'était
évident noir donc c'est normal lui il va
pas mais est noir donc il est pas
combatif et enfin il faire nul en non
mais il est content de faire nul c'est
normal et kakin et ben il fait son
rajabof c'est ça fait son Rajab et donc
on a un magnifique
perpétuel moi ça change un peu on on a
plein des perpétuels
sur sur la
Grunfeld en généralel je le connaissais
pasutre Dansette dans cette partie bon
rien à dire hein dire is le ils ont
appris leur truc ils ont fait nul comme
ça minutes 30 minutes tranquillement
voil ça de jours de repos kak à mon avis
il a vraiment aucune ambition là tout ce
qui l'intéresse c'est les candidats
c'est les candidats il jamais pr avant
c'est s
ouais donc ok une nulle donc du coup on
peut on pe revenir du coup sur sur ch on
va revenir sur Sam ch Richard
était là au début par un peu confux on
avait une P on
disait hésite il avait la main sur la
pièce il ais sa main il a rejoué on
ouais pareil énormément de débat théori
sur cette ouverture depuis match
Championnat du Monde caranayé cette arme
avec succès contre Caren et puis on a vu
que NP
employé à son tour
Paro plus ou moins efficace
contme symétrieu faire penser pardon à
une une défense française aussi une
varich de la françaiseme simitud en TER
de
structure la pete différence on voit
pion doubl mais bon les blancs à mon
pouront jouer C4
potentiellement et le C4 prendre et
rejer C4 derrière voilà exactement on
voit quand même que leurs pièces sont
relativement braquées sur le roi noir
donc il peut y avoir une petite
initiative d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans la partie ici c'est 5 il pas
faire il
réagit il attaque le P D5
h et j'ais demandé qu'est-ce qu'il a
prévu sur C4 bah on va le savoir puis
que c'est la partie C4 donc F F5 c'est
standard met son fond F5 il peut
potentiellement y avoir des échanges
assez massifs ici h sur cavalier prend
E5 donc fou F5 et G6 par exemple fou H3
ça reste en fait euh ça ça me fait
penser à une idée de de de de la Nimzo
avec FO H3 pour échanger les FC blanche
euh regarde juste un truc mais euh alors
ici moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que peut-être euh le petit plus blanc il
peut être lié au fait que le pion des 5
peut se retrouver parfois un peu faible
ah le pion des 5 est faible là on a un
avantage d'espace quand même et donc ce
qu'il faut un petit peu voir c'est les
échanges donc massif dont je vous
parlais donc la prise avec le cavalier
au quel cas bon on a pas le choix on
reprend bien sûr et euh le fou va
certainement se mettre dans cette
diagonale et admettons moi je sais pas
s'il faut manger ou laisser les
d'ailleurs les les noir manger mais
juste pour illustrer on peut se
retrouver dans une position type où la
seule pièce mineure restante c'est un
foot cas noir de chaque côté et on
pourrait croire que bah la structure de
PION blanche est mauvaise puisque il y a
des pions doublés des pions isolés mais
le fait est qu'en fait ces trois pions
ils contiennent assez
bien ça voilà les quatre pions noirs ici
ils sont difficilement attaquables en
fait ils peuvent être un petit peu
chatouillés par exemple par la dame mais
globalement ils bloquent assez bien leur
vis-à-is alors queà l'inverse les blancs
s font au coup prophylactique comme
rchin ils ont un cas de com 3 qui peut
être assez puissant et vraiment créer
bah une majorité au centre voir Créer un
P passé ou pourquoi pas des idées de de
réseau un peu sur le roiah c'est un peu
du long terme mais c'est un déséquilibre
en fait qui est intéressant et peut-être
plus facile à jouer dernière chose après
je la me dire ce que tu en penses il y a
la colne ouverte je suis d'accord et ce
qui est hyper intéressant aussi c'est
que le pion D5 ben c'est un pion qui est
qui arriéré en fait le pion D5 tu vois
je per tour à D1 et le pion il va être à
défendre donc alors je sais pas s'il
faut j'ai fou au 3 d'abord pour essayer
d'échanger les fous parce qu'en fait les
Noirs vont Esser de faire D4 pour se
débarrasser de leur pion arriéré un pion
arriéré c'est un pion qui est en arrière
par rapport à sa structure ilit pas être
défendu par par les pions en fait du
coupion sir quoi c'est ça donc le pion
il est il est censé être faible et et en
plus il est sur une colonne semi-ouverte
ouverte côté blanc du coup les blancs
aimeraient faire tour D1 et aller manger
le pion D5 les Noirs pourrai faire D4
justement pour essayer de de sortir de
ça et échanger ce pion qui est une
faiblesse hein c'est quandême mieux de
l'échanger que de le perdre et euh donc
l'idée ce serait d'essayer de faire ça
aprèser le P
B7 plein de choses concrètes à
considérer il aussi avoir du contrejeu
sur le pion A2 c'est la tour sen va
parce que c'est vrai que il peut être il
peut être fort en final après ouais donc
ça reste une position quand même avec
des Chan des deux côtés mais assez
intéressante même si vo le matériel est
réduit on est pas encore là on va voir
si si c'est la la voie que choisit
rapport avec les noir après Richard
rapport c'est un joueur qui quand même
essaie de de de bah de gagner toujours
ESS d'avoir des pr dynamiqu il tente sa
chance donc je je vois pas jouer des
position vraiment vraiment
trop trop
égal je moi je pense voir garder les
pièces euh alors je sais pas du tout ce
g je sais pas j'aime pas G6 mais moi non
plus pas trop mais je sais pas
mais mais je sais pas je
peut-être apparemment Caval prend le 5
c'est le seul coup de la base ouais ça
toué que ça cette position
ouais al d'ailles voir un peu regarde ch
il a 1h40 donc il est clairement s prép
pas il a pas dépensé une seconde alors
que rapport il a déjà réfléchi 30
minutes donc ça c'est quand même assez
intéressant à noter ça peut jouer dans
les prochains cou c'est aussi pour ça il
do réfléchir à se dire ok comment
j'essaie de le sortir de sa prépa ici
pe mettre sa créativité contribution
justement peut-être trouver un coup pas
prévu par son adversaire ou av voir dans
les prochains cous il nous reste quoi il
nous reste une seule partie peut-être à
voir on a tout on n pas vu car en plus
peut-être plusell du jour voir c'est
intéressant et c'est la seule partie où
on n pas la caméra donc on est désolé on
a une caméra qui ne fonctionne pas c'est
la table numéro 1 et donc ça c'est c'est
une Espagne comme d'ab alors on va
revenir bon Caron qui son espagnol quand
même c'est une arme qui l'emplo très
régulièrement vidé al de joueurs quand
même très très bien préparés en général
beaucoup les ouvertures ouais oua après
c'est vrai car il est aussi dans une
situation il a les candidat bientôt donc
à quel point il est prêt à utiliser ses
grosses idées c'est toujours une
question après il y a le risque aussi
des fois on les garde trop souvent en
laboratoire et malheureusement quelqu'un
a joué avantau et du coup c'est gâché
c'est toujours dur de savoir com
l'utiliser donc là espagnol il s passé
quoi dans l'espagnol du coup alors ils
ont récité encore une fois une très très
grand bon est dans dans la rue encore un
antimarchal avec A4 qui est ultra à la
mode qu'on a vu hier entre entre Doua et
Carlsen
h donc il a un second n de Carlsen donc
pas étonnant qu' joue le répertoire de
de Carlsen aussi le répertoire du match
du championnat du monde monde il do il
doit bien connaître son sujet euh D3
D6 C3 donc VO dans la partie d'hier car
il y avait eu euh un échange rapide et
on avait liquidé toutes tous les pions
de de l' donc là c'est pas le cas il y a
un peu plus de vie mais pareil on est
toujours dans une ultra théorique calier
A5 le fou qui recule en A2 je sais pas
si dans cette variante le fou C2 est
aussi possible euh C5
fou G5 d
D72 et B prend
A4 déjàette position ouais bon position
donc 4 du coup ça bon mange un pion un
pion qui sera récupéré plus tard je
pense sans trop trop de
difficulté ici les blancs non moin gag
la C4 quand même ouais peut-être
cavalier C4 est possible ici euh changer
les cavalier et gagner du coup les
casses central he maintenant cavalier C4
pourrait menacer aussi cavalier E3 Caval
F5 ce type de chose euh et tout à
l'heure on parlait aussi du combat la
case D5 euh voilà alors D5 n'est pas
possible pour l'instant à cause de fa
prend F6 vous voyez bien que euh le bon
ça peut arriver l'idée c'est que le
cavalier F6 contrôle la case la case D5
et très souvent pour s'emparer de la
case D5 et ben on va d'abord échanger le
fr les cavalier et après installer une
pièce en D5 donc là j'aime bien le coup
cavalier C4 pense ça nous ouais ça me
semble être une idée intéressante prise
peut-être prise et euh problème il peut
peut-être s'accrocher au pion en fait
c'est pas si passile de récupérer ce
pion et ce qui est embêtant c'est qu'il
y a la colonne B qui est ouverte donc on
va quand même avoir une pression sur B2
et bon avec les Blancs comment tu
justifies vraiment euh ce pour alors moi
j'avais deux idées ici
j'avais deux idées ici la première c'est
D4 de jouer de
manièretion 4 en l' pour voir mais sinon
l'autre idée que j'avais peut-être plus
simple c'était plus classique ESS
cavalier F3 en D5 donc avec cavalier D2
cavalier F1 cavalier E3 donc manœuvre
thématique pour ramener le cavalier sur
la bonne
case5 et au moment quand j'aurai mon
cavalier en E3 avant d'aller en D5
manger le cavalier en F6 et installer
mon cavalier en problème c'est que c'est
après le problème voilà comme tu dis
c'est que les Noirs joue aussi et euh la
colonne B est ouverte et le P B il est
faible et j'ai du mal pas le défendre
avec des pions peux pas non plus
l'avancer à cause du pions à4 donc
peut-être4 est pas le meilleur mais en
tout cas c'est le coup qui qui avait
l'air assez euh qui vient à l'esprit en
tout cas à considérer euh salu aussi
Fatou qui nous a
rejoind salut Fatou alors attends par ce
que j' salutal 581
aussi h du cou alors pas tout tu
remarqueras qu'aujourd'hui j'ai mis une
belle chemise c'est vrai je je l'ai noté
moi directement c'est un très voilà
alors alors est-ce que Fatou tu peux
nous expliquer pourquoi à ton avis j'ai
mis une belle chemise aujourd'hui ah il
y a une raison précise ah oui attends tu
crois que
je c'est c'est la c'est la SA fat tout
peut-être je sais
pas calendrier 18 janvier la ça fat tout
du coupe du coup ici bizarre ça
c'est son
anniversaire c'est vra anniversaireUne
idée hein fait genre non aucune idée
mais d'accord ouais mais elle c'est très
très bien c'est très très bien c'estou
on peut le dire pe dire on peut souiter
un bon
anniversatou donc Jo anniversaire Fatou
Fatou c'est la grande modo de de la
chaîne stouf de twitch en général je
pense oui elle est sur la chaîne
française
et donc donc joyux
Noël
oh arrêter
[Musique]
pas encore pour tout ce que tu fa pour
nous déclaration
alorsinrogation qui
ouais de précision pas
terribleis donc à part C4 qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire une position
intéressante je suisux de voir ce que
queana a
prévu4 je comprends pas du tout
son F4 ça menace deer le4 mais après F
C6 c'est quoi
l'idée ça c'est d' c'est PRS enfin ouais
difficilement fou C4 et ça pour fa fou
prend F6 direct et fou
D5 c'est juste l' qu'on a check donc il
est pas
forcément extrêmement fort non plus
ok bon on va voir on va voir comment ça
se passe on a regardé tout les parties
je crois on a v pr déjà non att euh PRAG
on a vu c'était une une Grama 3 mais on
peut aller on peut revoir si tu veux
ouais bon attends retourner voir Marc
Andria allez et euh et d'ailleurs au
passage ti j'ai vu que euh alors le
tournoi n'y aa peut-être pas son terme
c'est pas la bonne nouvelle il y a deux
bah il y a deux cas de covid dans les
second ans des joueurs euh on a le
second an de de Prague com c'est
ramesche je crois qui é positif hier
Coville euh et l'autre le nom a pas
filtré par contre mais en en tout cas
pas just jusque jusque là mais bon les
deux joueurs en question dont les second
donc sont positifs eu sont bien testés
pour les jours et pour l'instant ils ont
il non'ont rien mais bon ça pourra être
complexe dans les jours à venir en tout
cas on espère bien sûr que ça
n'impactera pas la suite du tournoi mais
euh c'est vraion a quand même beaucoup
de monde il y a beaucoup de car en ce
moment II au PaysBas donc c'est pas
gagné c'est pas
gagné sont faibles hein temps on a vu
même tous les jours donc peut-être que
ça va pe protéger je sais pas tous ces
joueurs qui se sont testés positifs là
euh bah s'il y en a un qui est positif
après je crois que bon déjà il est
obligé de faire porter mais c'est Tom
est fini quoi euh là en ce moment le
covid c'est compliqué un peu de partout
hein ben moi je l'attrapé le covidé tu
es bien placé en ce moment je suis
positif les gars hein je vous le dis
hein et j'ai commencé le tournoi comme
ça et c'est c'est difficile aussi pour
tu as perdu tu m' dire l'odora et la
ouais j'ai dans la vue ça va encore non
mais c'est fou hier hier je me fais à
manger en fait vous savez le stream en
ce moment moi je suis en Argentine donc
l'oraire Galé et en fait là chez moi il
est il est 10h47 il est 4h de moins que
chez vous et en gros quand on commence à
14h chez moi il est 10h donc en gros le
repas du midi ben moi je je le saute
tout le temps j'ai pas le je peux pas je
je reste avec vous et en gros après
après le le tournoi je su fait un bon
plat de pâte j'étais bien content
j'avais un gros steak on Renti de la
viande c'est et euh je me suis pas
envie comment c'est pas hyper envie
raconter comme ça mais ok passon non
mais bon j'avais un gros petit steak
alors je l'ai je l'ai coupé en petits
morceau j'ai mis plein de petits
condiments plein de petits trucs je l'ai
fait cuire la poêle j'ai fais des pâtes
à côté de la sauce et cetera bref
j'étais un homme très très heureux et
comblé et quand j'ai commencé à manger
mon plat j'ai commencé à à m'autoinulter
en me disant que franchement euh je
cuisine vraiment comme une grosse
merde et euh j'étais vraiment fâché
contre moi-même pour euh bon je suis pas
un grand cuisinier mais bon ça va quoi
je sais faire à manger quoi à peu près
et euh et en fait ce que je faisais à
manger n'avait absolument aucun goût et
je me su dis mais vraiment c'est abusé à
quel point je suis nul quoi et euh et un
petit peu après bon ben j'avais une
bière dans le frigo je dis tiens je je
vais ouvrir ma bière quoi et ma bière
elle avait elle avait un goût bizarre
ENF en fait elle avait pas de goût quoi
et je dis bah tiens là c'est vraiment
enfin ici dans ce pays enfin juste et et
un petit peu après je commence à
vraiment à à réfléchir mais peut-être
qu'en fait j'ai perdu le goû de l'odor
donc j'ai j'ai j'ai pris du parfum je
l'ai mis sur mon bras et je sentis et en
fait je sentais rien mais vraiment rien
et donc la question c'est est-ce que mon
parfum sent rien est-ce que depuis le
début de mon voyage je me fais escroquer
sur tout ou est-ce que vraiment juste
j'ai perdu le goû l'odorat et en fait
ben j'ai perdu le goût
ilodorat sur les conseils de Fat ouais
maintenant que tu n'as plus de goût M
franchement pens en fait c'est le moment
de te mettre au légumes tout ça tu vois
tu pourras peut-être t'abituer mais
franchement c'est clair parce que je me
suis dit ok al prendre une salade c'est
quand même pas le moment enin c'est
enfin je ve dire la salade c'est juste
pas possible je pense que c'est visuel
euh en plus-être tout ça
mais mais ouais bon on va revenir à Mar
Andria apparemment ton son Sami il a un
peu flanché alors je sais pas si c'est
le cas pour tout le monde est-ce qu'on
peut nous dire dans le chat si
B écoute j'ai rien touché depuis tout à
l'heure donc ça me paraît étrange
mais on va
voir un peu faible on va regarder ça à
la pause on va essayer de voir un peu on
est bientôt en pause on on va sûrement
pouvoir changer
ça d'ici quelques minutes on va finir
juste bah le l'état des lieux sur la
partie de de Mar Andre donc on on avait
vu le on voit que ça pas mal évolué euh
bon sur A6 il va jouer bien sûr le
thématique A4 pour empêcher la prise
d'espace par
B5 et dame
C7 le fou à reculer parce que bah ici on
menacit avec les noir indirement de mon
g fou il y a une petite pression dans la
colonne C donc il a anticipé ça je
passage je se replace dans une diagonale
intéressante pour peut-être attaquer
plus tard le le roi
noir prise prise
euh
les Noirs terminent plus ou moins leur
développementud résoudre le
problème et ENF cavalier B4 on est dans
cette dans cette position essayer de
croquer la paire de fou des
blancs donc des fois ce F on peut le
donner des fois pour
l'avantageespace pas beaucoup de cas
pour le
garder quel pourquoi ne pas
avoir ici
directement
en fait je pense que l'idée c'est que je
pense qu'il veut il veut je pense qu'il
veut l'changer pour moi je m'attends un
commeê fou 3 et prise prise tour C1
essayer de jouer assez assez rapide tour
C1 l'avantage de l'avantage de
développement on peut faire pression sur
ce pion peut-être on va avoir du A5
alors A5 ça donne cette
case on a quand même un avec le pion à4
ici
B3 bon il doiv être encore peut-être
dans des sentiers battus ici même si
tout exactement leur prépa il doivent
connaître un peu les
plans
hil a joué à 5 a BL c'est ça non attends
je non pardon c'est bizarre ça me paraît
assez bizarre il réfléchit
OK ok bon c'est c'est une position qui
qui qui est plutôt bien il y a pas de
souci pour l'instant à se faire encore
beaucoup de choses
à ch à voir
ouais alors est-ce que est-ce qu'on
partirait pas un petite pause Sami le
temps de un tout ça et de on reviendra
avec la partie car pour voir pour voir
où on est champion du monde yes ça
marche allez à tout de suite les gars on
passe une pe page de
[Musique]
pubz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
V est de retour avec de cararlessen 2
forest je te laisse yes commenter
l'évolution de cette position mon cher
St yes alors du coup Carlsen V forest
donc là il s'est passé il y a eu juste
cavalier F6 cavalier euh il fut F5
pardon ça c'est thématique donc le but
ici des Noirs d'changer une paire de
cavalier les Noirs ont moins d'espace
que les Blancs donc bien évidemment les
Noirs veulent essayer d'échanger euh une
pièce mineure en tout cas les pièces
mineures
euh donc euh cavalier C3 vient d'être
joué par Carlsen donc là je pense qu'on
peut s'attendre à un cavalier pr C3 sous
prend C3 et peut-être même un cavaler
qui peut revenir en F6 et E4 euh moi je
verrais bien un petit truc comme ça
euh bon ça ce qui s'est passé dans la
partie donc là il y a C frç qui vient
d'être joué F prend C3 donc là ça va
être le coup de car devrait être
automatique euh je sais pas si vous
m'entendez un petit peu mieux ou
pas
et donc fou pr C3 a été jou par car scen
instantanément et maintenant
euh moi je verais bien un petit cavalier
F6
retour parce que
euh cavalier B6 je pense pas que ce
vraiment dans l'intérêt on vis 44 je
pense que c'est logique hein oui je
pense qu' avait les F6 qui avait le 4
c'est normal après il y a aussi un coup
hyper intéressant qu'on on a pas parlé
encore c'est le coup F 4 F 4 c'est un
coup assez intéressant ouais en fait
c'est c'est un coupagege euh je cloue le
fou le fou G2 et
euh le cavali fou G2 et tu peux pas en
fait par enlever le clouage donc des
fois des position comme ça où en fait
les Noirs jouent F4 et souvent les
blancs jou fou H3 pour s'enlever clag et
après joue cavalier D2 alors faire
attention à ça parce qu'près fou H3 il
est vrai que si je joue cavalier D2 et
ben le fou n'aura pas vraiment de Cass
pour vraiment reculer bon j'ai j'ai la
CEE D3 mais c'est bizarre avec le
cavalier peut découvert c'est compliqué
et et du coup il faut faire un peu
attention à ça mais mais F c'est un coup
qui regarde complètement c'est un coup
hyper thématique dans ces position parce
que le fou F5 c'est le mauvais fou des
des des noirs et on aurait bien pouvoir
échanger des pièces et échanger les fou
de C blanche en tout cas fou c'est un
coup qui se regarde après sinon le coup
hper thématique le coup qu'on joue en
blitz tempo c'est cavalier F6 cavalier
E4 d'autres idées peut-être d'essayer de
jouer avec avec C5 pour tout tout
échanger ou si la pousse 5 qui va se
préparer un peu plus avec oui c'est s ça
va perdre un pion sûrement mais il a
c'est position riche je pense que qu'
devrait se décanter du coup dans les
prochains cours logiquement pas mal de
choses à faire en tout
cas et euh
ouais on va
voir on va voir comment ça se passe donc
rien de décisif encore pour l'instant C
partie euh non rien décisif est-ce qu'on
peut aller voir Prague ouais parce que
la PO elle avait un peu évolu j'imis
beaucoup sa position il un pion passé en
D5 ou là oui effectivement il s'est
passé plein de trucs alors
ouais on été resté à ce fameux dame à 3
C5
voilà j'ai fou le de de
jouer bon on va juste préparer le
peut-être le petit rock ou pas
d'ailleurs puis que finalement on s'est
fait spoil il a joué avec en envoyant
page B6 est très naturel dans cette
position il défend son pion il prépare
la sortie du font et là donc Prague qui
suit la mode H4 c'est vrai que c'est un
coup qui est devenu de plus en plus
populaire surtout depuis l'émergence des
suers
ordinateurs a beaucoup ce genre d'idée
et depuis bah les top joueurs ils ont
repris à leur compte aronan je sais qui
aime beaucoup ce coup il le joue très
souvent dans plein de positions
Caren après il a il y a un truc aussi
important dans les positions de faneto
donc des inden de grunfield ou et cetera
en fait euh l'idée dès que ton cavalier
en fait enfin dès que les Noirs nont pas
de cavalier en F6 et ben tu vas avir tu
vas pouir jouer H4 bien plus facilement
parce que H4 H5 en fait il y a pas de
cavalier F donc il y a pas de cavalier
prend H5 donc là le cavalier noir a
disparu il y a eu un cavalier prend D5
cavalier prend C3 et et du coup comme il
y a pas de cavalier en F6 et ben les
blancs peuvent plus facilement balancer
le P h ici et là on voit en plus que si
cavalier venu en F6 on prend de je E5 pu
H5 donc du coup il y a pas de souci
là-dessus donc l'idée d' de H4 H5
clairement c'est d'aller changer euh le
le pion h contre le pion g pour ouvrir
la colonneage et essayer de lancer une
attaque avec le fou H6 et changer les
fous de fianquet des noirs et lancer
l'attaque là-bas euh autre idée ça
pourrait de faire H5 voir aussi H6 avec
les Blancs pour all fermer le fou G7 et
euh donc une asphyxie he plôt que
l'ouverture des lignes euh donc donc
après voir comment ça se passe donc là
il y a EU5 donc qui dit afféissement
allèle avec H4 réaction au centre donc
coup complètement logique mais ici du
coup les blancs peuvent jouer du coup le
coup D5 qui leur permet d'avoir un pion
passé si logique que ça 5
mais c'est quand même une grosse
concession positionnelle est-ce que
c'est toujours pareil fa tout le le son
hyper bas ou pas
là parce que D5 de jouet donc il quand
même un pion passé
protéger sur le long terme alors on
imagine que un momenté peut-être il va
essayer de devouir jouer F5 pour casser
mais ça a l'air dangereux alors dans ces
positions généralement donc là il va
jouer cavalier F6 onit très souvent dans
ces positions les Noirs vont essayer de
mettre un cavalier en D6 alors vous
savez quand les pions enfin quand on a
un pion un pion passé comme ça le
meilleur bloqueur d'un pion passé c'est
un cavalier donc généralement on va
mettre un cavalier devant le pion passé
pour
empêcher P d'avancer et en fait le
cavalier en D ser vraiment très très
fort pourquoi parce que premièrement il
bloque le pion et deuxièmement et ben il
attaque les pions qui vont défendre le
pion D5 par exemple le cavaler D6 depuis
sa belle cas et ben il va réussir à
attaquer le pion E4 qui défendrait le
pion D5 et aussi le pion C4 qui
défendrait aussi si le avance le pion D5
donc le cavalier défendrait les deux
pions qui défend qui qui défend le pion
de5 et aussi pourrait attaquer essayer
de rompre un petit peu toute cette bah
c'est casser un peu les les pions avec
F5 et éventuellement aussi avec B5 si le
pion blanc arrivait en C4
ouais cavalier euh le cavalier c'est le
meilleur des bloqueurs donc en D6 il
serait assez fort h là peut-être que
c'est mieux je sais pas vous allez me
dire j'ai t' écris sur Facebook c'est je
pas si tu as vu
non bah oui mais ça m'ide pas beaucoup
ce que tu m'as décrit oui mais bon euh
moi j'ai fait j'ai fait un réglage là
pour pour essayer d'augmenter
manuellement le son ma sortie en tout
cas on va
voir cavalier F6 donc on
voir le CL donc ilempêche la manvre que
tu viens de
décrire et du coup il y a dame cloué le
cavalier pour empêcher la manœuvre que
tu as décré donc la dame qui prend la
case du cier donc maintenant on va
vraiment avoir du mal mais par contre pr
4 C prend 4 une menace donc là il va
falloir défendre la la menace ok donc
euh pour prend F c'est un coup
thématique avec les Blancs pour
justement empêcher la belle manœuvre on
avait dit le cavalier qui peut arriver
un jour en D6 donc pour l'instant c'est
pas une menace parce que euh le cavali
peut pas aller en en E8 tout ça mais euh
faut prendre F6 faut prendre F6 ça reste
logique au final le fou F6 restera
complètement enfermé derrière le pion5
il
et du coup on va jouer à ch qui est
thématique ici dans les positions
fermées donc on en a parlé hein les
positions ouvertes qu les positions il y
a les diagonal sont bien ouverts les
colonnes sont ouvertes et cetera on va
de garder les fous parce que les fou
peuvent viser de loin il sont très forts
et dans les positions fermées où il y a
pas de tension au centre et ben les
cavaliers sont meilleurs les cavaliers
peuvent plus facilement manœuvrer et on
voit dans cette position ici que
euh on voit dans cette position ici que
euh les pions sont fermés le centre est
fermé et donc du coup le fou le fou F6
aura du mal à vraiment trouver quelque
chose à faire euh alors que Cavalier
Blanc en F3 pourrait aller en en D2 en
C4 fait plus de choses à faire peut-être
une idée pourir ça serait d'échanger
pour avoir des f col pososé mais le
problème euh ici c'est qu même on aurait
pas peur par exemple de se faire droquer
pour illustrer parce que le centre est
fermé donc not 3 il craint rien du tout
et par contre on se trouve avec un
cavalier vraiment dominant contre le fou
donc là c'est l'avantage stratégique
qu'on essaie d'obtenir les blancs
peut-être c'est d'avoir le bon cavalier
contre le mauvais fou qui est bloqué par
ces pions donc ça ça serait ça serait
l'idéal pour Prague d'un point de vue
stratégique euh bon on peut supposer que
grandéus il va tenter d'éviter ça mais
en tout cas il y a eu FPR F6 FPR F6 donc
moi ça m hyper logique he ce coup F F6
parce que en fait encore une fois sur
sur case noire il va pas se passer
grand-chose le pion le 5 et bloque
complètement tout case noir et du coup
les noirs vraent du mal à à à à bouger
leur pièces en tout cas moi j'aime
beaucoup PR6 de la part de Prague et je
pense que vraiment bel avantage pour les
blanc pr ou donc là il y a perire de fou
pour les Noirs ouais mais c'est pas un
avantage ici perire de fou pour les
Noirs mais la position est fermée et du
coup les fous ont beaucoup de mal à
s'exprimer eTTH et du coup c'est c'est
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué et euh
et euh bel avantage pour en tout pour
PRAG ici je pense en terme de stratégie
ce qu'on pourrait essayer de faire c'est
peut-être essayer d'aller changer les f
class blanche ce que je viens
d'expliquer tu m'écoutais pas en fait
voilà donc oui mais c'est pour ça que tu
vois le fou G4 disais je pense pas que
ce soit l'idée des Noirs en fait parce
que après fou G4 l'idée c'est que je
vais faire moi cavalier 2 comme tu l'a
montré prend de prend le de et c'est
pour ça que je pense que F4 c'est pas du
tout une bonne idée mais en tout cas
jouer cavalier contre fou ça peut être
viment une bonne idée ouais du
couu le fou noir c'est dur pour les noir
de trouver un plan je sais pas qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'il va jouer grand en
plus il est pas en confiance on a vu
hier qu'il avit pris beaucoup de
mauvaises décisions en milieu de jeu
contre
rapport donc quand tu as 05 sur 3 tu une
position dur à jouer en pratique
c'est assez prometteur pour PRAG qui
pourrait peut-être marquer son premier
point même si on est encore loin en tout
cas il a un bon
avantage positionnel du moins à voir si
s'il arrive à accélérer
ensuite
yes c'est la première fois qu'on tentend
dire de pas aimer la paire de fau bah
ouais mais quand la position est fermée
la paire de fau elle est pas active quoi
pourant tu aimes bien les chevaux aussi
je pense que les fourchettes raortter de
nombreuses victoires dans ta
carrière pour ne pas dire l'essentiel de
tes
victoires généralement généralement les
joueurs les joueurs d'attaque les tacti
bien les cavaliers c'est V une des
pièces qui vénère le plus aux échecs
mais ok ça dépend de la position en fait
ça dépend du caractère de la position si
la position est ouverte évidemment on
préfère les fous la position est fermée
évidemment on préfère les cavaliers donc
dans cette position bien que les les
fous noirs ont du mal vraiment à trouver
quelque chose à faire et et le Cavalier
Blanc va se régaler je pense donc il
vraiment changer les blanch et essayer
de mettre un cavalier sur une case
intéressante genre en C4 par exemple
ouais bon on va voir depuis C4 c'est d'
pour ça que que praganda voyez ne joue
pas C4 actuement parce que depuis tout à
l'heure il aurait pu jouer C4 pour
consolider vraiment renforcer son gros
centre de case blanche hein c'est
intéressant mais en fait il veut pas
faire ça parce que c'est cas c'est une
case pour le cavalier le pion est déjà
bien défendu tout va bien et le cavalier
depuis C4 et ben il pourra attaquer le
pion5 qui une faiblesse contrôler la
case D6 qu' un jour il pour peutêtre
avancer le pion et aussi attaquer B6
donc plus tard un plan se M cavalier en
C4 et pousser le pion aussi en A4 pour
sécuriser la case C4 du cavalier
empêcher B5 des noir pour chiser le
cavalier et un jour peut-être même jou
A5 et er attaquer la faiblesse B6 donc
il y a plein d'idées ça assez riche euh
vu que la position ici elle est fermée
et ben le roi blanc est en sécurité donc
le petit rock peut-être pourra être joué
un jour même s'il y a pas de pionage
c'est possible mais le roi esti très
très bien au centre pour l'instant il y
a pas de du tout de de de de problème
j'ai pas envie deire le pour
l'instants bien pense qu'avec les noirs
on va quand même essayer c'est le seul
plan que JIS peut-être un mon de jouer
F5 même si ça paraît difficile mais pour
essayer d'ouvrir un peu la position pour
les fous justement Mo la colonne pourour
parce que sinon commence activer en
fait si on fait pas ça même si ça ça
crée des affaiblissements donc c'est
c'est un cou est dangereux mais en même
temps j'ai du mal à trouver d'autres
d'autres idées pour les Noirs alors
alors effectivement les Noirs bon F5 ça
m'a l'air très très Gumble oua mais les
noirs doivent réagir donc on est
d'accord à ce niveau-là F5 en fait ça ça
l'air logique dans l'idée que on a la
part de fou du coup on veut ouvrir la
position mais F5 on voit que j'ai un peu
passé en D5 qui est dangereux les ces
blanches pourraent s'ouvrir là on voit
qu' plein de trous sur ce blanche ça
peut être difficile donc Fatou demande
dans le chat quel est le le but du Fou
de Ben pour l'instantit le fou il est
derrière les pions donc c'est pas la la
pièce qui va vraiment plus rayonner dans
la position mais l'idée serait
d'échanger éventuellement son fou de
contre le fou C8 ser vraiment la bonne
nouvelle pour Fr Valir le cavalier
contre le fou contre le mauvais fou
comme on l' expliqué après voilà il y a
un monde où un jour le fou peut s'ouvrir
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant on on
est loin mais c'est sûr que c'est une
pièce qui qui a un rôle plutôt défensif
et passif et on n pas vraiment de
diagonale pour l'améliorer nulle part
donc on va pas essayer de jouer
spécialement avec ce fou c'est pas
l'objectif c'est vraiment plus tard
selon l'évolution de la position on peut
pas en faire grand-chose c'est logique
le fou des noirs est mauvais parce qu' a
la structure sur cas noir et ben c'est
une forme de symétrie à ce momentlon a
un très beau pion passé certes mais
c'est qu' bloque la diagonale
ouis et puis et puis non mais le Fou est
quand même pas mal en faitand même pas
mal de bon
boulot on aussi la structure des
no5 il bloandme pions etôle
les garde vrai sur sur qui est pas
inutile
donc euh non non les blancs aussi ont un
bel avantage ils sont en maîtrise les
blancs eu ok donc on va voir dans les
prochaines minutes si Prague arrive à à
faire l'écart h qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
aller voir
ici peut-être peut-être mamedarov Douda
c'était cette fameuse finale comence à
évoluer il y avait des petites tactiques
allez vas-y
alors salut tevermant salut à toi alors
matin j'ai pensé à toi ce matin j'ai
j'ai bu un thé j'ai prière prè fois de
ta vie non comment c'est la première
fois de ta vie que tu bois du thé ou moi
je suis pas trop boisson chaude euh mais
j'ai j'ai été forcé parce que non mais
j'avais en fait j'ai j'ai j'ai vraiment
là ça va un peu mieux depuis que j'ai
Bué du coup mais j'ai beaucoup toussé
encore cette nuit et et ce matin mon
réveil tous beaucoup
encore donc il faut que je je fasse un
truc comme ça parce que ça ça va pas tu
prennes soin de ta petite gorge
oui pour tenir jusqu'au bout du du
tournoi donc entre Mamé et Douda on en
était resté là il venait d'y avoir qu'É
des C de jet et oui exactement il a
raison il a raison
remonte tu peux même mettre des petites
huiles essentielles dedans ça te fera du
et donc il y avait la menace he tour
c8ite comme on l'a montré tout à l'heure
de clouages sur le fou qui était
problématique et le petit prophylactique
3 B1 qui est
parti et ici à Doua s'est activé K5 et
c'est vrai que on avait plutôt des
craintes pour sa position la sortie de
l'ouverture avec son roi un petit peu au
milieu de l' Chiquet dans des colonnes
ouvertes j'ai l'impression que s'en est
très bien sorti je sais pas ce que tu en
penses mais il est en train de
d'équilibrer il va consolider en mettant
son ro F6 ensuite sortir son fou il sera
ok ouais non je pense que moi je je
préfère presque même les Noirs en fait
parce que le cavalier je il fait un peu
la gueule et si le noir vraiment arrive
à centraliser le pièce comme tu viens de
montrer donc donc le F du reculer et
évidemment F6 qui un C important
parisque ce cavalier en fait on veut le
consolidé car il va bloquer pour
l'instant la colonne fara quand même
faire attention il peut y avoir du F4
qui peut partir à tout moment tour 1 là
c'est ultra logique fait il a identifié
la cible et donc il menace F4 dans cette
position et il y a pas 36 solutions faut
défendre donc le pion E6 en prévision et
donc il a été joué tour8 par
Douda H qui qui ne s'affole pas ici euh
je pense qu' assez content de sa
position donc la menace CIT F4 comme tu
l'as souligné avec t 36 derrière donc du
coup tour8 bien défendre le pion voilà
et et sur F4 F4 c'est quand même un coup
qui qui qui quand Mme assz responsable
aussi parce que ça ça donne des cases ça
donne des CASAM
ouais parce que même si on aura H3 pour
chasser le cavalier par contre ça
affaiblirait beaucoup la colonne g ce
qui serait très dangereux donc c'est
vrai que ça donne et les cases E4 et les
cas G4 sur le long terme donc faut voir
F4 c'est un coup responsable comme tu
l'as dit et où on mettrait le cavalier
ici alors plôt en G6 plôt G4 même ici h
ouais non mais F4 c'est pas c'est je
pense que c'est un bon coup si vraiment
il y a un truc concret derrière sinon
c'est pas un coup tu vas tjours fa ouais
mais tu fais quoi tu as pas tu as quoi
comme idée ici avec les
BL ouais les les les Noirs vont finir
par fou C5 attaque le pion F2 et même si
tu bouges le pion en F3 euh j'aurais
toujours du Tour G8 et H4 attention
après F3 j'ai même du H4 qui avait les
bouges et H3 aussi dans C dans cette
position vous pouvez avoir l'impression
que le pion G2 bah il est ultra sécurisé
parce qu'il est caché mais en fait c'est
c'est la principale faiblesse des blancs
P G2 parce qu'il est dans une colonne
ouverte et que bah le cavalier qui
bloque devant il est pas stable du tout
il peut facilement se faire chasser et
donc il y a un monde où les les blancs
doivent se retrouver à amener une tour
passive pour défendre le pion G2 donc ça
peut être un problème dans quelques
coups ici pour
mierov on va voir comment il gère ça là
ça lui en tout cas il a vraiment placé
toutes ses pièces de façon petit mal n
parce que ce cavalier il est pas
extraordinaire peut-être il peut essayer
de le recycler mais bon toutes ces
pièces sont quand même assez bien
placées mais il y a rien de très concret
alors il vient de revenir à sa table
qu'est-ce qu'il va jouer F4 alors il y a
qu'est-ce que tu penses de F à 4 est-ce
que c'est une idée ici ou pas al F
déstabiliser la tour alors ici la
question c'est est-ce que jeoue tour7
est-ce que je joue cavalier C6 et
pourquoi pas je sais pas tour C8 par
exemple al tour C8 ok faut voir si j'ai
pas du F4 et fou D7 en fait cavalier C6
dans ce cas là pour D7 mais bon ça ça
peut rentrer hein en fait il est vrai
que il est vrai que le cavalier en5 qu
contôle la case D7
importante parce que c'est la case
d'entrée de la tour qui pourrait venir
chatouiller les pions A et B sur la 7e
ouais donc du coup c qui est plutôt bien
placé mais F4 c'est un coup qui assez
comite moi je pense que il va devoir
passer par là en fait parce que ce
cavalier il est trop fort donc4 va
tomber à un moment donné est-ce que VO
il va d'abord intégrer ce petit à 4 un
petit peu vicieux là pour poser des
problèmes pratiques ou envoyer direct
après il peut doubler he plus
modestement mais il abandonnerait la
colonne
D bon je vois ma de façon plus énergique
ici ouais ouais donc là réfléchit ça
fait combien de temps qu'il réfléchit à
ce coupl bah ça fait pas longtemps je
crois qu'il vient de se rasseoir il
vient de d'accord et euh ok bon on va
voir en tout cas il y a des possibilités
en c'est encore pas clair mais j'ai une
petite préférence noir dans c parti
quand même ah moi qu j'irais pas jusqu
je préfère encore les blancs mais je
trouve que les Noirs
ont plutôt bien négocié la sortie
d'ouverture qui pouvait s'apparenter moi
j'aime bien ce cavali 5 et j'aime bien
les idée de de fou C5 et H4 qui peuvent
arriver sur le cavalier de qui est mal
placé en fait j'ai clairement si on
compare les pièces j'ai un cavalier qui
est nettement meilleur que le tien ouais
mais il va pas il passer sa life ici
quoi bien sûr mais après F4 et ben tu as
des problèmes sur G2 tu as aussi sur la
case case F2 E3 parce que M après si
j'ai un coup C5 je jou F4 que je fais
cavalier G4 je pe venir en F2 venir en
E3 attaquer le H2 je trouve que c'est
c'est c'est compliqué mais de générale
préfère je préfère les noir le résultat
le plus probable ça reste bien sûr la
nul ici parce que la position est quand
même équilibrée mais si tu veux moi j'ai
une petite pièce sur mamedarov et toi
sur sur douudda mais bon ok il devrait y
avoir la nulle pour pour nous départager
quand même non c'est assez éégal c'est
là c'est une question de de de point de
vue hein ouais
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'on ah tiens j'ai
vu que juste un petit tour on repasse
par par Magnus puisque V Forest a joué
le l'idée que tu as suggéré mon cher
stuff ce fameux coup de fou E4 voilà la
partie a pas énormément évolué il a
juste eu deux coups mais intéressant de
noter donc fou E4 a été joué il y a pas
eu fou H3 comme tu en parlais peut-être
ça va venir ensuite mais dame 2 dans un
premier temps et
E6 bon on une position lente priori
parti qui risque de durer longtemps je
pense mais on va le voir le H3 arver
c'est hyper normal un moment donné
alorsre maintenant ici moi je le vois
bien
ou ça fait sens tu vois il VI pourquoi
parce que il sait
que bon déjà c'estp logique parceon
communiquer entre
parlid avec H3 et cavalier D2 où il y
avait le le fou des TR des Noirs qui
était possible avec Dame 2 maintenant et
ben je contrôle la case euh la case D3
du Fou et du coup il peut plus faire fou
D3 maintenant que j'ai dame 2 donc du
coup dame 2 et là je pense qu'on peut
préparer un petit foie je crois
exactement ça ça c'est une idée dans la
position on va voir si si Magnus te
suit est-ce que tu nous ferais pas un
petit stream en chaussette pignoir la
prochaine fois ti sur ta chaîne bien sûr
atts j'ai un bug avec twitch j'arrive
plus à me connecter depuis tout à
l'heure je vois pas le chat au
chat ça qu'est-ce qui se passe t Vermond
te propose peut-être de passer au
clquage chaussette PIR pour ton prochain
stream pour continuer tes bonnes
résolution de janvier je pense que ça
pourrait attirer des des spectateurs et
des spectatrices donc les gars du coup
si vous voulez on peut en profiter de
cette de ce petit tu vas faire de la
pube c'est ça non non non pour pour non
pas du tout euh pour vous annoncer une
une une nouvelle concernant St et
euh et et et les prochains streams alors
en fait du coup stouf a décidé je parle
la trè personne bizre de parler de soi à
la trème personne surtout quand ton
pseudo c'est Stouff quoi en fait quand
tu t'appelles Louis 14
bon c'est plus dans dans le thème quoi
j'arrive pas connecté à twitch je sais
pas ce qui se passe j'ai été banni je
crois qu'on on m'a banni je crois Stouff
a été banni de de
twitchoup plus connecté à son
compte bref tu tu allais annoncé que tu
vas rentrer bi je je te laisse le faire
peut-être le faire Europe je vais
rentrer en Europe très bientôt dans euh
on est le combien on est 18 dans un mois
dans pile dans pile un mois je suis je
suis en France
donc je rentre à Nice première chose par
voulezattendre à l'aéroport de Nice vous
connaissez la
date le
jeudi non je parle 1 j'arrive on te
demande si expulsé c'est c'est une
hypothèse fa il est en Argentine alexon
notre ami je suis en Argentine et je
rentre je rentre dans un mois et et par
contre je vais rester que 10 jours en
France avant un nouveau départ alors non
je ne pars pas en Alemagne toujours pas
on est déçu Fatou
F être déçu je suis vraiment désolé pour
toi je sais que tu tu tu tu tu espéris
ce retournement de mais non je suis
désolé non je n'irai pas en Allemagne
c'est pas pour moi euh je vais rester
dans le côté hispanique et je vais
partir au Canaris alors vous savez que
j'aime beaucoup les Canaris je suis allé
beaucoup de fois j'ai je connais
beaucoup de gens là-bas et je vais aller
m'installer euh au Canaris pour quelques
mois en tout cas pour commencer et là le
gros avantage par rapport à l'Argentine
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça en fait que
j'ai vraiment envie de rentrer en en
Europe c'est que ben j'ai j'ai des
problèmes de connexion ici et euh et
aussi j'ai pas mon ordinateur mon vrai
ordi mon gros ordi lequel je peux bien
stream et euh tout mon matériel en fait
et ben il est en France et et là du coup
bah la Canarie c'est une île mais je
prends le bateau donc du coup jeis
prendre ma voiture donc j'aurai ma
voiture j'aurai mon mon ordinateur
j'aurai mon micro j'aurai tous mes trucs
tous mes mon matériel et je pourrais
restream enfin comme comme à la belle
époque et non enfin juste streamer bien
quoi parce que là c'est vrai que avec ma
connexion un peu bizarre mon ordi
portable j'ai qu'un écran j'ai le chat
sur le téléphone bref c'est un peu
compliqué et pour stream ben c'est c'est
pas des conditions optimales et du coup
bientôt très bientôt et ben je pourrai
je pourrais euh revenir et streamer euh
comme comme avant donc ça c'est prévu
pour à peu près un mois tu tu auras des
des visiteurs et des visiteuses
peut-être je crois au Canaris euh dans
le Chatin et euh c'est vrai que moi les
Canaris je connais pas mal aussi puis
qu'on a fait pas mal de tournois d'échec
he là-bas on était invité au moins
quatre en toi plus que moi du coup tu y
allais plus souvent mais euh les chèqus
sont très démocratisés euh notamment à à
lapalmas hein même à tenerif aussi mais
plus à lapalmas peut-être et il y a
beaucoup de compétition
a même beaucoup d'échecs dans les écoles
donc c'est assez assez sympa quand tu
joueurs d'échec d'habiter là-bas bon
bien sûr il y a la plage et tout donc
ouais c'est une
destination qui me semble correcte on
ira de voir on ira de voir en attendant
on va retourner
à à notre ronde 4 et du coup là j'ai mis
la partie de Carana contre
doub ah je crois que tu as freeze alors
tu fais très très bien la la statue de
cè là c'est c'est une performance on va
tu vas on va tu vas recevoir beaucoup de
pièces je pense
mais moi tuas tuas tu fre dans une
position CCI qui te met plutôt à ton
avantage c'est pas mal c'est pas mal on
va attendre que tu que tu reviennes
parmi nous je pense d'ici quelques
secondes
h pas d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
m'entendez encore j'ai l'impression que
des petits bugs
petit bug de caméra c'est Google meet du
cou a d disparaître notre ami
stouf notre stouf qui a disparu du coup
on a une une faux caméra
je crois qu' a disparu du Google meet
donc du coup vu que les caméras sont sur
sur Google meet ça fait tout
buger on va on va attendre on va voir
s'il revient on VO plus est-ce que vous
voyez encore les éch quand même ou pas
c'est la
question alors j'essaie de le récupérer
sur
Facebook c'est un petit peu
problématique
ici je crois que sa connexion a rendu
lame
ouais vous voyez ch pas le commentateur
OK ou bah c'est logique he c'est assez
logique vu que vu que la le CO Google
meet a disparu et que les commentateurs
sont dessus on va attendre que reviennne
euh qui repaye son forfait de de mobile
et le revoilà stou est désolé le revoilà
notre ami stou
j'ai en fait j'ai des problèmes de
connexion comme je vous l'avais annoncé
et c'est pour ça que je vais vite
rentrer parce que j'en peux plus c'est
un truc de fou non mais je je c'est trop
compliqué je ne veux pas stream
normalement je peux même pas être sur un
vocal du coup là tu es sur t sur ton
mobile ou non mais là j'ai partagé la
connexion sur mon téléphone mais bon en
franchement genre je suis branché au
modem de du de la box quoi et j'arrive
pas j'arrive pas c'est horrible la
connexion Argentine
complexe c'est euh du coup je suis
désolé tout ça en tout cas donc je vais
en Argentine pour ceux et surtout celles
qui ont envie de me rendre visite au
canari mais mais oui voilà euh retour du
coup on en était à cette partie carwana
contre contre dubof
h c'était pas mal interroger là c'était
un peu bizarre ce pion A4 là qui avait
été encaissé du coup par par doubof
c'est ça ouais on avait du mal à trouver
une idée pour les blancs puce que je
crois que la suggestion principale Ctait
fou C4 qui était pas du tout
naturel et du coup il a joué fou
B1 donc il menace de récupérer son pion
carwana fou B1 wouh ah fou C2 et donc le
fou qui va sûrement en cas de fou C6
c'est la partie peut-être pouvoir
revenir en C2 si vraiment l'objectif
c'est de récupérer spion
A4
ah c'est une colle que tu nous poses
Alex Verson dans le chat tu vois
toujours pas le le chat St si si ok je
sais pas c'est une réponse à cette
question comment achetter utilisé
actuellement par la F pour
ben alors la référence déjà je sais pas
si alors je sais je n'ai pas la
référence donc là je sais pas quel
exactement mais après je sais que c'est
DGT alors DGT tu peux
marquer en fait qui retransmett sur sur
Internet attends c'est
quoijuc peux trouver un truc
mais
mais tu peux trouver un peu
[Musique]
partout je sais pas exactement quel est
le format quel est le le mais
mais là j'ai un lien là ou je pense
qu'en grattant tu dois pouvoir trouver
une fois que tu as la r ça do pas être
si compliqué j'imagine moi il y a celui
qui est juste très bien je dans le
chat c'est le gros
lienmite 500 at je peux pas l'envoyer le
message même si je suis mod c'est parce
que ton lien est trop gros là je pense
tuas faut que tu vires tout
le toutes les lettres en trop mais bon
ok mais oui variante deopéra tu vas sur
Internet ouais sur variante c'est bien
ouais après il y a aussi le il y a aussi
le le la le la boutique Debac oui bien
sûr tu peux aller sur Alpha échec tu do
avir plein d' chiqu il y a sûrement la r
même peut-être tu peux poser la
question là-bas mais tu tu dois pouvoir
trouver ton bonheur facilement je pense
ouais mais euh é chequ d GT après il y a
plusieurs sets possibles ouais euh c'est
vraiment euh je sais pas lequel est
utilisé actuellement on a les caméras un
peu sur les joueurs mais euh mais je
sais pas vraiment euh lequel est utilisé
mais en tout cas etquier DGT c'est eu
ouais après tu peux l'acheter tu as deux
trucs différents tu peux l'acheter avec
vraiment les euh les câbles et tout et
les puces à l'intérieur des pièces pour
vraiment transmettre plôt sur sur
Internet
ça tu peux le faire et ça ça coûte assez
cher par contre et sinon tu peux aussi
acheter les chquers sans avoir les puts
je tu as juste très beau et cetera et
voilà après çap ce que tu veux y faire
parce que tu peux très bien jouer même
sur internet sur chesscom tu peux jouer
avec les Ch ça Mar c'est vrai c'est vrai
alors je te conseille pas en bulette
mais en bulette c'est compliqué il fa
jouer les deux coups blanc et noir mais
tu peux avoir ton vrai chqu devant toi
et le configurer sur sur chesscom et en
fait tu peux jouer au vrais échec un vra
toi tu bouges les pièces et en fait se
rend compte des des pièces que tu V
déplacer quoi inéressant et ça ça peut
vous entraîner aussi pas mal parce que
vous savez que le but quand même de sur
Internet c'est quand même de progresser
au vrais échecs et les vrais échecs et
ben quand même en présentiel sur un
vraier donc ça permet aussi de prendre
l'abitude à jouer sur un vra c'est
intéressant Mar on vaer on va aller le
voir ouais on va finir vite fait sur ce
Fabi doubov donc Fabi il a envoyé des C
direct serait un beau cadeau je pour
faire pour ton
anniversairet ça pourrait faire un beau
cadeau à Fatou
effectivement je pense que le jour où
Fatou elle va ouvrir sa chaîne twitch je
pense qu'on pourra peut-être tous se
cotiser pour
envoyer plein de petit sub pour qu'elle
puissecheter un je pense ça pe pas mal
for si tu es d'accord avec moi je pense
que on va essayer de
taperer là-dessus cavalier B3 ok pr
prise en D4 et donc on nous demande
quiier B3 alors est-ce que cavier B3 est
en coup
ici h il y a peut-être un problème quand
même c'est que bon admettons par exemple
l'échange il y a spion E5 qui est pas
protégé donc je pense qu'il faut quand
même d'abord régler euh le problème de
spion E5 qui est en
prise je sais pasmettons prise prise
prise prise on va quand même repèdre ce
pion et on peut même peut-être être
encore plus malin et laisser la tour
commencer par manger le
5 en disant si mange la tour on va
manger F6 ah ça peut être vraiment très
dangereux parce que sur je pr F6 il y a
le fou qui va aller en H6 donc pour
l'instant on a une qualité de moins ok
certes avec les blancs mais il y a la
tour qui attaquer donc on va essayer de
voir juste si la tour bouge par exemple
admettons tour B8 il risque d'y avoir
une attaque quand même tout toutes les
pièces ça va être très dangereux pour le
pour le roi noir donc ce cavalier en
pour l'instant il pas du tout et
cavalier qui va arriver en F5 la dame
qui va libérer il y a ce fou qui en B1
qui est pas innocent parce qu'on
n'hésitera pas à pousser il y a trop de
trop de danger je pense que le roi noir
il va pas survivre ici donc c'est un
coup intéressant mais je pense que pour
cette raison là ça va pas marcher cahier
B3 faut d'abord résoudre ce ce problème
ici
ouais et d'ailleurs ça fait penser un
petit peu à une partie de championat de
France que j'avais vu championat de
France adulte en contre romain Douard
avec les Blancs contre Vlad katf à
l'époque où Vlad était pas encore
retraité et il y avait eu dans une
espagnol il espagnol j'avis vu un
cavalier B3 cavalier pr A1 ou
romain edard prendre la tour en exprès
mais av maté très très
vite
Vlad mais mais ouais c une partie
intéressante un peu le même genre de
thème où il avait eu un
un a une attaque très rapide c'était il
y a très longtemps il y a peut-être 10
ans parce que effectivement je m'en
rappelle si on commence par prendre B3
raison tu as peut-être raison
zoo là c'est peut-être ok pour les Noirs
puisqueon avait un pion de plus donc
juste on repère le pion et c'est pas si
grave mais par contre l'autre variante
qu'on a vu où on sacrifie la tour a
l'air très prometteuse pour les blancs
oua et donc dans la partie juste il a
joué à CH ici il a posé la question au
faut de prendre une décision si on mange
bah très bien mon pion sera défendu et
sil recule bah il estime que avoir
intercalé H6 x H4 sera toujours utile
pour lui il aura peut-être moins de
problèm d'ailleurs comme dans la vari
qu'on vient de voir d'attaque et il
pourra prendre une nouvelle décision à
ce moment-l et salut Pierro salut Patou
alors Patouche qui arrive en retard il
il il arrive après les les confessions
de ça va pour avoir le replay je suis
sûr que tu les répèteras les confessions
je suis pas très répter après on aur
droit une version bis alors pas tout
c'est si tu regardes un petit peu le
replay peut-être 10 minutes en arrière à
peu près ben tu pourras tu pourras
essayer de voir ce que j'ai cro je crois
que tu as appelé tu as appelé Pierro
Fatou mais tu vois Fatou partout j'ai
l'impression ah peut-être excuse-moi
mais je suis comme ça c'est son
anniversaire aujourd'hui fou je vous
rappelle les gars aujourd'hui c'est la
saatou alors c'est son anniversaire faut
vraiment la la félicité je veux du Fatou
partout sur le chat les gars je veux des
Fatou sur le chat de partout
atts on a une longue question de T
verment alors qu'est-ce qui nous demande
quand je vois des parties de ce niveau
malgré vos commentaires j'en ai mal à la
tête car bien trop compliqué pour un
1500 tilt comme moi même en tant que
spectateur est-ce que ce qui fait la
différence c'est uniquement la
compréhension complète du jeu des
positions les années de travail le
talent les trois en même
temps B c'est sûr que expérience déjà
c'est une chose que si tu joues aux
échecs depuis quelques semaines quelques
mois même un an seulement forcément tu
as vu beaucoup moins de positions que
nous ou d'autres joueurs de notre niveau
donc bah ton cerveau il reconnaît moins
vite des schémas ou même des schémas
plein de schémas lui sont encore
inconnus donc déjà ça forcément ça ça ça
procure bah un temps de latence dans la
compréhension des enjeux et cetera bah
qui qui va être plus
compliqué après je pense que bah déjà tu
as un niveau quand même tu comprends des
choses tu comprends tu peux comprendre
un peu ce qui se passe même si des fois
il y a des subtilités qui peuvent
t'échapper de temps en
temps mais bon plus tu vas progresser
plus les parties du top niveau te
sembleront moins obscur je pense
et après faut bien prendre le temps
aussi d'essayer de de se poser les
bonnes questions h pas être trop dans le
calcul en fait c'est calculer des
variantes euh tu comprends pas en fait
du coup et essaie de te demander à
chaque fois bah quelle pièce est bien
placée essaie de de voir pourquoi quelle
pièce est passive quelle pièce est
active essayer de trouver les les
faiblesses dans la position de regarder
les pions des deux camps est-ce qu'il y
en a qui sont sur des colonnes ouvertes
donc facile à cibler est-ce qu'il y en a
qui sont un peu isolés un peu trop
avancés a plein de petites questions à
te poser qui font que normalement bah
petit à petit tu devrais mieux
comprendre les enjeux des positions et
les parties même si parfois c'est
subtile là c'est vrai que la variante
qu'on a vu avec cavalier l le sacrifice
c'était assez complexe mais c'est pas
toujours comme ça non plus
ouais bah c'est normal qu'il des
subtilités qui t'cha à nous aussi
d'ailleurs mais même à eux aussi parce
que sinon il y aurait que des nuls s'il
y avait aucune subtilité qui n'échappait
à personne il aurait que des parties
entre guillemets parfaites et et pas de
résultat
décisif le principal c'est au fur à
mesure de voir le plus de choses et
surtout les choses essentielles dans la
position donc vraiment les bonnes pièces
les mauvaises pièces et un petit peu la
structure les possibilités d'attaque tu
vas voir que petit à petit tes idées
vont vont
s'affiner si tu veux rajouter quelque
chose TR par rapport à tout ça mais non
non mais je suis d'accord je su d'accord
après voilà comme moi je rejos vraiment
Sam sur le fait que la tactique dans les
parties qu'on regarde ici c'est vraiment
pas que ça plus à ce niveaul on est
plutôt sur des manœuvres sur on pe la
coméhension du jeu et et tout ça donc je
pense qu'en tout cas parce que la
tactique c'est facile l'ordinateur tu
regardes ce qui se passe et cetera mais
là on va d'expliquer les les plans de
l'un et de l'autre et comprendre un peu
ce que qu'on va essayer de faire de
manière général dans les parties
donc là d'ailleurs on on a montré le CP
cavalet B3 qui est intéressant cette
idéeon peut des fois même laisser du
matériel pour attaquer par
là-basou pour expliquer ça différent
même sans vraiment tout calculer sur un
coup comme cavalier B3 tu peux ne pas
être sûr que ton attaque va aboutir en
fait même là nous quand on regarde il y
a pas de mat concret en ligne si tu veux
juste on va se dire que dans cette
variante donc juste en passant un peu
plus vite voilà cette position on sait
pas exactement est-ce qu'elle est
gagnante on sait pas instantanément mais
on sent en fait que le roi il est quand
même extrêmement faible bon après c'est
classique quand il y a cette
piè blanch là c'est presque des
mathématiques compes le nombre
d'attaquants potentiel je mets tout ça
parce que toi la tour elle peut
facilement rejoindre l'attaque le
cavalier on a vu qu'il allait aller en
F5 et contre les défenseurs chez les
Noirs bah le roi il est livré à lui-même
donc on a peut-être 5 attaquants contre
un roi qui a plus de bouclier puisquil a
été cassé et il est tout seul donc là il
y a pas besoin de calculer à tout prix
jusqu'au bout juste tu dois te dire ok
bah je vais tenter et j'ai normalement
beaucoup de perspec
et ça devrait aboutir même si tu es pas
capable de calculer encoreah comme un
joueur beaucoup plus fort faut aussi
essayer de développer ton intuition quoi
plus tu vas sentir le jeu plus tu vas
être appelé dans les bonnes directions
prendre les les bonnes décisions les
bons plans parce que effectivement c'est
quand même complexe bien sûr ce qu'on
regarde ici bah oui c'est c'est parti de
niveau mais en revenant au bas juste en
comptant le nombre d'attaquants et de
défenseurs bah finalement genre il a 50
bah sur un terrain de sport quelconque
où là c'est plus simple bah juste tu te
fais despes rentre dans le but avec le
ballon bah là aux échecs ça va être un
peu la même chose en fait le gardien il
est tout seul ici il a pu il a pu son
mur devant lui donc par la force des
choses ça devrait aboutir à un mat une
attaque de ma
h je te propose qu'on qu'on aille voir
comme on l'a promis notre ami ouais Marc
Andria notre petit français alors la
partie a pas mal
évolué on en était euh on en était
où on était à CAH B4 pour aller manger
ce ce fou et on a dit que certainement
il allait le laisser ce fou il avait pas
le recul de et il nous a écouté il a
joué fou à 3 donc intéressant il veut
échanger ses quatre pièces et c'est dire
mon cavalier va être supérieur à ton fou
C vite
ouais ce qui est certainement vrai un
peu le même genre que la partie de
Prague au final oui bah en tout cas il a
cette idée de supériorité du cavalier
sur le fou dans une autre
structure alors il prise en D3 dame
prend D3 prise en à3 dame prend à 3 donc
tous ces échanges qui étaient
relativement forcés h et donc fou D7 il
veut essayer de sortir sa dernière pièce
le mettre en C6 il sera peut-être pas si
simple cavalier E5 a été jou 5 très
logique il se place au centre tour c'est
C8 et tour
C1 les Blancs ont fini leur
développement ouais
et attention que le pion B en prise et
le fou aussi donc là on peut pas jouer
dame D8 à cause de cavaler prend D7 le
forcer dame D8 for ch dam d do rester à
la défense du Fou et il a mangé le pion
à Mar and pas de bluff il dit ok mais
par contre il va peut-être perdre A4
ouais il a fait tour PR7 mais après il y
aura F en l'air donc c'est calul a aussi
d en
l'air
c'est une séquence un peu tactique en a
qui arrive là je
CIS va être joué je pense c'est en train
pr C1 prend4 t prend F7 d prend D4 alors
attends pas tu vas trop vite tu vas trop
vite pour ouis non je je te coupou j'ai
bien coupris mais il y a deux
possibilitésjà il peut commencer par
manger là peut-être ouais je peux manger
comme ça aussi manger là alors on va
regarder plus évident c'est peut-être
prendre sur échec pour détourner la dame
de la défense du pion et manger à 4
alors qu'est-ce que ça donne ici le
problème c'est qu'il y a F7 qui tombe
peut-être alors la question c'est déjà
avec quoi on mange F7 avec la tour ou
avec le cavalier ça l'air assez complexe
comme position h je sais pas quelle est
ton intuition de prendre plutôt du
cheval ou ou de la
tour bah si tu prend de la tour il y a
d'un prend des qu et le cavalier
t'attaquer et si tu bouges le cavalier
bah tu perds la tour parce que la tour
c'est défendu par montrer quand même
tour prend là il a dame prend des4 et il
y a une autre chose qui est importante
dans cette position c'est ouais la
première rangée qui est très faible et
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
hyper important auquel vous devez faire
attention dans toutes vos parties ce
fameux thème de mat du couloir parce que
maintenant la dame B si si le pion était
en H3 la dame elle pourrait aller
joindre la l'attaque par dame G5 et il y
aurait une menace de mat parce qu'on
défend qui serait quasi imparable parce
que sur G6 on ferit dame F6 et on matait
donc là Marc and il serait gagnant si il
y avait pas ce mat du couloir qui
traînait qu'il pouvait abriter son roi
donc malheureusement ça ruine ici toutes
ses possibilités d'attaque et c'est lui
qui va se retrouver avec des problèmes
avec un peu toutes ces pièces attaqué on
voit qu'il a peut-être des idées de
perpétuel en sacrifiant la tour mais pas
forcément ce qu'on
veut donc on va revenir en arrière dans
position et calier pr F7 ou ça va être
peut-être et bon il y a pas de Mo pour
les noirs c plus envie mais c'est t
cette première rangée moi qui me pose
problème cette
faiblesse 4 qui est en priseion qui peut
quand même devenir aussi extrêmement
dangereux
voir bah apporter la victoire au noir
dans une position comme ça plus tard
donc il va falloir trouver des
compensations concrètes sur le roi donc
c'est vraiment une position à double
tranchant ici après il est pas obligé de
manger le pion non
plus
en priseah attention à tour C8 dame B2
du coup
dame3 mais mais il manque un peu de
temps pour pour V lancer l'attaque puis
après
les intéressant aussi F venir défendre
ce pion F7 donc ça peut un c un peu
faible d' c'est une possibilité ici si
on veut pas manger le pion on peut jouer
F4 dam Bou parler de la8 pour pousser le
oui oui mais mais mais même ici c'est
pas débile en fait peut-être parce que
tu as un tour Mo mais tu dis tu vas
peut-être le récupérer tuactiver il y a
quand même plein plein de possibilités
ici je pense ça reste pas clair
Ouaiss on voir est-ce qu'il y a eu dans
la partie ah oui bah ça va être
intéressant on y va tout droit il y a eu
fou prend 4 de jouer ah non il a joué
donc comme je disais au début
elle a joué pardon la joueuse chinoise
elle a elle a pas commencé par manger la
tour alors elle a commencé par manger le
pion alors on va voir pourquoi ouais
c'est possible aussi dans ce dans cette
si je prend F7 maintenant avec la tour
c'est quoi la différence avec tourcien
d'cien et d' des4 c'est la même chose
alors juste pour répondre au passage
pardon à Biblos merci déjà pour ton
message et n nos élos actuelsouf je sais
pas si tu veux le dire du coup mais bon
tu es passé sous les 2300 mais c'est pas
ta valeur he parce que tu étais bah très
proche des 2400 jusque il y a quelques
mois avec trois normes de matre et moi
ça fa bien longtemps que j'ai pas joué
ave depuis le covid en fait donc j'ai
environ 2360 j'aurais même pas dire
précisément voilà pour répondre à ta
question et donc de retour à cette
position qui un peu complexe donc elle a
décidé zo de d'abord manger en A4 alors
juste bien sûr on peut pas manger le fou
que c'est le drame le mat du couloir
qu'on va à tout pr éviter et St
qu'est-ce qui si je commence par manger
la
tour al C8 alors déjà est-ce que
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas prendre de la
dame en disant je t'attaque ta tour et
ah non je menace pas mat pour l'instant
donc ça marche ah7 ok non mais là il y a
pas il y a pas la
cass du coup c'est un peu bête donc ok t
reprends donc le Fou est toujours tabou
on peut pas on peut pas le manger et
qu'est-ce qui se passe maintenant
cavalier prend F7 je pense que c'est
comme tout à l'heure dame prend D4 d
prend D4 mais du coup là D1 H3 on mat
donc sûrement H3 pour parer le mat du
couloir d PR4 c'est non non le le sujet
àou je trollis Biblos parce que
justement il vient de perdre son point
alors qu'il était au porte du titre de
ami donc donc c'est juste que c'est pas
un sujet qui lui fait très plaisir notre
stouf oui j'avais j'avais 2390 avec 4
normes de M donc en fait j'étais à 10
points de passé mare international et
j'ai fait une série de tournois pendant
les pendant cet été où en fait j'ai
perdu 100 points du coup ça s'est très
très mal passé du coup je veux plus
parler de mon élo par que tu es un
habitué du du yoyo aussi donc ouais tu
as plutôt une carrière où tu tu as des
gros pics de forme et de moins bonne
forme donc voilà ça va ça va rebondir
dans le bon sens on peut
espérer voilà donc du coup c'est pour ça
que ici on ne parle pas Deo merci alors
on me demande si les mates du couloir
sont déjà arrivés à très haut niveau
alors je sais pas si bon alors en blitz
évidemment après en parti lente le jour
est pas forcément allé jusqu'à se faire
mater mais il a mais oui ils ont perdu
plusieurs fois à cause de combinaison
avec ce thème de mat du couloir non mais
j'ai vu ça ça existe championnat du
monde de de de Blitz bah oui ou Blitz
c'est standard qui qui a comme ça ouais
il y a une histoire comme ça ouais oui
il y avait un joueur arménien donc je
sais plus les nom parce que je sais qu'
ouais Dino mais un joueur à 2650 he qui
a qui s'est fait mat en un coup et je
crois que c'est contre doubbof ou un
truc comme ça ouais et il s'est pris un
M en un coup du couloir B oui mais c'est
pas
étonnant il y a la fatigue en fait juste
ça fait que tu
peuxou a beaucoup de parties mais bon 26
50 quand même ouii mais même en Pary
land c'est le grand corch je plus contre
qui c'était qui avait perdu une partie
donc vraiment classique pu à l'époque où
corchna il faisait partie des meilleurs
joueurs du monde à cause du mat de
couloir alors il se l'était pas pris
mais juste il joue un coup bah c'est
réfuté en un coup parce que il y a le
mat du couloir qui qui à Nil donc VO ça
c'est un exemple juste que je connais
parce que la partie est assez célèbre
mais je su sûr qu'il y en a plein dans
l'histoire des échecs he parce que ça
reste un thème en fait récurrent donc il
fait d'une absence d'une seconde et et
on personne à l'abri hein alors je crois
pas que c'était Aronian par contre non
mais Aronian il est plus à il est il est
plus oui il est amériicano arménien
maintenant ouais ouais il est passé sur
le sur le le drapeau américain mais non
c'éit un joueur à 2650 alors je sais
plus mais c un
jeune martyan ou autre oui je crois que
c'est lui là je crois lu que j'ai vu
j'ai vu la vidéo il était là je crois
que c'est lui qui il se mat un coup
j'arrive plus à te dire contre qui je
pense c'était contre un un mec vraiment
fort mais ok ok mais bon oui voilà pour
vous dire faut Pasut pas vous inquiéter
si ça vous arrive
connais des fourchettes en
échec j'ai pas pas forcément compris la
subtilité les échc
les fourchettes fourchette c'est quand
on attaque plusieurs pièces à la fois
merci stou C éclairage définition de
fourchette aux échec alors est-ce qu'il
y avait une blague sous ta question ça
je ne sais pas peut-être et ou il y a
ronian qui est sous sous pavillon
américain euh mais bon il est peut-être
arrivé un peu tard sil est pas au pic de
sa carrière là Levon qui est quand même
un très fort joueur mais plutôt sur la
phase descendante à priori hein
d'ailleurs il est pas qualifié au
candidat il a pas fait les derniers non
plus euh bon je sais pas sil aura de
nouveau sa chance he bon lui souhaite
hein mais ça paraî un peu complexe même
si on a vu que champion du monde Deb
pouvait encore très bien jouer euh il
s'est écroulé sur la fin mais bon après
je pense qu'il a des conditions aux
États-Unis qui font que c'était une
offre difficile à refuser pour lui il a
bien fait il a bien fait pas s que
c'était compliqué pour lui en Arménie
dernièrement je crois donc
ouais mais bon est-ce que est-ce qu'il y
a eu un coup ou pas alors je réactualise
non on on est toujours à fou prend à4 il
réfléchit alors on voit que dans toutes
ces parties Marc Andria il est très
souvent is not là il a encore 30 minutes
de retard euh bon I C'est pas encore
très grave parce que ça devrait se
décomter dans les prochains coups ouais
mais peut-être quand même pour sa
progression c'est aussi quelque chose en
terme de de gestion du temps il doit
travailler un peu je pense
h et al on demande si t prend plutôt
cavalier alors oui c'est une très bonne
question donc si t reprend F7 tout de
suite on on l'a pas regardé ça peut-être
ouais mais t pr C1 d' prend C1 et d'un
prend4 ça transpose donc ça va
transposer effectivement dans ce qu'on
regardait tout à l'heure ou si la j
chinoise avait mangé en C1 direct et
donc là dans cette situation en fait euh
bah on a vu qu'il y avait ce problème de
mat du couloir donc attaquer le roi et
la seule solution ce serait certainement
de sacrifier la tour pour donner un
échec perpétuel parce que comme sou si
le cavalier bouge bah juste la tour est
perdue on peut pas vraiment défendre le
cavalier sans abandonner la première
rangée le pion est cloué donc la seule
solution serait tour pr G7 alors on peut
regarder rapidement donc on sacrifie la
tour pour dénuder le roi noir et après
l'échec en G5 alors
on voit qu'ici il y aurait un joli mat
àtouff qui fait toujours plaisir ça ça
va pas arriver le mat de route chinoise
qui est beaucoup trop forte donc elle
irait c'est pas impossible que la partie
continue comme ça et se termine par la
nul
vrai option tout à fait possible aur
dame F6 échec bon comme ça on voit que
on répète et si jamais le roi essaie de
s'enfuir vers8 alors il y aura un petit
problème al si voulez un peu réfléchir
ici parce que c'est une position où il y
a plein de possibilités on pourrait
gagner avec les Blancs alors comment on
gagne
ouais je sais pas si vous avez des idées
dans le chat on vous laisse un petit
moment donc ou il est bien GM ce gars là
donc c'est c'est un jeune homme ou 14
ans bah c'est le plus jeune grand maître
français de l'histoire il a détrôné ma
Maxime V grave donc F7 et cavalier C6
Arnaud il faut que tues un petit peu
plus attention tu es pas loin mais il y
a il y a un ennemi là qui contrôle la
case
ouais alors les joueurs les joueurs
jouent encore ah je crois que pasatouche
il a trouvé il est fort ce
Patouche et pasatouche il est pasatouche
il est est-ce que est-ce que dam ici est
un est un coup pour aller manger la tour
alors déjà juste avant de de parler de
ça si tu
veux en terme de de de méthode hein
quand vous cherchez des des coup
gagnants comme ça ouais généralement le
conseil que je peux vous donner c'est de
regarder en premier tour les échecs
parce que en fait là vous voyz bien on a
une tour de moins et et le roi noir est
en de l'échequer donc si je fais pas
d'échec et bien il va pouvoir me mater
ou il va il va pouvoir se défendre qu'il
veut et en gros en premier on va
regarder les échecs des blancs donc là
même lesb faut le regarder donc là bon
dam8 dame 7 dame D8 on se rend compte
que bon ben ça donne quand même
uneidamment un coup pas les meilleurs
nou mais bon il faut quand même des fois
regarder ça peut ça peut arriver et
sinon dame F7 et dame H8 sont les deux
échecs il y a aussi d PR6 he par c'est
possible ouais euh trois échecs qui ne
donnent qui perd pas la dame en fait en
un coup donc on
peuter en priorité
ouais après moi j'ai un conseil aussi
très important à vous donner euh en
terme de tactique celle qui très très
largement parce que j'en voie énormément
des parties de joueurs Mme même pas que
débutants du tout he 1000 jusqu'à 1600
et même plus ha en fait le thème qui est
le plus récurrent dans les parties
d'échec en général c'est celui des
vis-à-vis alors les vis-à-vis peut en
avoir dans plein de sens est-ce que
j'appelle vis-à-vis c'est quand il y a
euh différentes pièces qui sont alignées
dans une même rangée c'est le plus
fréquent ou colonne mais aussi dans une
même diagonale et ici vous voyez il y a
deux dames qui sont dans les même
diagonal et il y a un truc au milieu et
ce truc au milieu et ben faut toujours
se poser la question mais est-ce que je
peux pas le bouger pour créer une
découverte dans le fameux vis-àis en
fait ça c'est dans chaque partie d'échec
quasiment il y a au moins ce thèmeel qui
apparaît une fois et qui peut faire
gagner ou perdre si on voit pas la
partie donc faut vraiment que vous
fassiez hyper gaffe à ça surtout quand
les pièces en question don les vis-à-vis
bien sûr bah s'appelle le roi une tour
ou une dame c'est là où bien ça va être
le plus intéressant d'un point de vue
gain matériel et donc ici dans cette
position c'est qu'on est un peu omnibilé
par tous les échecs qu'on peut faire sur
ce roi et on va peut-être oublier de
remarquer qu'ass vis-à-vis et donc si on
arrive à bouger notre cavalier sur échec
ça veut dire qu'au prochain coup on
pourra gagner la dame et donc on
résoudra nos problèmes de mat du couloir
et on aura une dame gratuite au passage
donc ça peut vous vous aider et
exactement t verment bien jouer on va
rester dans la diagonale pour maintenir
le vis-àis et ce roi malheureusement
pour lui il a pas d'autre choix que
d'aller sur la case de 7 toutes les
cases sont interdites et donc ici vous
pouvez gagner la dame bah de deux façons
d'ailleurs euh en sacrifiant le cavalier
et derrière c'est euh c'est game donc
c'est pareil admettons ça par exemple et
donc la partie est gagnée juste pour
finir il y a pas de des problèmes de mat
du couloir parce que on peut faire des
échecs partout et ensuite on pourra
tranquillement se se donner une case un
abri donc voilà ça c'est vraiment hyper
important pour vous dans vos parties
essayez de d'avoir toujours en tête ces
idées de de vis-à-vis d'alignement de
pièces quand vous voyez des alignements
dans une colonne dans une avec un roi
une dame dites-vous il y a pas un truc à
exploiter là et vous verrez que souvent
c'est le
cas donc c'est pour ça que St roi8 est
impossible et la joueuse chinoise si on
en arriv là elle serait obligé de rester
dans ce réseau de
perpétuel il peut aussi faire dame F7 ro
H8 dame F6 ça fait nul aussi il y a une
autre manière de faire nul
mais on peut prendre le fou sur tour D8
alors oui exactement tu avais raison
même kvich cétait encore plus précis
dans ce qu'on vient de voir juste ici
même c'est encore plus simple on prend
le fou et on contrôle la case de de la
tour donc il y avit pas de problème de
mettre du couloir tout à fait ah on
s'attaque au pull au vert du pauvre
grand Déus déjà qu'il a 05 points
laissez lui au moins son pull quoi c'est
c'est tout ce qui lui reste en fait
c'est toutou parce que là il a plus
beaucoup de points là il est encore mal
dans cette partie doit faire froid en
plus au Pays-Bas ici en hiver
ouais là-bas il va il va par TR très
froid ouais nous demande si on pense que
alors j'ai quand même actualisé juste
avant pour voir non il est en pleine
réflexion notre petit français s'il a le
potentiel pour atteindre le top 10
mondial c'est tjour une question à
laquelle il est difficile de répondre
salut salut à Flo parce qu'il est encore
très jeune euh le potentiel il l'a
certainement après à son âge c'estàdire
qu'il peut avoir des choix de vie on
sait pas en fait même
on peut supposer qu'il a envie de
devenir joueur d'cheque professionnel
mais peut-être qu'il peut avoir envie de
continuer ses études de faire des
rencontres qui vont le détourner un peu
des échecs on a vu des très forts
joueurs par exemple c'est David Owell
qui éit un des plus jeunes grands
maîtres de l'histoire joueur anglais
eu bah finalement il est devenu je sais
pas il a un taf au placé un peu
businessman on va dire il avait un peu
laissé les échecs de côté alors qu'il
était monté à à 2700 là il rejoue
récemment mais on sait pas trop en fait
quel quel avenir euh va choisir Marc
Andrea et puis quelle francher il va
quel palier il va franchir ça va
dépendre aussi de son entourage c'est
hyper important ses
entraîneurs ses parents sa vie privée
enfin il y a tellement de facteurs en
fait qui peuvent faire la différence que
c'est trop tôt pour pour savoir j encore
beaucoup de palier à franchir en fait il
y a beaucoup de palier à franchir encore
et euh donc c'est un peu trop tôt pour
se prononcer à son à son à ce sujet mais
c'est vrai que euh priori oui oui il
aurait le potentiel pour être un très
très bon joueur déjà quand tu es plus
jeune qu
MRE un bon signe quoi quand quand tu
devan ctien bakro qui d'après par
exemple son entraîneur Dorfman qui a
entraîné aussi Kasparov bah av même
d'après Dorfman Bro était plus doué plus
fort que Kasparov il avait le potentiel
pour devenir meilleur que Kasparov donc
voilàand quand vous le devancez en
précocité même si on n pas la même
époque donc peut-être que c'est un petit
peu plus facile je me r d'eximer que à
l'époque d'Étienne de devenir grand
maître ça reste quand même une preuve de
bien sûr de talent de talent incroyable
après jusqu'où il pourra aller on lui
souhaite le plus haut possible on verra
en tout cas c'est bien qu'il ait déjà
des invitations parce que c'est la
première fois je pense qu'il jou dans un
tel tournoi pour je pense que oui ouais
pour acquérir de l'exéri il avait joué
les Olympiades il avait il avait joué
trucsou là c'est vraiment un des top
tournois même si c'est le challenger ça
reste très intéressant pour ah oui c'est
c'est très très fort là il est quand
même dans les derniers élos hein d'AV un
ou deux joueurs qui oné le plus c'est
tout bah son adversaire du jour et puis
je sais pas peut-être il y en a un autre
mais je crois qu'il est avant dernier il
y a il y a un autre
joueurem
VOG et après c'est VOG
effectivement donc bon B ce serait bien
qu'il mette le point mais donc là il il
a toujours pas jouer mais il faut dire
que la position est complexe comme on
vous a montré il y a plein de choses
tactiques à
calculer il a sûrement pas envie de
faire le perpet qu'on vient de vous
montrer je pense qu'il veut essayer de
gagner ici bah il a un demi sur TR et je
pense qu'il a envie de montrer qu'il a
envie de gagner une partie quoi enfin il
a envie de montrer
euh un
peu du coup bon on reviendra à sa
position peut-être quand il aura pris
une décision ouais est-ce qu'on
partirait pas avec une petite page de
pub ouais et du coup on va on va vous
laisser quelques instants et on va
revenir ensuite on va retourner voir un
petit peu ce qui se passe chez chez
Carlsen notamment et euh et donc d'ici
bah d'ici quelques minutes he on vous
dit on vous dit à tout de suite yes à
tout de
[Musique]
suite
et je suis de retour tour et pendant
cette petite pause alors que Stu est en
train de se remplir la penseche il
devrait pas tarder euh on a eu un
deuxème
résultat pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
il y a eu une première nulle en
seulement 30 minutes bon qui était
prévisible et annoncé entre entre
karyakin et et Guy et là maintenant ce
ce
sont chankland et rapport qui ont
partagé le point H ça faisait un petit
moment qu'on éétait pas allé voir la
partie mais ils ont joué exactement ce
qu'on avait prédit on était resté par
ici donc il venait d'y avoir du coup des
des des échanges massives voilà toutes
les pièces qui avaient disparu on était
resté avec les deux FS on avait vu qu'il
y avait quand même des possibilités pour
pour les de deux
joueurs mais ça c'est simplifié les F
ont disparu ensuite donc se retrouvver
avec les les six pièces lourdes
c'est vrai que c'est une position un peu
équilibrée même si les bon ici sont
censé presser un peu grâce à leur leur
centre dominant mais apparemmentà CH a
pas réussi à à obtenir grand chose
h pourant il y a aussi une pression sur
ce SP DIN qui est un peu faible als je
suis curieux de voir comment il a son
avantage ah oui ok d'accord bon bah j'ai
la réponse il a joué E6 E6 si vous
voulez ça revient une proposition nulle
ici
euh l'idée c'était plutôt de de jouer F4
de peut-être garder un peu les pièces
doubler pour presser ici ou plus tard
essayer de créer quelque chose contre
son roi mais E6 c'est la
simplification j'ai r E6 c'est la
simplification pour tout est changer
donc apparemment ch hier il a joué un
petit marathon contre Carana il dev être
fatigué il avait envie juste de rentrer
à la maison et il a forcé Laan nul plus
ou moins avec les Blancs par on se
rrouve dans une
finale avec qu tours mais égalité et à
ce niveaul des pions vont s'échanger
d'une façon ou d'une autre et ça devrait
bon voilà faire nul et ici c'est un
petit perpétuel donc bon une partie au
final pas très
intéressante
et on voit que Ch il a terminé non is je
crois qu'il a terminé avec 1h30 non il a
quand Mme il a quand même réfléchi bon
il il a rien
trouvé rapport une bonne opération avec
les Noirs il vient de gagner deux
parties de suite par en repos avec 2 et
demi sur
4 du coup on va aller voir Magnus contre
contre vent
forest on était resté par
ici avec le fameux faux C l'idée de
Stouff qui Ava été joué par One forest
Magnus a joué tour
D1 A5 qui veut prendre de l'espace c'est
assez logique avec les Noirs à l' d'ame
et donc surt fallait parler de fou H3
pour éviter l'échange de fout case
blanche bouger le cavalier et donc dans
la dans le même esprit Carsen a joué fou
F1 pour pour garder son
fou et donc face à Caval d D2 qui allait
arriver peut-être créer des problèmes je
juste faire un coup de je passe mon tour
pour
illustrer pas avoir des problèmes avec
ce fou en fait si recule même parfois
avoir du G4 B du E4 il va être assez mal
placé et on n pas envie de se le faire
manger ici donc face à ça forest il a
décidé de de tout de suite échanger
voilà c'est la partie il y a eu ensuite
eu pas mal de coup il y a eu un coup
d'ailleurs assez spectaculaire ici c'est
cavalier
C5 alors cavalier C5 on joue sur le
clouage du pion D4 dans la diagonale je
vous parlais tout à l'heure quand on a
fait la petite tactique ensemble des
fameux vis-à-vis bah un de plus mais
dans cette partie je pense qu'on on va
les compter s' en a d'autres qui se
reproduisent vous allez voir c'est
vraiment fréquent là on joue sur le sur
le vis-avis dans la diagonale donc le
pion est cloué
en aucun cas on est intéressé pour
changerici on se retrouve avec des fous
de couleur opposé ce fou qui sera comm
PZ une très belle diagonale alors que
lui il fait un peu la gueule pour
l'instant qui qui jouer pour le SER les
noir bien s n' pas jou ça
il recu F sur la première rangée c'est
une autre chose intéressante
B c'est que les fous sont des pièces
quand même à longue portée et des fois
je vois souvent dans des parties les
joueurs peuvent un peu rechigner
justement à à laisser leur fou sur la
première ou la deuxième rangée mais faut
voir ils font le même taf depuis E1 et
F1 dans cette diagonale là que s'ils
étaient en C3 ou en D3 c'est le plus
important là au moins ils sont plus
embêter par le par le cavalier
adverse donc ne pas hésiter c'est une
pièce à longue portée faut profiter de
cette avavantage et eu cavalier
E4 il s'installe au centre j'espère
qu'on va récupérer
Stouff quand même sous peu fou D3 là la
menace elle est simple il peut essayer
de de gagner un petit pion tout
simplement juste pour vous montrer ça
c'est pas un cou c'est pas une idée pour
répéter en disant je rejoue sur le
cloage mais là bien sûr cette fois on
mangerait et la différence c'est que on
aurait de fous fou pour une tour ce qui
serait largement à l'avantage des blancs
deux pièces mineures contre une tour
c'est à part très rares exception quand
même très avantageux pour les deux
pièces bah déjà elles sont une de plus
en faitin
elles sont une de plus donc retour à la
partie sur fou D3 il a joué F5 grand
forest pour vraiment consolider son
cavalier au
centre
h et ici alors qu'on train récupérer
Stouff oui merci de laissé manger
j'espère que tu es
repu tour C été jou par Magnus j'ai
avancé un petit peu il a pas joué H3 jou
F F un peu la même idée que tu avais tu
avais soumise et du coup du coup il a
réussi à gagner le F
blanche G5
intéressantest ilmeamb cont avec les
Noirs il se contente pas
d'attendre il t sa chance hein il a
raison hein exactement donc il joue G5
il veut en fait fixer
euh les casses blanches
ici donc ça c'est un coup qui fait sens
hein dans ce genre de structure en fait
il a pas peur pour son roi il y a aucune
perspective d'attaque pour les blancs
les blan ils vont plutôt essayer de
jouer au centre ou à dame en tout cas
pour l'instant
ouais non je pense que ça va ça va être
lent moi je vois bien un petit
euh4 G4 a été joué et Caren il s'est dit
c'est le moment je mange ton ton
cavalier c'est peut-être un peu le
problème ici devant de forêt c'est que
si prend de
f Il pe le pion G4 en
l'air et s'il prend d ça intuitivement
ça a pas l'air ouf parce que il ouvre
quand même cette rupture au centre où il
y a encore un vis-à-vis un tour d'â pour
les blancs donc il a pris de F où il
active sa tour
h
mais du coup il sacrifie le P G4 hein
c'est la partie ça c'est la partie il
sacrifie le pion G4 forest car pas de
Blu c'est manger c'est quand même osé
comme choix je sais pas
si s'il a oublié quelque chose à un
moment donné ça paraît quand même un peu
risqué de donner ce pion il aurait
peut-être pu préparer G4 du
coup je pense qu'il a dû rat fa prend 4
ouais ça ça fait faut prendre comment le
rater en fait tout simplement c'est le
bon fou qu' un cavalier comme ça
généralement c'est pas un coup qu'on va
vraiment surveiller regarder et parce
que ça peut paraître un petit peu quand
même en fait souvent vous voyez quand
vous échangez une pièce il faut regarder
après d'ailleurs ce qu'il nous reste
comme pièce et après en échange fa prend
qu on voit qu'il nous reste le fou qui
est une mauvaise pièce et du coup en
fait on peut penser que enfin juste même
sans calculer hein se dire B en fait ben
non enfin prend c'est pas pas un coup
quoi mais là c'est un coup parce que du
coup il y a le P 80 ouais donc peut-être
forest il a il a oublié en fait4
peut-être ou alors il considère que il
va avoir de l'attaque sur la colonne F
et que il a des compensations
suffisantes pour le P bon c'est pas
idiot en terme de compensation non non
bien sûr que non ça précipité quoi pas
nécessaire
donc surtout contre Carsen quoi donc
prise donc là on est obligé de prendre
avec eux sinon bah il y a la tour qui va
rentrer dans 7e rangée donc ça serait
catastrophique donc e prend D5 et
Carlsen ah bah lui il est pas inquiet
pour sonroit il a joué tour
C5 pour essayer d'aller manger ben un
deuxième pion
ouais et B6 qui défendrait le pion A5 et
attaquerit la T5 serait aussi un
éblissement pour le pionou ça serait
même très mauvais je pense B6 deviendra
très faible tour C5 pour provoquer B6 on
reviendra en C avec la tour quand même
bizarre ce ce tour et après doubler sur
la colonne C et le fiancé serait
vraiment en
danger salut Olito c'est un joli pseudo
ça
mais je suis pas sûr
que que tour C5 était le plus préc je
sais pas bon après ça ça a fait sens
hein mais l'impression que cette tour
elle va être un peu hor
jeu c'est assez bizarre comme position
parce que il y a ce pion de plus mais
c'est vrai que quand même le roi est un
peu faible sur case
blanche tour 5 a été joué et V forest il
a réagi en jou
H5 qui paraît logique he cette dame elle
était bien placée c'est une intruse il
veut la chasser il veut récupérer
peut-être les cases pour sa propre dame
il se dit bah écoute le pion à 5 je
pense c'est pas si grave moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ton
roi c'est intéressant ça peut être une
partie à tris résultats he h si la dame
reste là en fait si la dame reste là bon
com h déjà H3 elle est un peu mal placer
un petit peu en je quand même ouis les
cases blanches sont quand même ouvertes
donc c'est quand même ça reste quand
même des options mais après un coup
comme pour dame G6 et ben jeand même
bien les cases blanches et donc là il y
a fait le plus 550 donc faudra peut-être
plus précis hein mais euh mais en tout
cas euh ça pour être intéressant sur les
cas blanches mais tu vois sur dame G5 à
la place par exemple de Dam H3 et ben je
peux avoir des idées comme roi H7 et fou
H6 par exemple c'est vrai que la dame
peut manquer de case à terme hein c'est
et euh ouais et sur damage 4 à la place
du damage5 ben je peux aussi avoir fou
F6 donc en fait j'ai pas 36 cases non
plus c'est pas si facile oui ça paraît
logique de rester sur les cases blanches
vu qu'on est faible sur case blanche en
faitin on veut que la dame contrôle les
cases blanches
h alors salut cigogne qui a raté son
premier
message c'est le mini S qui
part salut à toi j'espère que tu vas
bien si si donc bon on a une part partie
ouais qui très intéressante je pense à
trois résultats Carlsen bon il a un plus
mais attention ici il peut y avoir du
contrejeu pour la noir al B5 on affaibli
le pion mais d'un autre côté peut-être
il veut essayer de de rentrer sur la
colonne
à c'est une position comme qui est très
complexe donc dans laquelle peut-être
Carlsen pourrait faire parler sa sa
supériorité mais V forest on a vu qu'il
était dangereux qu'il était en forme
ouais le développement de cette partie
va être vraiment intéressant je comm ça
ouais parce queok il a il a en fait
donné un pion hein mais il a quand même
maintenant il joue sur le fait que
fouais fou aussi le fou qui qui n'a pas
de case et donc c'est c'est une décision
qui est quand même assez intéressante de
la part de de rest je pense pas une ga
je pense peut-être pas une gaff juste il
s'est dit qu'il avait suffisamment de
contre jeu donc écoute ouais je pense
que c'est hyper intéressant on verra
dans les minutes à venir comment ça
évolue on nous parle des Pinko dans le
chat je pense ça peut être pas mal ça
fait longtemps qu'on est pas all voir
deant qu' joue contre vidit qui est le
le leader surprise de ce début de
tournoi donc ouais on va jeter un œil à
leur partie je sais pas si tu avais vu
que en fait chanclan a fait n contre
rapport si si si bah on a vu pendant ton
absence bah vraiment ils ont tout
échangé en fait chankland avait une
position bah ce qu'on avait prédit assez
intéressante et puis il a préféré tout
liquider forcer la nuU donc bon il était
peut-être fatigué ok d'accord beauou
partie ouais il a fait une partie très
longue hier
ouais on était resté juste à l'ouverture
dans cette partie entre entre vidit et
sipenko donc on disait une duoco piano
qui est vraiment à la mode
oui et il a pas fait le même on s'éit
arrêté par ici il a pas eu G5 comme tu
t'y attendais un style plus classique
plus solide et sipenko il a il a roqué
tranquillement donc on va passer un
petit peu les coups suivants parce que
voà ce sont des coups assez logique de
développement de prise d'espace àel dame
on garde aussi des des ces de recul pour
le fou
euh pareil le cavalier qui va se
rediriger vers les cases
àroi et central c'est du très très
classique dans cette ouverture et il
copie il copie avec les noir il va faire
vous allez voir un peu la même
chose fou B3 donc là c'est peut-être
pour laisser la case C4 et on va
anticiper aussi he pour pas perdre de
temps des fois sur le fou quand il est
en C4 C6 cavalier F1 cavalier G6 cahier
G3 donc on retrouve une symétrie les
cavaliers qui se poursuivent d'un bout
àutre de chiquier pour rester en
miroir complètement symétrique ouais
c'est assez marrant après 13 coup ouais
et le premier
mais du coup ce qui est marrant c'est
que c'est très au noir la tour la seule
différence c'est voilà la tour ouais
donc ici il é assz il a exploité
finalement il dit peut-êre j'ai pas
forcément besoin de tour 8 je vais être
le premier à pousser au centre en jouant
D5 alors là fallait calculer hein parce
que du coup vu que la tour est pas en 8
il y a ce pion qui peut-être euh bah va
manquer un défenseur on va voir comment
ça va continuer prend D5 cavalier prend
D5 et ici il y a eu D4 alors pourquoi on
peut pas prendre le pion Stouff toi qui
a un fin
tacticien icier prendre 4 prendre
le petit faitesvous la main vous pouvez
chercher dans le chat si vous voulez
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez on vous
rappelle on vous rappelle ce qu'on avait
dit tout à l'heure par rapport aux
échecs en premier mais peu non mais oui
c'estra qu' a qu'un seul ou donc bon
vous doné la réponse la méthode vraiment
on va regarder les coups forcés là on a
un de moin donc si on fait rien les
blanc vont j des pour
pour consider le
centre gérer le P plus et en fait ici il
y a F point F2 qui est intéressant donc
voyz c'est un échec donc pourquoi à
chaque foiséchec c'est forcé après F
prend ro prend F2 et ben on a F6 qui va
faire attaque double une petite
fourchette voilà VO la tour sera perdue
ouais un petit sacrifice d'attraction et
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
des fois on a la bonne idée mais pas
dans le bon sens et il faut aussi touj
calculer dans les de cou là par exemple
on pourrait penser à Dame F6 en disant
je fais une double attaque et ça l' pas
mal sauf que bah il peut revenir en
défense et du coup des fois quand vous
avez des idées comme ça ditous est-ce
que je peux pas faire dans l'autre sens
ah et peut-être que des fois ça marche
dans l'autre sens même et vous allez
vous rendre compte que assez souvent
c'est le cas il y a souvent plusieurs
sens pour les variantes il faut vraiment
pas avoir peur de de vérifier et en
l'occurrence c'est donc F prend F2 dans
ce sens là donc qu'on gagne la la tour
voilà pour cette raison on revient à la
partie le pion il est
interdit qui fait que bahko a pu jouer
D5 à juste titre sans perdre de pion bon
il est pas en reste non plus viite il a
joué D4 à son
tour prend des4 donc les pions cent Trux
qui disparaissent
tous cavalier prend des4 et tour 8 et on
retrouve la symétrie après
coup qui est parfaite cette fois-ci là
la symétrie
ouais échange des tours de la part de
vidit puis prison des5 donc là pour le
coup il a rompu complètement la symétrie
et il va jouer sur le fait donc il donne
la paire de fou mais il dit tuas un pion
isolé et il a créé aussi le pion le fou
le fou c'est qui est une mauvaise pièce
maintenant parce que sur case blanche
trouis que le fou a pas trop de case il
manque de perspective voilà c'est pour
ça qu'il a qu'il a voulu manger hein
parce que le fou était mauvais en fait
les Noirs ont la paire de fou mais vous
voyez que la paire de fou encore une
fois hein c'est la partie de PR tout à
l'heure ou la per de fou et ben elle est
pas très active et c'est pour ça que les
Blancs se permettent de pouvoir Prz la
part de fou pour jouer contre le pion D5
on va jouer contre ce pion isolé parce
que VO on a un blour et évidemment la
différence c'est que sur la prise nous
on a toujours notre dame qui est là donc
on pourrait reprendre de la dame ce qui
serait bien sûr très important reprendre
du pion bah ça anillerait tout avantage
blanc parce que on se retrouverait à
nouveau avec une symétrie donc on va
reprendre de la dame pour pouvoir
presser ce pion passé on va voir comment
les joueurs on Contin parce qu'il encore
eu quand même quelques coups fou3 donc
termin le développement euh alors fou C7
c'est intéressant je trouve comme coup
il s'enlève de de ce vis-à-is il menace
de gagner en un coup la
partie déjà première chose et il peut
créer des petits thèes dans cette
diagonale justement sur case noire
voilà que la dame des fois une batterie
peut s'opérer le pion avancer pourquoi
pas bon il y a eu dame D2 va peut-être
faire coulisser même s'il faudra faire
attention à celui-ci fou D7 donc bah on
attaque une deuxième fois pion on le
défend et il a décidé de prendre G3 donc
là c'est une décision responsable
ouais qu'on la part de fou quand même il
donne le il donne la per de fou la de
fou et le bon fou en plus hein ouais
mais pour avoir des fous de couleur
opposé
bon c'est un peu risqué dis donc qu'ici
il risque d'avoir quand même une petite
pression blanche sans risque hein parce
que il y a un pion faible j'aime bien
les blancs j'aime bien les blancs après
voilà pour la gagner ça reste ça reste
compliqué hein la position est quand
même relativement solide hein chez les
Noirs c'est un peu bizarre ce coup de
dame ici parce que on a l'impression
que que le pion C3 se retrouve faible je
sais pas quelle est son idée ah il
défend juste G3 ok je ouis et sur ro H2
il devit avoir peur de de l'avancer ici
c'est vrai que c'est pas si facile c'est
pas con en fait son idée de donner le
fou pour créer des petits problèmes sur
ces deux pions là C3 et G3 et si un jour
il arrive à mettre un cavalier en4 ça
pourrait vent une bonne une bonne
nouvelle pour les ouais alors il en est
loin mais mais oui cavalier serait
monstrueux le cavalier serait monstrueux
donc il a fait dame F2 tour
C8 et donc bon vit il doit maintenant
défendre son pion C3
certainement comme fou D2 par exemple
comment tu pourrais
jouer fou D2 bah est-ce qu'on peut
essayer justement de vraer à à se
transfer ça a l'air difficile hein ouais
parce que pour arriver en E4 il faut que
j'arrive en D6 ou en F6 ouais il y a pas
trop fa arriver là déjà c'est compliqué
déjà là c'est vraiment des fois on fait
des exercices emmener un cavalier sur un
avant-poste faut trouver le bon chemin
euh cavalier F8 H7 F6
ouais il y a un chemin qui existe et euh
ça c'est long hein tout ça euh mais je
sais pas si si les no de le faire parce
que cavali tour tour qui va être
ant
aussi il faut voir ouisir il y a eu tour
F1 immédiatement par tour F1 ok donc on
va défendre donc euh on joue fou E6
est-ce qu'on joue F6 ouais c'est la
question bah fou E8 mê il peut être un
coup
ici mais ouais c'est très très long
comme plan et là typiquement ce genre de
meuf de cavalier ça peut être euh
pertinent mais plus dans les positions
fermées hein dans les positions fermées
vous pouvez vous permettre de perdre du
temps de manœuvrer parce que il y a
moins de risque concret tactique mais là
la position elle est quand même euh jeis
dire semi ouverte on peut dire je sais
pas ce que tu en penses mais euh en tout
cas elle est pas fermée puis qu'il y il
y a des faiblesses il a des colonnes
ouvertes il y a de la pression sur les
pions ou c'est pas non plus voilà les
portes jour des portes ouvertes mais
voilà c'est un peu entre les deux donc
on peut pas se permettre de d'avoir un
plan trop trop lent euh donc bon petite
pression blanche je dirais mais c'est
vrai que euh je fais confiance à
siipenko pour la tenir ici on verra on
verra comment ça
évolue je te propose je sais pas ce que
tu en penses d'aller voir si Marc Andria
il a pris une décision parce qu'il a une
position hyper intéressante un choix à
faire peut-être il y avait des des
perpètes d'ailleurs à l'horizon donc P
aller voir ouais alors il a mangé
cavalier c'est alors il y a pas beaucoup
de coups de jouet parce que la position
est vraiment compliquée et on en était
là il a mangé avec le cavalier donc un
coup bien sûr qu'on avait on avait
envisagé et il y a eu dame prend D4 ici
ce qu'on Ava regardé aussi ouais et du
coup H3 et là il a jou H3 maintenant
donc pour parer tous les thèmes de mat
du couloir dont on avait parlé qui
étaient problématique dans plein de
variantes H qui empêcha notamment de par
exemple de ramener la dame à l'attaque
parfois
donc il a j H3 tout de suite ok la
position vraiment intéressante
i alors est-ce
que je sa pas dans sens dans
manger prière chison il
Atta fourchett
mais regard juste ok je pense que ça
va peut-être seter à cavalier D6 alors
après il peut y avoir des perpèes
aussi on CAH D6 qui
défend aussi et attaque oui regarder
l'ordre de C peut-être peut-être d'abord
d'ailleurs et cavalier
D6 il y a dame échec en fait tu ça au
pire on peut faire ça et là ça a l'air
quand même assez dangereux pour
les sil faut faire G3 il y aura fou C6
et j'ai peur que les ces blanches so
trop ouvertes ouis alors que si joue
juste d G3
mais ça peut aussi terminer par un
perpétuel parfis mais oui comme ça
pertu cette partie le début exactement
mais mais pour l'instant bon il un peu
voir un pe ce qui se passe mais il garde
toujours un peu cette arme sur le coude
l'arme du
Perpétuel alors il y a du TR B4 mais
c'est toujours le problème en fait c'est
que c'est pas des vraies double attaques
parce que il y a toujours un échec pour
le noir là moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est en train de se retourner un petit
peu quand même la
position je commence à à donner plus de
chance pratique au noir
quoi parce que ouais parce que le
cavalier il est un peu perdu làhauttion
que le roi est un peu
faible du couloir le roi est un peu
faible le roi blanc mais bon ok ça reste
encore compliqué c'est complexe ça rest
compliqué
ilement 21
coup bon ça joue on va voir déjà le
choix de la joueuse chinoise est-ce
qu'elle mange 4 est-ce qu'elle mange ici
elle mange 4 tout de suite
voilà donc
Mang tout de suite
donc il peut se passer ce qu'on avait ce
qu'on vient de
regarder et donc D6 tout de suite est-ce
que c'est c'est mieux ou pas ça change
quoi est-ce que est-ce que c'est
intéressant de contrôler à la première
r là j'attaque la dame déjà
ouais dame B2 dame aussi pe menace des
fois je sais pas avec un mat en G7 le FR
en l'air des fois ouais je pas la
meilleure case ici des5 D4 c'est en fait
c'est tellement dur pour les Noirs il y
a tellement de possibilités que même
pour les no si on fait un coup pour
essayer
de dame C6 dame G5 ouais mais non mais
on on oblige pas du tout leschang dam en
fait donc ça va gagner ça parce que les
Noirs ont un problème c'est la défense
deong G7 elle est pas du tout évidente
pour le coup faire attention donc
peut-être rester sur noir du
coup attaquer
défendre et
ici ici moi c'est vrai que c'est chaud
en fait he parce que peut-être
maintenant il peut quand même
menacer tour B8 il menass mat he mat du
couloir au passage puisque le cavalier
contrôle la
case donc là ça a l'air dangereux
finalement pour les pour les Noirs ça
peut tourner des deux côtés hein cette
cette partie
position
intéressante
h on va peut-être les laisser un petit
peu quelques instants retourner
qu'est-ce que tu vas aller voir dans le
Prague je crois en train de de de
prendre un sacré avantage là le petit
Prague contre grandlieux on l'avait
laissé dans une position prometteuse
Prague on avait laissé à il venait de
manger le cavalier justement et il a
envoyé le H5 he comme on s'y attendait h
fou G4 que tu critiquais qui a été joué
du coup par grandéius et c'est vraiment
une suite qu'on a regardé un cahier D2
donc avec pour objectif de finir avec le
bon cavalier contre le mauvais fou en
cas d'échange ouais c'est ça donc ça
grandus quand même il l'a compris donc
il est revenu avec son fond en D7
euh et alors il a joué un coup qu'on
avait critiqué pr il a joué
c44 je pense que il voulait peut-être
jouer contre B5 renforcer son que B5 est
une menace
bon pourquoi il a joué C4 ah il a joué
C4 pour faire passer sa dame
ouais alors après il peut aussi jouer C4
pour vraiment verrouiller la ce B5
laisser la dame passer mettre un
cavalier en C3 et cetera que c'est une
idée mais euh mais en fait nous on
disait que c'est avec l'absence des faut
de case blanche mettre un cavalier en C4
ça va une bonne idée ça peut être une
case intéressante mais bon il veut verou
mais ok c c'est pas un coup que j'aurais
jou je
pense je préf
Cali
d il a mis la dame en C3 donc je pense
que peutre A4 même si le pion sera
faible ensite donc pas
sûr le fou reculer peut-être pour jouer
le F5 je te parlais peut-être la seule
la seule Lig un peu active pour les
noirs
ça tricote un peu chez PRAG dame 3 ok il
a compris maintenant que les Noirs
voulaient jouer F5 il s'enlève de de la
diagonale peut-être au cas où ça
s'ouvre F5 a été joué il a décidé
d'ouvrir la col h peut-être la dame qui
va arriver plus tard et de jouer A4 pour
fixer il jou un peu sur les deux ailes
il garde son au centre B la position est
intéressante l'impression d'avoir perdu
quelques temps avec les blancs mais
c'est pas forcément si grave bah vu que
la position est fermée c'est pas très
grave en fait ouais d'avoir perdu ce
temps là il y a quand même des trous
dans la position de
noir et euh donc c'est une on voit qu'
quand même la paire de fou chez les chez
les Noirs mais il y a il y a ce pion en
D5 qui est passé si on si on pouvait
poser un pion noir en D6 ce serait pas
la même c'est
clair c'est un grand avantage à long
terme je mets un pion en D6 noir et un
pion en B2 chez les Blancs euh oui c'est
diff on va tendre vers l'égalité là ou
voir peut-être mieux pour les Noirs mais
en tout cas là sur sur le long terme
c'est un vrai à tout pion ouais et al
fou F6 a été joué je pense queil veut
jouer roi G7 ma non pere c'est pas si
facile en fait
de il veut jouer fou
G5 il veut jouer fou G5 il va essayer de
faire un truc comme ça non c'est quoi
son
idée vous jouez F4 F4 il f quand même
c'est pas
beau alors dage 3 évidemment c'est
un que j'aime beaucoup parce que par
rapport au plan que tu préconises F G5
là là j'aurais d'
ouais pardon en fait avec F 5 et ben
j'ai ma suite donc en fait du coup
profilx par rapport à ton plan
j'anticipe et je menace de ma alors
question faire G
ser le drama question
pour
passe qui
passe et
dansourenser bon piè et
auè la bonne pièce des blanc no blanche
et contrôle plein de cases notamment
case6 G4 et C et la mauvaise pièce des
blancs c'est le F case blanche parce
qu'en fait bah tous les pions centux
sont s case blanche donc le fou a du mal
à à manœuvrer donc après l'échange de
fou de case blanche et ben le les blancs
vont vraiment pouvoir installer un
cavalier en E4 qui va bien sûr bloquer
le pion E5 bien sûr le fou F6 et les
noirs auraient une très mauvaise
position donc ça ça c'est thématique
dans les positions desest indiennes ENF
dans les structures avec comme ça
d'échanger de F cas blanche pour les
blancs c'est une très très bonne
nouvelle et d'installer un fort cavalier
en E4 qui va bloquer justement va
dominer le fou le fou noir donc
stratégiquement ici ce serait très bien
pour les blancs donc ça n'arrivera pas
il va il va jamais jouer ça donc dommage
3 c'est un coup qui va probablement être
joué mais F34 c'est pas un coup qu'on r
au devoir F4 non plus parce qu'on a on a
F G4 c'est la même coule alors c'est un
peu moins pire parce que il y a pas la G
4 pour le cavalier mais ça reste bien
sûr pas bon pour les le fou il est
encore très enin viment ça reste très
mauvais pour les Noirs stratégiquement
c'est déjà perdu voilà c'est j'ai un un
mauvais coup j'ai la colonage pas se
retrouver avec ce fou contre ce cavalier
voilà ok en fait les Noirs doent essayer
de garder le leur Focas ouais donc dam
H3 ça m' l'air très bien et là qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait voir sur D H3
à à la place de F4 de F pas dam G7 3 F7
G7 pourrait être pas mal essayer de
transférer le roi via H7
peut-être je P c'est le plan après ce
qui est bien qu'on peut jouer avec les
deux ailes a chez les Blancs quoi on
joue on joue un coup à gauche un coup à
droite peut-être à voir à voir position
intéressante pr qui je pense met la
pression il met la pression il peut
peut-être essayer de de remporter sa
première victoire dans ce tournoi
ouis un petit pour
St pour
alors on peut peut-être retourner
puis que la position était très
chaude était peut-être en danger même en
tout cas ça jou vraiment les trois
résultats position intéressante comment
il s'en sort le champion du monde contre
son petit second néerlandais qui joue
devant son
public on était resté voilà on venait de
jouer H5 chasser la dame car était
reculé avait reculé sur
H3 et ici donc forest il a choisi d F7
donc il se fout de ce pion je parle un
peu trop vite parce qu'en réalité il le
défend en attaquant F2 puisque ce fou
maintenant peut plus
partir du coup Carsen a rapatrié sa dame
en G2 pour tenir le pion contrôler quand
même toujours les cases blanches autour
de autour de son roi et A4 a été
joué donc ce pion qui éta attaqué bah on
l'avance ça paraît
logique et on a envie bien sûr d'activer
cette tour donc la prise est hors de
question hein pour les blancs parce que
là la tour rentrerait en jeu ça
commencerait bah les Noirs les Blancs
sont obligés d' un peu passif en fait de
défendre plutôt sur leur seconde rangée
et leur pion de plus que pion G3 et
pourrait rien en faire du tout donc
Carlsen a fermé ici par
B4 et donc son fou il est quand même
bien moche
hein ouais j'ai un mauvais fou mais j'ai
un pion plus lui est pas extraordinaire
non plus mais dame D7 ouais dame D7 dame
7 je pensais que c'était un peu pour
empêcher B5 mais B5 quand
même ok donc c'est vraiment chaud alors
l'idée c'est que sur la prise j'imagine
il veut il peut doubler les
toursc qu' peut-être juste tour C vite
ici aller manger P B5 tourb peut-être ah
tu veux faire comme ça comme ça ou
manger de l'utre je ouais c'est clair
cb5 mange B7 ouais effectivement tourb1
qui devrait i être bien pour les
blancs euh donc van forest il a il a
touché à rien et a continué son plan
d'agresser Carlsen à l'roit il a joué H4
donc on enemmenit dans cette position
H4 donc ça a l'air très chaud al son
idée est-ce que c'est plutôt de manger
de pousser ou d'attendre en fonction de
ce qui se
passe ben je pense qu'il va voir un peu
passe H3
alors sur H3 en tout cas le coup forcé
ce sera dans M F1 parce que dans ma la
lame sortir après ce sera quand même un
enfer ça serait compliqué ouais d'avoir
la dame au piquet ce serait un petit peu
j'aurais jou ro F1 ro E2 pour la sortir
par ouis ça serait perdu en fait ouais
ça serait perdu parce que elle serait on
aurit une donc là en fait sur H3 madame
en sûr mais après elle pourrait elle
pourrait ressortir et le pion H3 j'ai
peur qu'il soit un peu FA sur le long
terme c'est vrai donc euh moi je serais
plutôt d'avis de de Banger en G3 alors
je sais pas si maintenant va ou de
maintenir la tension ouais on peut
garder comme ça mais après de manière
générale je pense que il y aura un
échange qui va se et qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire du coup euh du coup carass dans
cette position bah tour C1 prise en ou
prise en C6 plus tour C1 ça a l'air
logiqueouais on va essayer de la
pression sur le pion C6 euh et voir ce
qui se passe mais c'est pas évident de
d'attaquer non plus parce qu'après les
Noirs vont défendre aussi tout pion tour
F6 et mettre le tour en F8 pour tap sur
exement ouais ça a l'air pas mal c'est
vraiment Chud comme position ou j'ai du
mal à évaluer qui est mieux
ouais chacun a son jeu ouais et euh et à
voir aussi que R forest as aussi un un
coup intéressant qui peut arriver hein
c'est la partie après tour F6 après tour
F6 avant de faire de faire tour F8 et
ben j'auris aussi des coup comme fou F8
avec l'idée de mettre le fou en D6 taper
sur
ramour
asentellement il y a du je des
ID no
contre fait paree viment
pastit
on va décider de de prendre ici est-ce
qu'il va jouer un coup comme G4 G4 H3
pour essayer de se faire un pion passé
protégé de fermer mais pareil c'est un
coup très responsable parce qu'près le
pion H3 peut être très
faible paraît très risqué comme
quoi question vraiment qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire après quoi comment on va
réussir à à trouver du jeu parce que là
on est bien on est beau avec no tour sur
c on va manger en C une fois après B
prend B prend par exemple euh comment
comment on continue parce que bien ok
ouais comment comment je rentre après
c'est compliqué B peut-être faut
repartir voilà tout ça me lui va pouvoir
peut-être jouer tour F8 tour F7 c'est un
peu long ouais c'est long et et je sais
pas si vraiment ça va parce qu'en plus
quand la tour elle elle part quand la
tour C elle part de la colonne C et ben
il pourrait y avoir des C5 avec les
cont c'est vraiment pas
[Musique]
facileour
inér
ouais c'est une belle partie c'est une
belle partie sement la partie du
jour ok
ok ok on on va peut-être attendre que ça
se décante et refaire un tour qu'est-ce
qu'on a pas vu depuis longtemps je vois
qu' une tour E6 qui fait
échectre
Dou Dou ouf comment
s téléporté alors paressus le le P ouais
on en était là
FO 4 voilà coup qu'on avait
évoqué il
pardon 4 donc pour attaquer la tour la
tour est venue histoire de de
défendre il a jouer H4 MAM ok pour
empêcher luiême H4 pourquoi pas ça fait
sens et CAH G6 c'est vra qu'il voit une
faiblesse qui vient d'être créée donc
pourquoi pas l'attaquer non plus
peut-être même mettre la marche en avant
avec les pions ouais un jour pour D4 il
défend prépare peut-être un doublage
moment donné jusqu'ici ça a l'air OK
tour
C7 c'est logique il libère son fou
ici le Fou est revenu en B3 pour
attaquer le P E6 et donc voilà 5 comme
on pouvait s'y
attendre prend un peu d'espace la tour
qui rentre en D8 mais on voit qu' c'est
pas un ré clouage parce que
c'estfend rien de grave il a été prendre
le P l'air depuis plusieurs coups alors
on peut dire peut-être que Y qui va
tomber en
contrepartie h cette position qui était
une finale qui s'est vraiment bien animé
ouais
et ici tour je peux jouer ro G5 t ro G5
et je défend il est for et en fait tu as
du mal à vraiment
rentreruse là je me la PR G2 peut-être
ouais H5 ID mais en tout cas non non
intéressant c'est assez chaud
ouais mais ici il a préféré tour V il
veut rentrer en E6
apparemment en tout cas8 ça attaque le P
5 déjà et il attaque le pion5 tu as
raison et donc il faut le défendre donc
il a jou cavalier de 6 j'imagine il est
revenu il a mangé un pion il est revenu
donc il est content
Tourch a été joué et le roi donc
atterrit en G5 et lui dit bah à toi
écoute j'ai un pion de plus c'est une
finale mon ro il est actif il soutient
même mon pion euh
je sa pas au des idées des réseau
quelque chose justifie perte du P H4
c'est ça pourrait très vite mal passer
pour lui en
fait est
calier est-ce que peuttre coup Esser
d'allerallerer le comment
je jouer4 ou
qu
regarder
toujours
arriverre de position
l'ID je
moner découvert des
ça un petit peu et tu restes avec çaon
même ça ce serait pas si clair en
vrai techque à avir mais le
calier son trs ça devrait faire quand
même
mais est un coup ici peut-être ce serait
juste du F3 pour miner
certainement qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire
d'autre en fait est-ce que tu menaces
vraiment cavalier prend parce que du
coup il y aura toujours t pr c je fais
H4 c'est ça c'est ça ouaisre que il a
juste je prends C de et une fois que tu
manges C de je prends vous voyez c'est
c'est de pièces t c'est enfin c'est
mieux hein ça va pas pour les blancs
donc du coup on pourrait jouer H4 en
fait mais qui se passe quoi sur F prend
ah oui juste qu' prend
ici et on n pas le temps de manger là
manger là parce qu'il y a le fou et si
juste on mange comme ça bah tout
simplement le pion qui arrive en F2 là
il va faire la décision et fou C de a
été joué à la caméra on voit
par par ma miarov donc on va voir le le
choix de Doua ici donc on voit qu'il y a
H4 mais celui maintenant qui joue pour
le G H pas mal H4 gros
avantage parce que
pasoup du
coup les compensation quand
mêmezo va s le
fouou
temp HM cavalier pe à s'exprimer ce
cavalier aussi bah c'est le cavalier que
tout à l'heure en paré j'avais dit que
le cavalier en G3 était mal placé c'est
vrai ça pe poser problème ouais ouais et
là on se rend compte que le cavalier en
fait bah
il avec la structure les P qui avance au
cavalier AA jamais vraiment eu de poste
fiableoi stable et on a eu un autre
résultat
stou on a caroana et du buf qui sont
neutralisés ce qui confirme que caroana
il a quand même beaucoup de mal dans ce
t noir à obtenir des choses avec les
pièces
blanches
h on étaé resté par ici donc dans une
position qui est encore complexe les
joueurs ils ont joué ils ont joué très
vite hein il y a beaucoup de coups qui
sont partis pour le
coup ça faisait un petit moment qu'on
était pas all les voir mais en en en 45
minutes ils ont jou une bonne vingtaine
de
CS et finalement benah il a rien obtenu
dans cette dans cette ESP le cavalier B3
qu'on avait évoqué plutôt qui qui a fini
par se
produire salut
faucon les prise en M c'est des
simplifications finalement tout c'est un
peu
échangé cavalier qui va peut-être
profiter de la case F4 plus tard bon il
revient en F6 finalement tout de suite
pour mettre la pression sur le
pion F C2 tour B8 et comme ça ça a l'air
on pas l'air d'avoir de problème du tout
finalement
ici le B2 est aussi FA voir plus faible
queouis c'est symétrique en fait cette
position et au centre bah si ça
s'échange ça sera juste symétrique et
même des5 ça pose pas vraiment problème
on mettra le fou en
B5 B3 bah le Fou est all d'ailleurs en
B5 on va avancer un petit peu vite
puisqueà priori s'est pas passé
grand-chose la petite manœuvre pour pour
essayer de forcer les
échanges qui on le lieu prise prise
garder dam quand même
mais bon je pense qu'ici déjà il devait
bien se rendre compte qu'il avait rien
obtenu de toute l'ouverture
ouais une fois qu'il échange en plus ici
là c'est vraiment complètement égal
maintenant voir peut-être un ouais je
pense que je choisis les Noirs si je
dois choisir un camp ici mais bon ça
reste égal parce que le fou ouais bon
dis que le fou B5 est quand même bien
placé le Fou est un petit peu mieux est
un peu moins bien parce qu'il Arve
oui c'est vrai qu' F des TR tout
simplement du coup il a joué ça pour
forcer mais bon c'est c'est g pour
forcer la nulle et les échanges et donc
là c'est complètement symétrique donc
les deux joueurs ont jou des coups
rapidement mais c'est juste jouer des
coups pour jouer des coups et tout s'est
échangé et on a une symétrie parfaite
dans cette finale de tour bah du bof qui
a bien récupéré sa défaite douloureuse
hier avec les
blancs en étant très solide contre
carwana et clé noir donc mission
accomplie pour le joueur
russe yes du coup on a TR n al juste
pour l'info Carlsen a joué G4 de coup
anncé a joué G4 bah attends on va
peut-être y retourner finalement parce
que on a qui on j'ai l'impression qu'on
a vu tout le monde récemment
ouais salut ouais salut à toi est-ce que
est-ce que ça a bougé chez Marc chez Mar
Andrea ça un petit peu bougé donc oui ça
a bougé un peu il y a eu UN1 je propose
regard la position après on fera une
petite pause allons-y alors donc on a
été resté à Dame PR4 donc joué
par par la joueuse chinoise donc
attaquer la tour euh là il eu CAH D6
tout de suite donc le coup qu'on avait
qu'on avait prévu pour à la fois
défendre
attaquer du coup l'échange des tours est
parti hm hm et donc là on on tout à
l'heure on cherchait une case he pour la
dame la dame et du coup la par4 qui l'
très bien parce que tu prends quand même
tous les chquers la cas tu défends le
fou en A4 tu attaques D6 tu défends
G7 la meilleure case clairement d c'est
une des fois il y a des échecs ouais
c'est vraiment la meilleure case case
centrale la D elle est inatignable ici
mais ça ça empêche aussi VO le contre
jeu par rapport à ce P G7 enfin ça le
réduit en tout
cas et du coup par que dame C7 était
quand même un coup possible parce qu'on
menaçait le mat du qui était intéressant
la case est contrôlée et pourquoi pas
même des fois des dames F7 cavalier E8
il y avait quand même des je sais pas si
c'est possible qu' y le fou encore mais
bon il y a des thèmes en tout cas il a
des thèmes d'attaque Mar il a préféré
dame à
3 qui défend aussi le cavalier qui garde
un il sur le fou peut-être il veut
basculer en G3 G3 elle serait plutôt
bien placée la dame aussi pourquoi pas
ouis bon n'oublions pas qu'il a un pion
de moins malgré tout d'ailleurs c'est la
parti un de moin mais euh mais le
cavalier est vraiment est vraiment très
puissant ouais mais ça peut faire peur
quand même si jamais le par exemple si
jamais les dames disparaissent de les
chiqu ça peut devenir très dangereux
pour pour le petit français ouais un
pion de quand même un pion qui avance en
ouais c'est un pion passé loin2 on
défend on défend F2 ou tout en gardant
un œil ici donc ça céit très làbas et
bah ce fou bon qui faisait rien en A4
depuis qu'il avait pris le pion bah
revenu en C6 attaquer la tour un coup
aussi qui a l'air assez logique
ouais attention peut-être qu'il va être
temps de de jou pour la moi j'aime moi
j'aime de mieux de plus en plus les les
les Noirs quand même ouis moi aussi he
moi aussi parce que par exemple là il
bouger la tour donc disons 7 tour 7 je
sais pas qu'est-ce que juste fou
D5 fou D5 je défends je défends le le
pion et après ben peut-être voir si je
commencer à poser le plan R mettre tout
est tout est tout est assz défendu après
il peut y avoir des complications des
choses mais fallir être créatif et
trouver idées voir que l'ordinateur
propose cavalier C8 cavalier7 c'est coup
que je suis en train de regarder aussi
en pratique
[Musique]
bon sincèrement c'est le premier coup
qui m'est venu à l'esprit dans cette
position parce qu'en fait si tu regardes
tu pe rien faire ce que je veux dire
c'est queas aucune case tu vois que
c'est acobatique et que c'est oui oui
c'est ton seul ta seule chance qui ça
veut dire que tu dois commencer à te
battre peut-être pour la nuul justement
quand on est tu commences aller dans des
dans des coups un petit peu acrobati
c'est pas forcément très bon SIG donc
avec des
idées peut-être il y a des thèmes je
sais pas des fois des sacrifices mais
j'y crois pas trop dans ces
positions ça il a jou t du coup ça va
être la même histoire il va jouer SAF
que il aura même pas ce plan
pere du coup il a cavalier comme idée
dans le même esprit un petit
peu pas
Mali
ça
éch peuttre voir ce P fait quand même
très peur ou là on se bat plus que pour
quasiment donc peut-être que il y a ça
ouais avec idé bon si on prend là il y a
juste la
découverte hop la dame qui
tombe
et sur tour prend il y a un petit mat du
couloir qui fait plaisir pour le coup un
peu qui sort de nulle
part et enfin sur dame pr on a toujours
cet échec en B8 alors sur dame F8 a
tourite voilà on va gagner la dame même
cette position elle sera pas forcément
gagnée pour autant il peut y avoir des
idées de forteresse mais ok ser une
bonne nouvelle et bah sur tour F8 tout
simplement mange la dame donc il y a
cette idée je pense que d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'il a prévu à mon
avis VO pas trop qu'est-ce qu'il peut
espérer d'autre mis sa tour ici pour ça
mais après fou D5 c'est que c'est pour
défendre le pion est-ce qu'on pe faire
du dame F6 c'est la
partie c'est la partie donc on peut
s'attendre à cavalier 8 et ok des
complications peut-être un
perpétuel la jou chinoise qui peut aussi
peut-être craquer mais c'est elle elle a
du temps elle a 34 minutes hein c'est
Marc Andria qui en a plus que H8 h donc
il est quand même sous pression encore
notre notre petit prodige français euh
bon je pense que on va faire une petite
pause touf yes et on se retrouve après
pour voir bah justement comment il s'en
est sorti
ça marche vous dis à donc quelques
minutes on envoie la petite late pub à
tout de
[Musique]
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok ben écoute on est de retour stou
après cette petite pause on espère que
vous êtes toujours avec nous pour voir
le D de c parti aujourd'hui bon pour
l'instant il a eu que des nuls mais il
commence à y avoir pas mal d'animation
et notamment chez le champion du monde
ça devient très très très chaud alors on
va tout de suite regarder ce qui s'est
passé on était resté là donc juste pour
rappel van forest qui avait sacrifié un
pion pour essayer de créer un peu
d'activité
eu et ici Carsen a fait un choix qu'on
avait considéré mais qui était quand
même
très très responsable et et assez risque
aussi de jouer
G4 pour fermer
euh fermer un petit peu cette tile roi
mais ça fait des trous et la réponse de
von Forest est quand même très
intéressante il a balancé H3 il est
vraiment en mode il joue pas du tout la
peur au ventre il lâche les chevaux il
prend tous les risques avec les noirs
pour essayer de battre son champion du
monde puisque c'est travaill quand même
un petit peu pour lui donc voilà en
envoyant un deuxième pion qui a été
encaissé par
Carlsen il av pas trop le choix en même
temps alors du coup pourquoi H3 ouais
alors essay de nous expliquer
l'idée alors en fait
euh revi un en arrière ouais en fait si
les blancs arrivent à consolider avec H3
et ben euh peut-être qu'ils arriveraient
plus tard à à à se défaire un petit peu
de la pression qu'il avait sur sur le
roi et et notamment essayer de commencer
l'attaque du coup sur sur si le P C6
l'idée en fait en jouant H3 pour les
noirs et ben ils veulent essayer de
désorganiser la position des blancs et
gagner un peu de temps empêcher H3 ouais
et après après d' point H3 il y a eu
tour F
donc on double tour logique dame G2 et
tour G6 et maintenant en fait et ben on
menace en fait de manger le pion le pion
G4 et sur un coup comme H3 et ben je
pense qu'il aurait simplement le coup
tour
F3 avec l'idée en fait donc là il y a
plusieurs idées hein mais par exemple on
peutencer à garder les sacrifices à base
t F3 pour après Esser d'aller manger G4
ouais et il y a aussi bien sûr la grosse
menace maintenant le tour H6 avec les
noirs pour aller manger F3 H3 quand je
mange H3 H4 tomberas forcément en fait
c'est hyper dynamique vraiment les les
les Noirs J c
blanche le fou en1 il est complètement
jeux il ne joue pas du tout et du coup
les Noirs jouent vraiment là-dessus et
c'est hyper intéressant ouais on a les
tours qui tapent un petit peu sur un mur
pour l'instant puisquon arrive à
défendre latéralement tout en attaquant
et du coup vous voyez là toute la nuance
en fait c'est que s'il avait encore son
pion H4 hein one forest c'est pour ça
qu'il l'a sacrifié il aurait pas ses
idées le long de la colonnage de mettre
la pression parce que le pion finalement
aurait été un défenseur pour Carlsen son
pion H4 cétait un petit peu un plot dans
la position qui servait à rien et du
coup il l'a envoyé au combat pour ouvrir
encore plus les ligne et créer des
thèmes donc ici c'est plutôt Magnus qui
est sous pression il se fait bien
attaquer et il a pas le droit à l'erreur
euh c'est Chud évidemment il a vu tout
ça donc il a pas joué H3 mais il a dû
jouer G5 quand même un coup qui fait
peur hein parce que le pion commence à
bien s'éloigner de du reste de l'armée
et il y a quand même cet alignement qui
est assez euh
effrayant on pourrait considérer des
idées pour tout de suite mettre la
pression donc après il va certainement
suivre avec H4 mais là c'est une partie
qui est extrêmement
euh extrêmement complexe et on sent que
tout peut se passer les trois joueurs
enfin les trois joueurs les deux joueurs
peuvent gagner la nulle est aussi bien
sûr un résultat possible mais trois
résultats moi j'ai moi j'aime bien les
Noirs en fait plus plus on passe du
temps sur la partie plus j'aime les
Noirs c'est position qui sont Mo aussi
j'ai l'impression plus facile à jouer
pour les Noirs parce que les blancs
doivent trouver toutes les toutes les
défenses et et en fait bon généralement
attaquer c'est plus facile pour défendre
ouais si on pouvait transposer ce ce
fuxin par ici là c'est sûr que ça ça
irait beaucoup mieux si le fou passait à
l'extérieur de la structure mais il y a
pas de chemin le chemin est
contrôl on sera gagné parce que j'ai
quand même de P de plus et cetera et on
pourrait mettre marche en avant mais là
en fait ce qu'on se rend compte c'est
qu'il y a que la dame qui défend avec
ses pions et alors que les pièces noires
elles sont quand même plus nombreuses à
roder autour du roi blanc et ces tours
bon alors certes ell mettent une
pression qui lie un petit peu les mains
des pièces noir mais bon elles sont
quand
même voilà bloqué et c'est pas si facile
deesser de se réactiver dans la colonne
B ça prend du temps et c'est pas
forcément si efficace non plus ce qui
fait que Carlsen je pense
que Ben une position dure d'un point de
vue humain je trouve que c'est difficile
d'être à sa place après il a une option
de plus donc là là vous voyez enfin même
l'ordinateur ici donc moi j'aime pas
trop parler de l'ordinateur mais
regardez ici il donne égal 00
l'ordinateur et il y a même de plus pour
les blancs et ce qui veut dire en fait
que normalement plus si on compte comme
ça mais mais en fait c'est
ilégalitéégalité alors on voit rien
d'immédiat ou forcé pour l'instant mais
en fait on voit simplement le potentiel
noir dans la position les les
compensations qui peuvent arriver qui
finalement l'ordinateur il pens que la
position elle estgale alors plus
position donc il y a quand même beaucoup
de contrejeu pour pour ce pion et même
l'ordinateur est d'accord donc euh
vraiment moi je j'ai envie de dire que
car il en difficulté partir il est en
difficulté il est en danger en tout cas
aprs ça veut pas dire qu'il pas gagé
hein mais il est quand même en grand
danger ici et ça serait une sensation
que Van forest l'emporte avec les pièces
noires c'est clair c'est clair il
justifierait largement du coup son titre
de son rôle en tout cas son nouveau rôle
de second an parce que on va dire qu' s
pas pas trompé en prenant de son équipe
il voit qu'il a beaucoup d'idées et que
c'est très intéressant de l'avir avec
soi alors là dans la partie de
marcandrea il s'est passé un truc un peu
bizarre alors on va on va on va switcher
ouais on va laisser car en caméra pour
voir alors attends on en était à tour 7
pass ouais alors il y a eu en fait tour
7 alors on Ava expliqué qu'il y avait
tour 7 et tour possible donc je pense
que Marr a dû raté l'idé de cavaler C8
qu'on avait évoqué tout à l'heure ouais
mais on pensait qu'il avait l'idée qu'
avait lieu V mais bon peut-être qu'il
l'avait en tout cas il l'a pas
joué là il a jage2 qui un coup que j'ai
du mal à comprendre honnêtement ouais il
a dû vouloir s'enlever de la diagonale
enin du vis-à-vis ouais et surtout mais
le problème c'est qu'a prend F2 et ben
euh et ben s tour au 8 et ben je va
attend qu'il revient donc je sais pas ce
il y a pas de vraie menace parce qu'on
peut on peut revenir
couvrir il faut faire attention aussi il
peut y avoir des menaces de mat hein
ouais donc c'est assz donc t c'est la
partie donc il y a eu tour E8 tour F7
tour F8 et tout recette ouais et il fait
ouais il a il a il a en gros tuas donné
un pion en un coup tu as la même
position qu'avant que tu as enlevé le
pion F2 c'est ça ouais je crois qu'il a
craqué encore il a dû commettre on a vu
qu'il avait malheureusement
déjà la première ronde qu' contre gang
il av fait une assez grosse erreur de
calcul il souffrait un petit peu mais il
a donné une pièce bah plus ou moins en
un coup quoi enfin et là on a vu hier
aussi que sur le fou F3 c'est contre
gère là il avait oublié le tour des7
intermédiaire donc il avait dû
abandonner donc j'ai l'impression que
tactiquement il est pas il est pas dans
le coup qui peut-être difficile
peut-être longtemps qu'il a pas joué
devant V je sais pas mais ça a l'air
très compliqué là parce que ça fait mal
si la défaite se confirme alors il y a
eu
H6 bah du coup qui évite tous les mats
du couloir et maintenant l'idée c'est de
menacer soit même mat avec les Noirs en
disant je me crée un abri euh et donc il
avit maintenant mais alors là du coup
c'est assez dingue qu'il l'IT pas
fait dans cette position pu que c'était
la même chose sans perdre le pion F2
ouais je sais pas ce qu'il a dû voir il
a d il a dû voir un fantôme peut-être il
a dû halluciner ouais il a dû après tour
7 là il y a H6 qui av le 8 et donc
maintenant en fait ils peuvent jouer la
même hein mais euh alors on a vu que
tout à l'heure il y avait cavalier prend
G7 qui fonctionnait je crois pas ça
marchait pas hein mais maintenant ça a
plus marcher bah tout à l'heure ça
marchait oui quand il y avait le
P
ici là ça marchait
pr on avait regardé ensemble on avait vu
que sur bon d ouais mais il y ouais il y
avait ça
euh et sur tour pron il y avait il y
avait mat du couloir on on avait regardé
différ donc ça marchait ce thème mais
euh dans la situation actuelle
maintenant qu' a h ça marche plus du
tout on est comme ça parce que bah il y
a plus le mat du couloir en fait il y a
la case achè tout simplement
ouais il a créé la case donc ça veut
dire qu'ici bah c'est la partie t F7 il
va se retrouver contre un ce qu'il a
fait dééchanger les tours et et
maintenant bah c'est juste c'est juste
foutu à part s trouve un perpè
miraculeux c'est tout ce qu'il peut
encore espérer mais il y a deux pions de
moins il y a deux pions de moins le Fou
est dominant donc au mieux il vaer
changer donc il aura une finale de dame
avec de P de moins et le pion a qui va
filer à Dame ce roi il devrait trouver
un abri en plus a les noir on peut
toujours menacer d'échanger les dames de
différentes façons ici c'est c'est
complètement perdant je pense qu'il y a
pas de ouais pense que quiment plus
aucune
chance donc là ça devient très difficile
parce que c'estra céit un petit peu la
partie pour se relancer avec les Blancs
contre la joueuse qui avait 0 sur
et une partie qui était intéressante
mais malheureusement encore bah une
ouais une gaffe sil y a pas d'autres
mots une gave de Marc Andrea qui a c'est
un petit peu perdu dans ses calculs et
du
coup bah faudra faudra faudra se
relancer après le jour de
repos coucou OL salut salut
Richard tu arrives au moment du du
craquage de notre petit prodige français
qui qui a beaucoup de mal pour l'instant
dans ce tournoi mais après la route est
longue il peut encore espérer bien sûr
se se reprendre alors est-ce qu'onirait
pas voir la partie de de M parce que là
il s'est passé encore quelque chose ok
alors
juste je te propose on retourne vite
fait sur car avant il y a eu deux coups
et après on bascule sur
mamedarov que la position est hyper
intéressante on peut d'ailleurs
peut-être avoir l'expertise de notre ami
OL qui est un fort maître international
au passage on peut le rappeler qui vient
d'arriver dans le chat qu'est-ce qu'il
pense de cette position euh je sûr qu'il
aurait peur avec les blanc leolia ici
serait pas très rassuré c'est pas
vraiment son style cette position avec
les Blancs
il est capable de jouer des positions
comme ça euh donc on était là et on a vu
à la caméra donc van forest qui été joué
tour F5 hein bon qui menace de manière
très directe le pion et bien sûr Caren a
défendu he c'était forcé par
H4 et fou fut à suivi donc on attaque la
tour ce F il va peut-être ensuite
revenir par ici et la dame se crée aussi
pourquoi pas un chemin pour mettre la
pression sur les
pions il Carlsen qui a reculé sa tour
j'ai l'impression en
C2 ok B il va quand même falloir
justifier ces deux pion enfin trouver un
moyen concret d'exploiter ces deux pions
he pour pour les noir faut faire
attention si
tu c'est vraiment très compliqué cette
position al est-ce qu'il peut pas
essayer d'attaquer le pion H4 il aura
peut-être juste dame G3 dame
G4 vousassz des sacrifices qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur fou comme fou7 en tout cas
tu as V l'impression que le roi blanc
est tout seul avec la dame quoi tu tu tu
vas pouvoir à un moment donné envoyer un
c'est la partie écoute je suis dans la
tête deant forest je fou
7 fallir prendre la fuite hein mon fut
prend G5 ici pour aller gagner la
dame c'est hyper intéressant cette
partie regardez si là on fait on fait
rien de spécial les bar pr G5 je jouer
un coup pour passer mon tour juste pour
pour montrer tout simplement
B le bouclier blanc qui éclate et les
fameux vis-àvis dont on vous parle
depuis le début du stream là qui sont
euh morteles et on gagnerait la dame
bien sûr carassan il va pas faire de
coup d'attente ici il va certainement
bouger son roi hein ouais je pense que
bouger le roi ça va être obligatoir
pourquoi il irait pas par là-bas en fait
bah il faut déménager bah oui se cacher
au centre euh avec son en D1 et je vois
ce qui se passe quoi e E2 il sera pas
mal il ça a l'air
bien2 mais il faut déménager en tout cas
que ouais commencer le déménagement
est-ce que
est-ce qu'on pourra quand même sacrifier
en fait que ça reste un coup he calculer
que prise tu reprends dam H 2 prise
alors tu reprends et attention que euh
madame qui peut arriver en F4 ou en B8
ah j'aime moins déjà parce que je mais
c'est pour voir parce que tour g l'idé
là c'estavoir un perpète juste pour
montrer ah non il il y a même dam H3 qui
gagne la
dame dame H3 gagne la dame
je juste ré
pour
bien ici et aprs
G4
C on va faire
contreer et au final j'ai une piè de
plus ma cha de P
leouend est-ce que du coup avant de
faire tour G est-ce qu'il y a moyen de
faire dame G4 dans la qu'on a regardé
pour empêcher le roi de
s'enfuir ro F prend g5end
ouais d G4 donc là je menace pas dame G1
mais que je menace dame F3 et ramener
un maintenant trop l'air de faire tu vas
tu vas faire des échanges tu vas même
mater c'est
trop et on nous propose F4 dans le chat
je pense icime F4 ça être juste la
prison pass si la prison pass nexistait
pas malheureusement ça serait le coup de
rêve là ce seraitah ser B si la prise en
passant parce que là tu consolides tes
pions mon fou revient en jeu en G3 je
vais pouser mon pion H5 ce serait
tellement le rêve maisant qui existe pas
l'ouier la PR passant et c'est le gros
problème de la position c'est qu'il y a
un pion noir en qui m'empêche à chaque
fois de faire la PR
ouais mais il reste combien de temps bon
les deux joueurs on c coup
pour une dizaine de minutes donc ça
devrait aller on va y revenir tu nous
disait que Mamed Douda c'était très
chaud donc on on va aller voir
ben l'URE ben Douda a gafé je pense
alors j'ai pas vu ce qui s'est passé
ouais parce que dou avit l' gagnant mais
avit l' gagnant et maintenant et ben il
a une qualité de Mo ou là effectivement
il a il a du gafé il est où Douda il est
par ici alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
on en était à à
on en
était il pr tout de suite ok son F C de
on pensait nous commencer par
H4 non mais attends mais pas ça la
partie bah moi j'ai ça j'ai tout reprend
C mais attends moi j'ai pas vu
ça moi j'ai vuain c'est chelou ce passé
moi j'ai vu
H4 t peut-tre un bug de
retransmission là je suis pas d mais
j'ai vu H4 tour3 E4 après c'est vrai que
ça paraît bizarre moi j'ai ça to tuas tu
as vu quoi ici là H4 j'ai V H4 tour E3
tour3 E4 non mais tour E3 c'est ah oui
ok tu prends en fait en en G3 prends G3
et je prends G6 après a là là je
cavalier prendre
F5 et là voir ce qu'il faut faire t
prend C2 ou reprend F5 je sais pas c'est
passé en fait est-ce que tu peux essayer
de voir si tu peux euh euh actualiser
chquier ou ce que j'ai fait parce que
moi je l'ai différent moi je te promet
pas même parti he mais site
j'actualisece qu' dit l'ordi mais moi
j'ai j'ai
ça chaud on n pas la même position on a
pas la même partie on pas la même
position ON étant tous les deux sur.com
ouais5
là ici là
ou ouais c'est extraordinaire du coup
attends voir sur la caméra c'est un peu
petit j'ai du mal à
voir moi
j'ai
pr juste moi ce que j'ai pour voir
plible
aussi c'est
bizarreiz c'est toi qui bug c'est pas
moi
ça l'air bizarre j'ai pas la M partie du
coup j'ai pas de je
va jeualiser la page ça ch quel
[Musique]
chose al maintenant j'ai la bon position
myux du coup ce qui s
passé pas le prier pas le dernier
ouis ok d'accord d'accord Richard donc
il a bien eu H4 donc il a gaffé ensuite
notre ami dou il a l'air de regarder on
voit sur la cam genre au loin et je
penseêre un peu de donc tour à 3 qui é
une façon un peu ingénieuse de de
défendre indirement le cavalier cavalier
il y aurait tourion G3 avec échec et
récup le cavalier derrière
voil donc ici il y a eu
E4 ok pourquoi
pas cavalier prend F5 et roi prend F5
tour prend donc on a on avait paré cette
position donc tour prend par av prend C2
et7 ou quoi et ça l'air ah il a gaffé oh
là là terrible c'était pas si facile à
voir en fait ici il y a c'est la
position qu' qu'on a évoqué avec deux
pièces pour pour tourpion mais les tours
qui peuvent pas trop faire d'échec donc
ça devait être sûrement gagnant pour les
noirs et fou C5 a l'air très naturel et
excellent ben en fait il y a une petite
pointe tactique que M a trouvé c'est G4
échec et al l'idée c'est que sur la
prise en
pass on va reprendre c'est assez bizarre
cette position vrai on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi pourquoi faut C5 est
tant une gaffe que ça
non l'ID ça de jouer
G4 si je fais un coup comme B6 F B6 pass
pas alors tu fais
B6 il dit
B4 VO admettons admett j'ai du mal j'ai
du mal à à bouger quoi G4 et on dit que
tu as du mal à
bouger
mais est-ce que tes pièces sont pas bien
organisé mais c'est très bizarre d'un
point de vue géométrique cette position
parce que F C5 a vraiment pas l'air
d'être une gaffe non non c'est le coup
le plus naturel et c'est quoi la
différence avec tour H7 montre-nous un
peu tour H7 si jamais il fait G4 et donc
t la différence qui était le meilleur
coup à priori et sur G4 maintenant on
fait juste 3 G5 en fait il y a plus ce
problème de tour 5 parce que quand ah
oui parce que parce que G4 était la
ressource tout à l'heure maintenant on n
plus un coup parce que du coup j'aurais
un pion passé en H4 c'est très fort et
là dans cette partie sur G4 ro G5 et ben
il y aura tour5
la différence c'est que là du coup on va
perdre le F ah mais G4ME quand même pas
mal ouais tu as raison non il y a F4 du
coup j'ai F4 encore mieux ou f44 et T
reprends
G6 il a plein de petites
magouilles et du coup c'était c'était
beaucoup plus complexe qu'il me
paraissait ouais ça avait l'air simple
enfin simple ça avait l'air bon pas trop
trop dur à tenir mais en fait il y avait
quand même des subtilités va être hyper
précis quoi mais du coup Doua il a pas
été précis par ici en fait dans cette
séquence il avait sûrement mieux parce
que bon on voit par l'ordi disait que
fou G7 c'était genre plus 3 C
complètement
gagnant mais c'était très complexeun
point de vue humain quand même fallait
pas se tromper mais trouver des bonnes
ressources D qui laisse passer sa chance
c'était quand même une belle occasion de
marquer le point avec noir alors on va
voir donc il s'est passé ça donc le
fameux fou C5 qui était qui était pas
précis du tout
G4
échec il a jou ro G5 quand même F4 donc
c'est la partie donc il veut vraiment
jouer pour le gar il a même préféré
sacrifier la qualité en disant mon P
très dangereux et peut-être qu'ici j'ai
encore des chances avec les
Noirs je pense qu'il a pas tort ça doit
sûement être objectivement nul mais ça
l'air plus dangereux pour les blancs
pour les
noir
H3 H3 mais attend
quoi il est en train de craquer
complètement non t C3 je vais oigé c'est
pas comment
tu pass
derrièreoi H2 je passeras pas H3
G3 je pas H3
toujours
il il va il va peut-être la perdre
euh il est peut-être ser un petit peu si
hein pour NDA qui l'a perd C là il a
fait une grosse partie ça ça fait penser
à à doub vidit d'hier un petit peu c'est
c'est en train de se retourner
complètement
ouais
ou ou al ou la partie de
de de de doubbof contre marov on voit
les noms qui se répètent h les
euh c'est
incroyable non c'est vraiment incroyable
t c'est
perdu on voit sur la caméra il est au
bout de sa ville
cont reste 20 secondes là pour jouer son
39e C il prendre une décision mais il
est
dégoûté il est dégoûté il
a jou h quand même a plus trop le choix
donc juste pour
revenir ici son erreur ça été d'avoir
poussé son PC mais il s'est mis tout
seul en difficulté en
fait c'est un peu comme comme il a trop
voulu par ici il aurait d se rendre
compte qu'il avait merdé et se contenter
de la nul il a voulu la tenter en
sacrifiant la qualité avec le pion h
visuellement ça a l'air quand même
dangereux et intéressant on se rend
compte que les tours sont
fortes que ce qui est actif bah
finalement il y a quand même des
problèmes de
clouage et le 40e coup été joué ro G3
c'est la position qu'on avait prévue et
maintenant ça doit être gant pour parce
que si le pion h tombe après bien sûr
c'est
terminé quand
mêmeortable bah c'est logiqueindre le
40e ah ok
d'accord donc on pourra revenir pour
voir plus tard tourner sur les Z not bon
ça fait longtemps qu'on est pas allé
voir
Venko mais je suisandme plus chaud pour
voir la fin du Z not de carass Forest je
sais pas ce que tu en penses ouais je je
suis d'accord aussi parce que c'est une
grosse grosse PR5 qui est parti mon cher
STF donc ét ah le roi le roi est resté
en G ouais il a pas joué alors était là
et ici donc car il NAA pas joué ro F1
comme on pensait pour se cacher à son il
a jou tour
B2 pour pour essayer de trouver du
contrej à colonne
B et là il y a eu fou pr G5 de jouer
après peut-être que là il se dit que
d'accord maintenant le Fou est cloué il
y a tour en l'air le Fou est cloué c'est
vrai qu'on menace pas on menace pas de
bouger le fou donc peut-être qu'il peut
bouger son roi maintenant
et du coup peut-être c'était
intéressant il se passait quoi si on
prenait avec la tour du
coup manger avec la tour je pouris
peut-être manger de les les deux tours
genre on prend pr pr prend et euh et
après euh bah ça tu as l'air plutôt
content avec les noir parce que tu vas
pas la perdre tu vas avoir ce perpè
surcasse blanche non
ouais B peut-être qu'il en voulait plus
hein ouais ouais
euh et je peux comprendre hein son là cl
tu qu envie de claquer
G5 et euh
ils ont plus beaucoup de temp c'est
quand même très très chaud parce que ça
est-ce que ça force nul ou est-ce qu'il
a une idée car ici pour
gagner bon h PR est forcé il faut manger
pour là il faut manger aussi admettons
que tu fasses un échec je sais rien pour
voir si c'est quelque chose tu vas
devoir
prendre je vois pas comment tu'échappe
du Dam G4
ouais non ça nul
ça du coup c'est étonnant parce que bon
on peut supposer
que que forest la vue en ça paraît dans
cette position tu le calcules forcément
en fait tu joues pour ça depuis le
début et tu as la nul en poche et du
coup tu le joues
pas et à la place donc il a pris avec le
le fou et je pense qu'il a dû rater ro
F1 non parce que maintenant
je sais pas ou alors vraiment il joue
pour le gars il en veut
plus parce que là imaginons je joue un
pe comme roi H7
ouais est-ce que jeess en fait de
défendre la tour G6 en fait là je
menace just donc tu vas manger j'imagine
pourend le problème c'est que là il y
aura un échec donc ça va pas c'est pire
donc c G7 peut-être dans
cette7 Prise t prend et damage 2 c'est
un peu la même ouais et mon roi qui va
partir sur D dame G4 comme tout à
l'heure jeiretour B7 la dame qui va
venir en H8 non mais ça va pas du tout
par par rapport à ce qu'on a regardé
c'est une grosse amélioration pour les
blanon a la tour dans la colonne
B est prête à à venir participer au
jeu va
arverussi'est-ce qu'il peut faire al
ici déf sa tour tout je pense pas
d'autre choix il a pas de ATT
compris8okel moment
bah je pense pe sur roi F1 peutêtre dame
A6 dame A6 par dame C8 pardon pour d A6
exusemi tour B6
ok t B6 j'empêche d A6 je t ouais6 tour
CB1 qui peut arriver aussi avec tour B8
attention a un problème sur la clouage
donc hyper intéressant comme
idée j'ai bien aimé l'idée ouis Clement
céit une bonne idée qui a l'air d'être
réfuté par tour
ici et alors attends il a joué quoi bah
regarde il a joué vraiment dans le même
esprit mais en
empêchant tour B6 il a jou dame à 7 il
menace dame à
6 et là du
coup du coup il y a sûrement roi2 qui
doit
gagner
par le RO qui
va
[Musique]
bien qu'il a pas oublié ce coup for
justement pour répondre
à dans le
chat joue alors je sais pas s'il a perdu
ou pas encore mais il était foutu
malheureusement avec les blancss une
partie intéressante il a fait une grosse
er de calcul on a
l'impression et du coup il avait une
finale avec de qui était à priori sans
espoir on va attendre la fin du not on
retournera voir si s'il se bat encore ou
s'il a
abandonné al je VO parti à regarder donc
il je crois que tu V aller voir ici
Penko mais il se passe pas grand grand
chose ouais on va on va rester il reste
trois coups avant le 40e on va rester
sur car for c'est quand même la partie
là la partie du jour peut-être et c'est
très très chaud et Prague qui il le
reste 10 coups à jouer aussi et Prague
ils sont à 6 minutes cont contre qu OK
et et pr qui a un avantage écrasant
dans il a réussi rentr tour sur la colon
il a toujours le qui va venir en4 pour
échanger les fous ok voir ça tout à
l'heure donc ça pourrait peut-être être
ça s le un résultat décisif pour pr ça
ferait plaisir pour
lui qui s'apprête à
jouer je pense que ro été oublié par
forest forest qui s Tromp qui pas pris
en bon G5 ici avec la bonne pièce he
c'est vraiment le tournant fallit
prendre avec une tour à priori pour
forcer la nulle et euh il faut prend G5
il je sais pas s'il a oublié qu'après il
était cloué ou juste il pensait que
cette ressource était forte mais euh
peut-être que roi E2 il a il a il a
oublié ce coup on verra moi je pense
qu'il joue moi je pense qu'il joue la
win hein ouais il joue la win mais bon
là là il va peut-être perdre dans trois
coups quoiou d' ouais oua et euh je
pense que nul avec il était quand même
assez content surtout avec une telle
partie je sais pas je sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'il a raté mais certainement
tactiquement
ouais ouais jadis il doit être gagnant
Magnus ça reste chaud mais en fait ce
qui fait qu'il est à priori gagnant
c'est que il a ce clouage en fait ce fou
il menace pas vraiment de découverte
parce que il y a la tour qui est en
l'air sur échec qui plusé donc c'est un
vrai problème pour
les pour les noirs et si le roi arrive à
se cacher bah il y aura juste fout plus
dame
G4 donc dame G4 qui na pas l' d'être le
coup gagnant alors on va voir roi E2 on
va essayer de voir qu'est-ce qui a fait
peur à Magnus sur
RO2 donc sur l'échec on peut pas aller
sur cas par que là il 3 non non il y a M
pire que ça ou mat
pardon j'étais C avec j'étais oui
focalisé sur cette sur ce visavis pour
vous montrer que dem général c'est une
mauvaise idée d'aller sur case noire
mais oui a bien sûr il y a plus fort
donc on va en D1 et dame D3 échec
qu'est-ce qu'il a raté tour des de parce
que il y a plus
d'échec donc a priori c'est pas ça mais
après je mange le fou et ça va quoi bah
après tu manges le ouais
ou donc il a il a laissé le Dr en F1 du
coup il a joué on va revenir à la partie
il a joué dame
g44 bizarre ça parce qu' dame
quoi va revenir après Mo qu'il pensé
faire tour
ici t je
dis c'est trop compliqué cette position
en
fait coup d'ordinateur pour le
coup c'est monstrueux ce défend la tour
on menace
F2 là c'est trop compliqué pour pour des
êtres humains
surtout que c'est pas
incl ta
pièce et du coup s'enlever
visis donc revenir dans le mauvais
visis et maintenant pour faire et on
défend
et là serait très dangereux pour les
noir très très complexe
c'est des variantes brutes de calcul
d'ordinateur donc je sais pas si son
idée c'est on voit qu'il réfléchit
peut-être il vient de se rendre compte
de quelque chose parce que Dame de comme
suggéré dans le
chat ben ouais je sais pas déjà la
finale elle donne quoi admettons pour
voir mais prise et prise H4 ça on a
récupéré nos deux pion moins mais c'est
vrai que on est peut-être un peu faible
ici mais on a du contre jeu là mais le P
F2 qui do tomber aussi
ouais c'est pas simple après Carson il
peut vouloir rentrer dans une petite
finale comme ça
mais on n pas peut-être pas obligé de
manger parce que là maintenant il y
aurait des menaces de mat de
partout en tout cas il reste plus que 4
minutes au champion du monde il reste
deux coups à jouer donc on va bientôt
dénouement de ces notes et on saura plus
sur qui joue
pourquoi vous pensz qu'il allait gagner
bon il fallait
trouver il fallait trouver roi
2 alors du coup de quoi il a eu peur sur
ro 2 il y a forcément quelque chose qui
le gênait admettons un coup pour
défendre la tour
maintenant prise je sais pas avec quoi
on
prend c'est vrai que ça avit quand même
l'air bien tu mets ton roi à l'abri non
de partout ouais tu mets ton roi à
l'abri et après tu vois ce qui se passe
quoi il y a pas de menace
et je sais pas ce qu'il a raté sur 2 je
pense qu'il a dû rater C8 je pense un
coup assz
caresque en plus ou en plus coup qui
vraiment dans son style quoi améli la
position ça CIT je pense dans R oua
effectivementchange les dames il
aurasataque pour noir mais le problème
c'est que au passage donc dans ce qu'on
vient de regarder ici ce qui repère s de
pions d'avance donc certes il va plus se
faire mat mais il a plus d'avantage
matériel donc il a peut-être encore des
petites chances en final
mais il était sur le point en fait il
pouvait potentiellement gagner une pièce
que je je vous rappelle il y a ce fou
qui est cloué donc on menaçait de de
gagner au prochain CP alors le D de
réussir à sauver son roi donc et
apparemment roi 2 on arrivit à mettre le
roi à l'abri et à manger le
fou c'était pas si facile mais ça
semblait quand même dans la range du
champion du monde quand même C RO2 ouais
clairement c'est assez naturel on voit
qu'il y a plein de problèmes tu veux tu
veux t'en aller tu veux te
cacher ça a été raté ça a été raté et
maintenant il se remet à réfléchir donc
ça veut dire que il vient de se rendre
compte qu'il a raté quelque chose parce
que c'est évident que sur que que quand
il a joué dame G4 là à l'instant il
avait prévu dame A6 bah donc il aurait
dû répondre à tempo et à mon avis il
avit prévu du coup tour 2
il pensait gagner une pièce derrière il
pensait gagner et il a dû se rendre
compte là qu'il dam C8 qui faisait très
mal et du coup il a joué B roi
G1 il a joué roi G1 bon il est en train
de lu dire quand même je t'attaque pas
trop G5 mais je t'attaque des
pièces et il reste
maintenant 2 minutes 50 pour Carsen 6
pour Van forest deux coups pour le
joueur ACL noir
tu joues quoi c'est
chaud pas facile à jouer non
plus l'idée c'est quoi c'est que si bon
si on mange le fou ça bien s on va
gagner la dame et la
partie si on mange la
tour ah mais attention parce
que dans le mêmeprit G7 c'est très dur
le but ici c'est être de sécuriser cette
tour pour pouvoir bouger le fou et faire
une enfilade sur la
dame C5 pour défendre ta
tour non mais ça c'est très dur à
défendre cette position on est au 39e là
ouais il reste deux coups al les joueurs
ils sont très heureux d'avoir leur à
jour au
40e il reste un coup chacun à jouer pour
avoir le r tout
temps mais reste deux pour V forest pr
qui fait une une œuvre d'art on voir aès
la parti qui faitessionnellement c'est
c'est Master Class tour G7 ça ça l'air
très
compliqué parce que c'est pas un coup
facile à jouer tu as quand même
plusieurs choses en prise le problème
c'est que tu peux pas te permettre de
bouger ta tour alors ici pens non il y a
juste prise c'est terminé il y a des
éche il peut peut-être trouver il peut
peut-être trouver tour G7 par défaut
parce qu'il trouve rien d'autre
et peut-être que Carlsen ici en fait il
a prévu ça il pense juste ici qu'il est
gag donc il y a pas de défense pour les
Noirs ce ce qui est plausible en réalité
hein c'est tellement compliqué
ici mais roagen qui jurait un tel coup
ouais j'avoue faut être courageux ici ou
sûr de ses
calculs surtout que le roi il vient de
là o venait de fuir et il estime que la
dame du coup maintenant un peu en jeu
et donc il peut se permettre de de
revenir en
G1
h encore 4 minutes pour mon fress là
c'est vraiment le moment de de sortir le
grand
jeu je sais pas est-ce que c'est le seul
coup pour faire n le tour
G7 d'après d'après les machines mais
nous en tant qu'être humain je voir
pourquoi par exemple C5 alors C5 a l'air
d'être idée aussi ça c'était mon idée
sans tricher le premier coup qui me
venait à l'esprit alors c'est de
défendre euh la tour et surtout
peut-être des fois si la dame parfois
elle va revenir en jeu par
ici ça enlève aussi parfois des
tactiques dans la colonne C donc C5 un
coup qui m'a l'air
intéressant avec donc l'idée sur dame
prend alors quelle découverte on fait
quelle découverte al il a il a joué il a
joué tour G
ah il a fait T g mais l'idée dans C dans
c'est que sur
G6 tout à l'heure et ben je
prends la
différence mais donc dans le même idé il
a joué il a joué tour G7 donc aussi on
sait que c'est un bon
cou et maintenant il le reste le 40e
chacun et c'est à Magnus de décider il a
2 minutes est que je cette tour ou pas
alors quels sont ces autres candidats
est-ce qu'il peut faire échec par
exemple d'aurs sur
échec je sais pas si ça marche mais pe
avir le coup Maron fou des8 c'est qu' on
se laisse manger sur échec mais pour
aller clouer la
dameend il H7 et au final ben maintenant
tu fais quoi avec ta dame voilà alors on
tour attends il y a tour des7 non tour
des7 assz joli magnifique tour des7
contre clou du contre clou donc là c'est
vraiment un
une partie le meilleur bricoleur qui va
l'emporter du coup tu dév la tour et
derrière en plus c'est le carnage ce qui
fait que là c'est vraiment ultra
tactique et avec si peu de temps c'est
très facile de se tromper donc là il
faudrait jouer tour F8 je pense
pour pour pas avoir de problème et
gagner la dame
ensuite très très
chaud je pense pas qu'on aura il a pas
joué encore je pense pas qu'on aura cet
échec du coup à cause de ça qui a l'air
de
marcher mais qu' va manger là on a tour
prend C6 qui a un coup apparemment donc
là c'est c'est juste le moment de de
brancher
alpha alpha 0 sur son cerveau parce
qu'on se retrouve avec toutes les pièces
en prise de partout donc jouer un tel
coup avec 2 minutes à la
pendule bon courage quand même
alors quelle est l'idée en plus de tour
pr CCI c'est pas évident parce que on
aimession qu'on donne juste une tour et
que la position finalement demeure à peu
près
pareil s'il prend directement F5 et ça
perd en fait il se fait matter il va
peut-être c'est peut-être le seul coup t
prend
c6ci j'ai
l'impression t C6 et il a joué tour B8
Magnus il a pas trouvé don t pr C6 qui
était peut-être introuvable et Magnus
qui pourrait qui pourrait la perdre avec
les blancs en tout cas c'est lui je
pense que fou va partir
ici un peu qu' un peu
surpris va j F il a sa dame audessus du
Fou voilà fou qui part qui fait très mal
qui est très
joli incroyable partie c'est la partie
par mais en fait ici P dans quelques
secondes là ouais le seul coup euh le
seul coup c'était tour pr C6 apparemment
pour
Caren dame pr F5 c'était tu faisais mat
t tu
perdais donc tour B8 fou D8 ce qu'on
vient de regarder et il va y avoir tour
F8 et après ça peut être une forteresse
ça qui est rigolo aussi hein parce que
si tuarrive à faire fou B4 à 3 échec
alors on va voir regardez c'est assez
marrant donc la dame qui va tomber hein
mais je pense que ça peut être bien
d'intercaler cet échec ouais bouche peu
importe où on donne sur la tour et der
on joue à3 et ça eu bah l'idée c'est de
dire bon ben on a tout verrouillé sur
case noire mais après bon il faut faire
attention le roi qui peut monter euh
est-ce qu'on peut avoir une forteresse
ici en tout cas car qui est bah
célèbrement réputé pour ne pas croire
aux forteresse après je sais pas à quel
point il il a déclaré ça il le pense
mais il va serouver dans une situation
voudrait mieux pour lui que les
forteresses existent puisqueil va devoir
se battre pour la
nul petite sensation quand même dans ce
dansci avec finalement un un forest qui
s'est trompé alors qu'il pouvait forcer
la nul mais c encore compliqué carassen
qui s'est trompé en
retour dans un feu d'artifice
tactique on coup estce qu'onit pas avir
la de exactement
oner voir
Prague PRAG contre grandius on va
essayer de tu as la position qui est
quand même largement
Faur tour sur la 7e le pion 5 qui va
tomber le P D5 qui est passé qui va et
ça a l'air écrasant
là qui un jour oui non là c'est
grandandéus va encaisser sa trème
défaite en quatre parties je pense que
après le rajout temps il devrait
abandonner on voit d'ailleurs même à
l'image il a l'air
dépité le petit PRAC qui est en train de
se masser les cuisse là en mode vas-y
abandonne c'est bon c'est la position
classique du joueur des on la connait
cette posture genre quand tu te penches
un peu en avant comme ça tu sais que
c'est c'est en train de bien se
passer c'est c'est on va revenir on va
voir comment ils en sont arrivés là mais
oui comme tu tu l'as dit c'est
démonstration positionnelle ah ouais non
mais c'est grandi a le plus la
sortie
j'avoue il est il est dans la
confidence le pauvre grandeux ça ça dev
très dur 05 sur 4 tu es vraiment la
victime de ce tournoi et Prague Mo il
prend son temps il fait ro
f2ou quand tu es pas en forme dans dans
un tour aussi fort comme ça c'est c'est
c'est dur ça peut être très très long
bah on a vu l'an dernier c'est Maxime
qui était pas en forme il a fait un de
ses pires tour je pense honnêtement le
penalty et tout le monde veut passer
dessus quoi et du coup il avait perdu
beaucoup de points l au passage il avait
gagné une seule partie et c'était un
miracle CIS CIT contre donchenenko alors
qu'il avait une poubelle avec les blanc
il avait gagné mais on sait pas comment
une car F3 ouais ouais non il
étaitêtement foutux et et 13 rondes dans
un tel événement quand ça se passe mal
c'est très très long quoi tu as envie
juste que ça s'arrête en fait tu fais
des Nules dans que ça s'arrête donc là
0,5 sur 4 on va attendre que la partie
se termine mais
alors il a un échec il a pas joué il a
joué tour hchin tour hchin il a quand
même tour qui rentre chez l'ennemi il a
un peu de
contement en
antipation et du coup c'est de
faireali peamener
une ser
jouer temp normalement tranquillement
pas tromper on va revenir en arrière tu
veux pour voir un peu comment il en
arriv là
ouais on s'était arrêté euh ah bah
justement par ici ouais il y avait eu
fou F6 je crois à 5 juste pour juste
intermédiaire ipit ça fait nul ok bon on
ira voir vite fait comment comment s'est
terminé après ça
hen ils ont joué la finale à tour F8
ouais par ce qu'on avait prévu hein ça
c'est c'est sûr mais du coup la par donc
là jusque là tout ce qu'on a prévu hein
ouais la partie de Caren risque de durer
du coup euh dame H3
dame
G7 ok il revient pour mettre une petite
pression il
tourne j'avance un petit peu vite pour
voir cavalier F6 ok parce que beaucoup
de C ont été joués depuis plus d'une
quinzaine on a vu en tout cas qu'il a
tricoté il profite du fait que la
position soit fermée il crée des petites
menaces un coup sur le pion5 un coup sur
F5 joue un coup à droite un coup à
gauche il profite de son avantage
positionnel pour mettre la pression ça y
est la colon qui s'ouvre une fois que la
tour adverse est partie et il décide de
faire le petit ro c'est marrant après
avoir ouvert la colonage se rend compte
qu'il a plus vraiment d'attaque
maintenant ce quiintéresse
c'est l'ame et c'est comme ça qu'il a
gagême le au 29e coup les
gars normalement c'est pas trop trop
conseillé
mais alors F4 qui un coup qui enterre
vraiment le F case noir en espérant
trouver un peu d'attaque avec les pions
ouis pas forcément très inspiré quand
même grand c'est encore aujourd'hui
parce que il il va subir ensuite dans la
7e et on a eu finalement ce qu'on
redoutait tant pour lui enfin ce qu'on
avait annoncé c'estàd qu' fallait
surtout pas pour les Noirs échanger ses
F de ce blanche et se retrouver avec ce
bon cavalier contre le mauvais fou et
ben vous allez voir que c'est ce qui
s'est
passé voilà fou G
et ça c'est maintenant c'est le
cauchemar pour on peut mettre
l'ordinateur juste pour vous donner une
idée c'est assez rigolo c'est égalité
matérielle l'ordinateur il dit plus 5
pour les blancs comme si on avait une
tour de plus c'est pour vous dire à quel
point c'est écrasant voyez les tour
blanches qui vont arriver sur sur la 7
rangée le fou qui est cloué qui qui est
mal placé le
C le pion E5 qui est faible D qui est
pas
protégé il il f tout ce qu' ve en fait
la position stratégiquement on les gagné
voilà exactement c'est
euh c'est une catastrophe ce qu'il a
fait quand même
grandélus et euh bon Masterc de de
Prague al juste il laisse un tout petit
peu de contrejeu on en est là non on en
a ro ouais il laisse un tout petit peu
de contrejeu mais normalement il devrait
même au pire c'est pas grave d'changer
une tour il pourra toujours gagner de
toute façon si se retrouve avec le
cavalier contre le fou en finale ça sera
très facile je pense
ouais trouvera un moyen de rentrer avec
son roi d'une façon ou d'une autre euh
ok donc il va peut-être prendre un peu
de temps là on est on est au 40e pour
réfléchir comment convertir
h je te propose d'aller voir vite fait
comment ils ont fait nul et après on
fera une petite pause yes donc vraiment
moi je trouve vraiment très très
impressionnant cette frag moi je l'avais
on avait en Top 12 avec avec lui et puis
cou et les petits copains indiens là il
anné et puis à un moment donné il joue
contre Elana anov c'est quand même
ancien top 10 mondial ouais et il était
gagnant et il craque un petit peu en
fait il finit par faire nul dans la
partie donc bon à l'époque c'était il y
a il y a 2 ans donc là il a 16 ans il
avait 14 ans et 14 ans grand maître
2550 cadeau enfin monstrueux quoi et en
fait il fin contre contre elanov en se
faisant arnaquer un petit peu et puis là
là il y a Romu donc Romu c'est le
capitaine de l'équipe he qui donne une
petite tape dans l'épaule à à gche à
frag dit gen genre bon ben bravo quand
même quoi tu vois genre c'est cool quoi
et euh et il lui dit ouais mais
t'inquiète pas tu marqu la prochaine
fois et euh et et là Prague il lui dit
non non mais t'inquiète pas je l'ai
battu il un mois quoi en fait il a moi
il avait déjà collé à yov qui était
encien top 10 et en fait lui des joueurs
à 2006 2007 il av déjà BTU plein à
l'époque bah il il il avait 14 ans à
l'époque ouais c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment moi je le trouve hyper hyper
impressionnant hyper talentueux et et
c'est bien pour ça que je je je je par
sur lui he on va voir on va voir comment
il s'en sort en tout cas là c'est bien
il va remonter à la moyenne à priori
faut qu'il finisse le travail h
ouais donc on va juste regarder comment
visite qui est le leader du tournoi je
vous le rappelle tu vas peut-être être
rejoint par V forest si V forest crée la
sensation cont Caren saura dans les dans
les minutes et heures peut-être même à
venir parce que la partie pourrait durer
donc donc ouais il avait les blancs on
en était resté là il venait d'attaquer
le P F7 ça était défendu par
F6 il eu tour 1 pour créer un petit
vis-àvis mais on a vu quepinko encore
une fois très solide avec les Noirs
ouais il très solide tout court
d'ailleurs très dur à battre oui euh ok
il y cet échange
là alors il y avait une double l'attaque
donc on pouvait pas manger le pion C3
fallait fallait résoudre le problème
bien sûr c'était prévu vu en amont Paro
CAH E7 dame G4 le pion C3 qui tombe donc
là il gagne un pion après il y a des
compensations je pense d'ordre dynamique
et ça avit dû être calculer par par vid
fou F4 dame C5 échec le roi qui qui se
cache donc là faut faire quand même un
peu attention il y a des menaces sur
case noire sur le
roi roi h quand même il a pris des
risques f un peu son dame pour essayer
de de créer du jeu donc
H4 pe essayer de jouer H5 ensite mais il
envoyé le pion D
dame6 et du coup il a proposé nul CIT
accepté c'est marrant dans ce tourno on
peut proposer nul mant ça commence à
être un petit peu à la mode de pas
pouvoir faire nul par accord mutuel
avant le 40e dans pas mal de top tour ou
pass quoi juste sur tour B3 à la place
de de B4 ouis je sais pas tour prend B3
alors dame
D7 et ah si cavalier bouge dame F5 avec
le cavalier bouge ah je c'est pas de
bonne case en fait ça le problème sur C
G6 on va montrer il y a
H5 sur la prise là il va voir des
problèmes de mat du couloir qui vont
arriver ça va ça va être compliqué ok
d'accord je
euh ok donc qui pouvait pas prendre D4
ça d'être plutôt un bon coup justement
pour contrôler les cases et dam 6 je
propose nul ok ça accepté est-ce qu'il
pouvait pas jouer ici pass quoi sur
comme car F5 par
exemple attends ils ont fait nul non
attendsattends qui a pas essayé de la
jouer quoi
incroyable alors on va pas partir en
tout de suite on va voir comment c'est
TER ils ont joué ils ont joué 10 coups
ils ont joué 10 coups après le 40e en
bullette quoi euh on va revenir au
direct donc on on été resté là on a vu
qu' on gagnait la dame on avait annoncé
qu'on avait essayé de faire cette
forteresse pour solidifier avec A3 ça a
été joué pour vraiment tout verrouiller
h roi G6 3 G2
ok il a mis la tour
Hin c'est5 ouis il veut faire dame G6
rapidement je pense ça ouais ok oui
sonion lui sert à rien
ouais pour comprendre et euh ah il a
fait perpè il a pas trouvé d'idée ok
si si le roi avance trop je peux faire
aussi du H5 faire attention c'est vrai
après tu te dis que tu as le perpè quand
même quand tu veux avec les Blancs ouais
quand tu veux mais ok ils ont fait une
partie sympa tous les deux qui a bien
raté le roi de
roi ouais je m'attendais pasce que ça se
termine si vite honnêtement non moi je
pensais ça allait ça allait être une
torture pour car bah je pense ça Ava été
l'inverse Caren ilurait il l'aurait joué
hein avec les noir c'est sûr évidemment
et on voit que M a gagné en même temps
en même temps qu'ils ont fait nul a
gagné il nous rest donc on va on va
regarder rapidement tu ve il a gagé
juste très vite ouais donc G4 il a eu
peur de l'avancée du pion je pense que
là quand même dit attention à des Réau
de mat mais tuas tour H3 très important
tu tiens tout et tu es inatacable en
faite
après tour H3 tu deviens inattaquable
hyper fort hyper important le RO peut
pas passer et maintenant on a jage qui
quelle horreur quoi c'est même les
blancs qui vont gagner quoi quelle
horreur qu et du coup je comprends mieux
maintenant pourquoi il a fait mieux là
on voit que les deux joueurs ils sont
amis ils discutent qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
raté
is ok bon on va aller voir on va aller
laisser bon du coup une nulle
spectaculaire qui
resteés 3 G3 3
G3 et juste 3 B3 abandon
ouais bah tu peux pourquo rien faire
parce que si tu joues cavalier H3 il va
y avoir tour C3 voilà on va manger le
cavalierc le cavalier c'est la tour se
met devant en F3 et ben je mange la tour
en F3 et après je Mang gag je Remer
ouais si M devant ben je mange en F3 je
mange en H3 et après je peux même manger
en H2 VO et là bon on a deux contre un
donc le roi est plus proche donc ça va
gagner assz
facilement donc icioup si je joue pas
cavali H3 pas de coup j'ai pas de coup
il il est en Z en quelque sorte mon
prochain coup ça va être tour C3 éche
voilà admettons par exemple tour échec
je juste cacher mon ro OK et qu'est-ce
que tu fais avec les Noirs c'est ça le
problème c'est que le pion H2 va tomber
en fait ton roi il est on surcharge et
le cavalier et le
Fou et du coup bah bon on peut pas
donner le et le le pion pardon pas le
fou on peut pas donner le cavalier et
bah par la force des choses on va perdre
le pion et après bon cette finale on
aura une qualité de plus on aura deux
contre 1 et le 1 va tomber c'est terminé
il y a pas
de pour ça qu'il a abandonné en fait il
il a pas de coup ceion ce pion H2 qui a
l'air dangereux bah il est juste stoppé
par derrière c'est assez dramatique là
pour Douda c'est cette défaite euh qui
lui qui était gagnant il y a quelques
coups et donc c'est la première victoire
de dans le tournoi qui bah passe euh
dépasse son adversaire du
jour on peut voir peut-être si qu'on a
un classement en direct est-ce qu'on
faire un petit point que class class tu
do être en en direct ouis il a pas
encore été mis à jour ah siil a été mis
à
jour si si oui vidit vidit est toujours
seul en tête et maintenant a
comment tu peux
l'afficher c'est ce que j'ai
fait
j'aiés ce que j'ai fait et du coup on a
maintenant 5 joueurs à 2 et dem
derrièrepport Forest et PRAG qui
remontera à la moyenne avec de points
donc coup d'arrêt pour dou par
contre coup d'arrê pour
JeanChristophe
on dans le
chengette
fins
vite
compr euh alors qu'il pouvait essayer de
jouer K8 tout de suite pour créer des
des magouilles sur le pion G7 et et il a
joué roi H2 donc juste t prend
F2 et on a eu la même position avec le
pion qui a disparu tout simplement et
après avec deux pions de moins bah
c'était c'était perdu on a vu il y a eu
des échanges on s'est retrouvé dans une
finale de dame et là sa seule chance
c'est un échec perpétuel mais euh ou
mais c'était illusoire le roi est bien
protégé donc là le chinois qui a su euh
qui a su conclure proprement qui elle
débloque son compteur et laisse du coup
la place de lanterne rouge au français
ouis pion on en avit parlé depuis le
début je dis attention à ce pion moi il
me fait un peu peur sur le long terme
bah c'est lui qui a qui a apporté la
vioire petite triangulation c'est assez
joli hein comme elle a fait était bien
se caché donc on couvre les échecs et on
défend le pion et maintenant c'est
terminé il suffit de menacer de rentrer
sur la première
rangée et il y a pas de
perpétuel donc c'est propre et du coup
du coup défaites douloureuses pour pour
le français faudra vraiment qu'il arrive
à hausser son niveau après le jour de
repos alors demain demain il va jouer
contre la joueuse russe chouvalova
ok avec les Noirs j'imagine avec les
Noirs donc elle a battu la ziner la et
elle a perdu contre murzine perdu contre
erwiin lami et 2 nul maintenant contre
un grand mat
2006en tourno donc elle fait un
[Musique]
tournoi à sonlo à peu près ouais donc
donc il a les Noirs donc ESS de voir
s'il peut aller la chercher ok euh bon
écoute on va faire cette petite pause
maintenant qu'on a quasiment tout vu
hein finalement il il que praganda à
voir dans ce dans ce tournoi ouais et
euh euh parce qu'on a fait le tour un
petit peu des autres parties et donc
PRAG qui fait vraiment cette master cl
là on va voir comment il nous termine ça
il a plus il a plus qu'à conclure
normalement il devrait
ouis il devrait pas faire trop du
plaisir je P grandilius on va voir si
proprement après là on peut imaginer on
peut imaginer peut-être une roi E2 ou
tour à 1 on pensait aussi ouis tour 1
avecidée que sur dame dame H4 échec
écouté il VI de jouer tour 1 à la caméra
voilà bon on va voir ça peut durer quand
même un petit peu parce que même si
c'est écrasant faut encore convertir
d'un point de vue matériel donc on va
revenir après la pause pour l'exécution
à priori de de cet avantage par le
petits prodiges dire yes à tout
àheureite
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors nous sommes de retour les amis
pour la partie de Prague alors est-ce
que Prague va faire le plaisir de gagner
cette cette super
partie peut supposer queoui hein ce
serait vraiment décevant sinon de gâcher
une telle telle prestation à priorie une
belle petite mastercl
stratégique grandéius qui depuis le
début tourno a beaucoup de mal je trouve
en milieu de jeu il prend pas forcément
les bonnes décisions pas les bons plans
et il se fait punir parti après
partie
pourant qui un fort jouur mais qui est
un peu irrégulier aussi qui a un style
parfois un petit peu
fantasque quand ça se passe mal ça peut
très mal se passer moi j'avais joué
contre lui à Capelle la grande il y a
très longtemps c'était très mal passé
pour moi
j'ai pires parties je pense contre un
fort
jouur je pas trop moqué de lui quoi
après ce qu' m'a
mis il est il est incroyable j contre
lui dans T ch et j'avais pas beaucoup
beaucoup survécu m'avait défoncé et
grandéius il est vraiment il est
vraiment très fort
et mais voilà là il fait un tournoi là
il fait un tournoi très difficile très
très fort et il joue cont les joueurs
qui sont en forme ais il a pas la confi
ouais quand tu es pas en forme dans un
tour comme ça ça peut très très vite mal
tourner et c'est difficile là là on voit
franchement les un peu les
difficultés
franchement je c'est un peu de peine
pour lui parce moi j'aime beaucoup ce
joueur oui c'est un jouur sympa en plus
il ras une grosse barbe avant de Viking
un petit peu parfois il l' eu c'est un
petit moment qu'
l' peutre que s ch de p comme suér
plusieurs fois dans le chat ça pass m
pour
les problème le P le pte
poisss je crois pas qu'il depu le début
tour
ouis là il cherche il cherche mais
problme c'est qu' a rien à trouver
quo si on joue un coup comme par
exemple
H4 le prier coup
regarder pas le
CH y a échec
et il y a pas pour comme ça en disant m
voilà je REM ta tour non parce
que on ferme la porte
ce qui fait qu'ici tu vas te retrouver
un petit peu bah
contraint de manger là ENF en fait tu
peux rien faire quoi ça le problème
c'est ça ça joue pas
et et donc si tu manges là ta dame tu
peux faire dame G3 même là je laisse
même là j'ai envie de faire dame à7 là
tu peux me faire dame
Hux F1 qui arrive même ça enfin c'est en
fait juste pour expliquer l'idée de ma 7
euh c'est qu'en fait même quand il prend
G2 ben j'ai j'ai j'ai ro j'ai cavalier
F2 et en fait tu passes jamais faut dire
d'ailleurs le
cavalier tu le sais certainement St
c'est le meilleur défenseur devant un
roi pour parer les échcs face à une dame
cavalier quand il est devant il est
hyper bon pour bloquer parce que là il y
a des pions imaginez que même si ces
pions qui font un peu rempard n'étit pas
là il y aurait pas plus d'écheec parce
que le cavalier contrôle vraiment les
cases autour donc donc là le roi
strictement rien par contre bah la la
boutique la boutique noire va s'écrouler
à l'eld dam donc c'est une option je
pense qu'il y a tout qui gagne en fait
ici grandéus il doit chercher de manière
un peu désespérée mais je vois pas
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire d'autre que
damage 4 il a des fourchettes aussi qui
peuvent traîner parce que ouais mais
c'est je pense que c'est c'est c'est
c'est
c'est c'est une position qui est bah qui
est perdue en fait il il y a zéro Arac
là il charge de ressources mais en fait
je peux même comme on a vu donner le PG
de à chaque fois je me faux même pas
autant à la limite si les de joueurs
étaient en bulette il aurait une micro
chance mais là Prague il a il a sont
rajou d'une de de 40 minutes même non
donc il lu reste plus d'une demi-heure
pour pour concrétiser il y a pas de cas
ici où il où il se trompe je pense he
c'est c'est vraiment facile même à notre
niveau ce serait hyper facile donc her
ouis her ça FA je pense que même nous on
B grand des ici ah bah bah sinon ça
serait inquiétant pour
nous ah là là là en fait on censé battre
alpha Z0 en fait c'estd que tu peux
mettre un magicien tu peux pas transform
le transformer il y a aucune chance
pratique c'est ça le problème tu peux
pas vraiment te poser de problèm tu peux
pas essayer de nous finter de nous
embêter
euh juste
c'est les pièces sont sont trop
mauvaises en fait ce fou c'est c'est
vraiment pour le coup hein le c'est un
pl
quoi il est derrière sa cha de pion noir
et juste il sert à rien c'est terrible
pour non c'était vraiment franchement
une une belle
démonstration stratégique hein de la
part de de Prague dans cette partie
franchement très très c'est parti dans
toutes les écoles ce que j'ai beaucoup
aimé c'est le côté il jou un petit peu
un coup à gauche un coup à droite donc
vraiment sur les deux ailes et puis
comme on l'a vu très tardivement au 29e
coup il finit par roquer malré
l'ouverture de la colonneage en disant B
bah finalement c'est à l' dame que je
vais prendre l'avantage décisif h en
plus c'est marrant parce que
généralement l'école indienne c'est
vachement tactique en fait ils sont très
tactiques et ils aiment bien envoyer un
peu et en fait pragalanda il a toujours
été différent de de boueh de Sarine de
tous ces ces petits copains indiens qui
en 2006 et et lui il a toujours été il a
toujours été hyper hyper positionnel et
euh et euh ouis je trouve qu'il est il
est vraiment très très brillant ce genre
moi je je je suis fan numéro
1 j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup voir
ces parties Prague c'est c'est vraiment
propre et et c'est c'est fou qu'à ceage
là il arrive à à à jouer à être si
propre et à maturité pour son ouais
c'est c'est incroyable parce que ok tu
peux donner une leçon tactique à
nimporteir Mme à tu peux le TAC tu
peuxux mais stratégique comme ça un
joueur aussi expérimenté comme ça à à
seulement 16 ans c'est quand même c'est
quand
même c'est quand même beau quoi c'est
impressionnant Gondorf qui qui a donc 4
mois il peut il peut se passer beaucoup
de choses en 4 mois faut y croire d'ici
16 ans tout est
possible c'est vrai qu'il est en train
de de réfléchir réfléchir grandilius
mais bon il est aussi je pense en phase
d'acceptation la défaite quoi ici parce
que il peut réfléchir autant qu'il veut
il va pas pouvoir inventer des
ressources inexistantes
ouais et puis le temps qui va qui va
s'écouler oui est-ce qu'on peut voir
combien il a temp parce que là on voit
pas bien il y a un petit bug je va voir
si je
peuxualise ouais parce que moi je vois 0
minutes je vais voir si je vais
rechercher la partie d'ici est-ce que
maintenant non c'est la pom est bugé
alors François qui n demande un petit
petit point sur les résultats est-ce que
tu pourrais afficher les résultats Sam
ou est-ce que tu veux je les donne àoral
bah tu peux commencer à les donner mais
je je vais également les les afficher
aussi d'cord alors on a Carlsen et Van
forest qui ont fait nul avec une très
très belle partie franchement François
je te recommande de la regarder parce
que elle est hyper jolie ouais un forest
qui a pris énormément de risque avec les
noirs qui sacrifia deux pions et
carassen a priori qui a raté les gain
mais c'était très très complexe même si
le roi2 pour s'échapper était à sa
portée à la fin il s'en sort grâce à une
forteresse c'est lui qui a eu un petit
peu chaud aux fesses
ouais
et on a eu fdit sipenko où il s'est pas
passé grand-chose ça a fait nul ouais
mais bon ils ont joué voilà sipenko a
été solide
medarov douudda alors Douda avait une
position probablement gagnante mais
c'était pas si évident il y avait un
petit tric
apparaît un petit piège qui était
franchement quasiment invisible à la uni
ouais mais il aurait pu être un peu plus
précis aussi et s'éviter justement de
devoir être ensuite
chirurgical il a bien craqué donc kakin
gu on parle même pas ça fin une
demi-heure
ouaisenko on en a parlé ou pas oui tu
viens de dire il y avait une nul qui a
été solide avec les Noirs visite a
proposé nul bon ça jouit encore un peu
mais ça a été
accepté et car doub c'est pareil c'était
une nul un petit peu
bon pas très intéressante mais bon il y
a eu les les les les coup ont été joués
ils sont retrouvés jusqu'à une finale de
tour complètement égale c'est pas une
nul les deux joueurs sont sont très bien
préparés comme la été doub dans la
partie le résultat n en fait il est
assez logique oui jusequà ritenu avec
les BL on peut pas les les blâmer
d'avoir fait nul parce que Ben juste
c'est une très bonne préparation
contrairement à Guiry et oui qui n'ont
pas joué pour le coup qui ont fait un
perpèicou
ouais ouais clairement donc là du coup
le petit français a perdu il a fait il
avait une partie hyper intéressante et
et et il a fait un petit coup il il a
fait des truc bizarres petit roi H2 làon
a pas compris ce qui
passait il était mal au encore une fois
il éit mal a mal aut temp et de calcul
je pense je pense qu'il est pas dans son
assiette non il est bah il doit pas être
en confiance par les premiers résultats
et du coup là il avait un apparimement à
s'apporter puis qu'il jouit contre la
lanterne rouge la joueuse chinoise qui
avait zé point il avait les blancs
euh mais voilà il aurait dû à mon
peut-être se contenter aussi de la nul
si sil avait pu mais il a peut-être il a
peut-être voulu plus puis ça a commencé
à tourner et après a très bien joué
honnêtement pour le coup l'exécution
était parfaite
ensuite donc il a eu tour H4 dans par
PRAG trs ouais il a joué tour H4 al je
sais pas est-ce que son idée c'est de
sacrifier
certainement alors ici euh ce qui est
marrant c'est que l'ordinateur je vois
il donne euh probement de faire tour
prend fou C7 ça donc toi tu veux
sacrifier ta ton cavalier et ben attends
je fais en
premier l'idée en fait c'est queend pr
et prend et pr 5 et en
fait en
faitas de pion de pion qui vont avancer
au centre qui vont être inarrêtables et
et en plus on ouvre la diagonale de la
dame je peir
cavalier c'est vrai après je serai
pas non je je ferai pas ça moi parce que
je trouve que c'est c'est une c'est une
prise de risque bah ce fou est quand
même tellement moche que tu as pas envie
de sacrifier une tour dessus quoi ouais
mais mais c'est une prise de risque mais
on voit que même à ce niveaulà on peut
jouer on peut de faire un truc comme ça
ouais après il y a beaucoup d'autres
coup on peut jouer tour tour bon si on
fait tour a en A7 bon il va répéter et
ben il y aura tout rchat et ça va
répéter la position donc il y a pas
l'intérêt de faire ça donc il faut
essayer de progresser la position il
faut fa essayer de trouver des des
choses à faire Prague a gagné Prague
joue là c'est la dernière partie
justement euh cette partie là la partie
de Prague il a les blancs et il a un
avantage il est en train de gagner voilà
il il a plus qu'à conclure ses balles de
match dit jéie c'est bien l'cho des
temps modernes bah je pense pas en fait
François parce que il a eu oui pendant
une période oui mais il y a quelques
années il a quand même essayé de
modifier son style de prendre plus de
risque et du coup il fais encore
beaucoup de nul mais très souvent à
partir de positions gagnantes ou
vraiment très intéressant
ou au fur et à mesure son style est
devenu quand même beaucoup plus
intéressant là bon dans ce tournoi ça se
passe pas très bien pour l'instant après
là aujourd'hui il avait les Noirs contre
kakin donc bon on propose nul avec les
noirs sans jouer là c'est c'est pas de
sa faute c'est clairement à kakin avec
les blancs de proposer quelque chose
guiris tout à fait normal qu'il qu'il a
accepté
et mvl oui on a déjà pu le dire
plusieurs fois mais il ne joue pas ce
tournoi je pense la raison principale
c'est qu'il veut se préparer pour les
grands prix qui arrivent très vite en
février mars et qui sont la dernière
échéance pour essayer de de choper un
ticket au au candidat donc là c'est la
priorité pour Maxime parce que là on
voit d'ailleurs les joueurs qui eux sont
déjà qualifiés pour les candidats bah
pour l'instant ils ont un peu de mal
dans ce tournoi parce quei B on sent
qu'ils veulent pas trop montrer leur
leur prépa donc c'est une situation un
peu délicate c'est un côté un peu t
d'entraînement mais ça reste un très
beau tournoi tu peux pas non plus y
aller en totalement en chaussette donc
c'est un peu entre deux
quoi donc là on voit PRAG qui réfléchit
encore al je vais remettre Prague alors
je pense que tu peux trouver la vidéo
parce que je crois que c'est la la
justement la la vidéo mais je l'ai pr
probl voyait
pas carwana ou c'est ça ouis je me suis
trompais dans ce caslà on va voir la
vidéo de Prague on va voir un petit peu
comment ils réagissent comment ils
sentent devant les chquers parce que
c'est vrai que le
le l'attitude les Ch elle est important
aussi voir comment on se sent voà on
voit qu'il est en train de de se pencher
vraiment sur les chqu alors qu' grand il
sont éloigne le plus possible comme s'il
avait pas envie de voir ça
ouais mais du coup c'est vra que c'est
un Mo important pour pr parce qu'il doit
décider comment convertir est-ce qu'il
sacrifie une qualité h c'est le moment
où il va prendre sa décision son plan de
gain en fait donc c'est normal qu'il
prenne un petit peu de temps ici je
pense il doit aussi évaluer il a
beaucoup de temps à la pendu je vous
rappelle ils ont eu au 40e coup ils ont
eu 50 minutes pour finir la partie et
ils auront encore 20 minutes 15 minutes
au 60e coup
euh vraiment ce qui est pas sûr à priori
je pense pas qu'on
ira jusque là non non plus mais mais
voilà ils ont vraiment du temps à la
pendu les PRAG à raison utilise tout le
temps qu'il a en sa positionession pour
pouvoir être sûr de marquer le point
ouais le F tiens la position noir c'est
quasi sûr qui calcu ton PR7 c'est vrai
c'est possible li moi c'est le moment où
je joue le C qui per et après il faut
que je joue à la Stouff
il pas beaucoup de coups qui perdent ici
ah peut-être que CAH prend les 5
per6 mais bon non
pr recul bras croisé sourcil français
tout est dit et F qui revient dire
bonjour ouais pour assister à
l'exécution de
grandellius donc dans tout y avait juste
F
Pr ah bien Simp ça bien coup
qui pas
j part les SAF de
qualité si je joue un coup d'attente
d'attente pourer de'acti on
voitme intéress il a quand même la
ressource il tré dans cette position une
vraie idée c'est de sacrifier la qualité
é très
fort l'idée surtout c'est de dévier ce
pion F3 qui bloquit les possibil de
contre et là ça sent attention attention
leour donc on voit des ch de
PERP que
ça c'est pour ça pas permettre de faire
un cou
peu je va rentrerame par exemple comme
ça et ça va terminé mais cette menace à
gérer je pense qu'il va manger C7 donc
il peuttre manger C finalement peut-être
le plus
efficaceéféch desidé comme ça pour Esser
gagner la D va bouger la
dameut pas changer grand peut-êre
maintenant il peutêre devoiro qu'il
arrive
parce que du coup tour
C7 de voir ce passe
alors pe prendre de la dame aussi en
fait je sais pas qu'est-ce
qu're le plus simple la dame ch dame
parce qu'en plus ça menace ça menace de
tour H8 du Tour à8 tour H8 si jamais les
dames sont pas échangé ça force vraiment
l'échange et maintenant don regardez
bien on a quand même de une qualité mais
en compensation on a quand même deux
pions pour la qualité et surtout deux
pions passés et un cavalier monstrueux
je vais bouger mon cavalier en G4 je
faire E5 E6 pousser le pion d ma tour
qui peut arriver en A8 le pion B qui est
faible les tours noirs sont mal placées
non ça c'est ça va être perdu et assez
facilement du coup la seule chance des
noir c'est de garder les pièce donc du
coup sur donc là sil Bou la dame il va
avoir tour à
ici
peut-être non mais là ça veut pas aller
ici je pense que sur sur t il faut
manger la tour pour regarder la la dame
en H4 un jouridé de RAM pr là d prend B6
ouais6 l'
for tour qui arrive derrière
oui c'est c'est une en fait oui je pense
queil fait t pr 7 la partie va pas durer
très longtemps peut-être ça va faire la
finale plutôt parce que sinon il va se
faire mat juste avec les avec les Noirs
peut-être qu'il échangera euh on peut
même prendre comme ça en fait mais
ouais tout gagne honnêtement t prend C7
c'est le coup de grâce comme le disait
OL il a raison c'est même si se fou il
est moche c'est lui qui tient toute la
boutique en défense donc on peut se
permettre de le de de sacrifier une
qualité de feu juste pour pour libérer
toutes les un truc intéressant ouais
propose sur dame prend5 euh tour prend4
fonctionne-t-il tour prend C7 dame prend
C7 ouais d prend le 5 tour pr G4 c'est
une finale mais j'ai pas de
tour8 j'ai pas
dam8 mais du coup j'ai tour à8 là je
tour à 8 aussi
viteè et sur roi bouge y a T mat et sur
tour F8 et ben je prends la tour en F8
et je prends la dame en C7 merci au
revoir
OL non je rigole vous savez les gens on
connait très bien OL c'est pour ça qu'on
se permet de se moquer de lui ça ne
marche
pas il faut encore que je recharge mon
internet j'en ai marre sinon je couper
is bah c'est c'est le dernier chargement
je pense pour la journée bah c'est sûr
hein
h alors est-ce qu'il va jouer ce
sacrifice sin il peut faire un coup
d'attente he mais bon gen l'idée ici
c'est de juste peut-être aussi rester un
peu en défense mais ça m'étonnerait je
vois pas l'intérêt de faire un coup
passif comme ça non il va il va balancer
il va
prendre il va prendre ma mais sur sur
ton bien j'ai pas de maison ouais tu
prend pas un gros risque alors pr Ryan
justement ça serait peut-être le seul
moyen pour les blonds de perdre ça
marche pas malheureusement parce que
quand on reprend c'est la double
attaque c'est la double attaque la dame
attaqué ce qui fait qu'on a pas le temps
de manger la tour on doit reprendre le
fou et il y a la tour qui tombe à la fin
du
coup du coup ça ne fonctionne
pas
c'est presque même le seul je sais Mme
pas c'est un piège parce qu'il sait
qu'il va pas tomber dedans
Prague mais en tout cas c'est la la
façon des noirs de défendre
indirectement le pion E5 c'est c'est
vis-à-vis dans la colonne dans la rangée
dans la 7e
rangée aucun problème c'est normal c'est
le premier coup à regarder ça comment
comment ah on va faire du pont et du
pont
oui je sais pas ce que tu as dit avant
moi non plus je sais pas ce que tu as
dit moi j'ai rien dit d'intéressant moi
non plus alors euh donc là il a il y a
pas eu de coup encore il y a pas de coup
non non on voit la caméra il réfléchit
moi je disais juste que c'est normal
d'avoir regarder qu' avait les PR que
c'est en fait un des premiers coups que
tu regardes dans la position juste non
non bien sûr il y a un ise on va voir si
on peut le manger quoi faut
faut voilà c'est fait il ne t'a pas déçu
tu n'as pas perdu ta maison tout reprend
ces 7 est parti
ouais non mais c'était c'était en fait
assez
assez assez évident ou parce que quand
on voit la menace des noirs avec avec
avec TP G4 et H4 euh il faut réagir
assez rapidement et du coup c'est vrai
que c'est bien joué il a pris le temps
qu'il fallait il a pas trop réfléchi non
plus
juste histoire d'assurer de bien
vérifier et maintenant on sait pas avec
quoi il va reprendre véus pour le
coup les deux sont aussi mauvais donc
difficile de faire un
choix il a sûrement dû réfléchir en av
en amont je sais pas s'il va tanker sur
ce cou je pense qu'il devrait peut-être
quand même reprendre assez
vite et et moi je vais parer sur sur un
abandon
ha
4 7e coup
45 ah tu es plus optimiste j'espère que
tu vas
gagner
euh alors pourquoi c'est un bon coup
alors on on va expliquer à à Gon d'or en
fait 46 pour Fatou al si Fatou elle
réussit et ben je promets dealancer 10
subs sur sa chaîne quand elle quand elle
lancera
ben écoutez les gars son anniversaire il
fa par plis elle va créer une chaîne
juste pour recevoir tes 10
j'avoue elle est elle est pas obligée de
de diffuser de streamer
après c'est frony St merci mais sa
chaîne elle est active je crois que je
suis je crois que je suis follower de sa
chaîne les gars allez suivre
Fatou il a joué vite il nous a fait
plaisir grandus alors oui pour pour
réexpliquer pourquoi c un bon coup en
fait par que ce fou même sil est très
passif c'est vraiment lui qui tient
toute la boutique des Noirs à savoir les
pions faibles et les Noirs il menaçent
quand même un peu de contrejeu de
sacrifier la
qualité juste pour réillustrer très
rapidement comme ça et d'essayer VO de
faire des échecs d'avancer le pion et de
mettre ce roi un petit peu en danger
donc pour éviter tout ça on sacrifie la
qualité et derrière en fait il y a tout
qui va tomber le pion5 le pion B6 ouais
la dame qui va rentré le cavalier aussi
il va y avoir deux pion pass voà ça va
être écrasant de la
tour euh il a pris avec la tour donc
grandéus on va voir prend6 on va voir
qu'est-ce qu'il mange parce que là il a
l'embarras du choix il joue vite prend
B6 attention est-ce que je peux manger
G4 quand même ou il a
mangé5 ok ouais peut-être c'est mieux
parce que sur D pr B6 t pr G4 qui é
untit peu plus compliqué alors d prend
B6 tour prend G4 je sais pas je ouaisage
4 je sais pas
is peut-être j'ai des petites idées
ouais je sais pas bon en tout cas il a
joué dame prend5 donc là il va menacer
aussi du cavalier F6 il a du dame F4 la
dame si la dame bouge ila tour à8 aussi
des fois des menaces de mats c'est c'est
une domination complète je pense queon
va avoir du mal àer jus j'ai dit combien
moi
47 45 je suis quand même pas favori hein
mais bah même temps là
c'est ça se passe pas très bien pour les
Noirs quand même cette position
cette 55 followers pas tout c diagonale
bah tu peux a JIS stream sur sa chaîne a
55 followers tu peux doubler
hein de twitch
quoi alors tour F7 a été joué bon tourus
qui joue assez vite il sa qu'il est
foutu il empêche cavalier F6 peut-être
Ilir du dame 6 pour pour
Chloé pour attaquer le pion pour libérer
la place au cavalier ça j'aime bien
l'air
assz assez
fort c'est hyper fort cavalier 5 derriè
6 ça pourrait être le dernier coup de la
partie 67 cavali 5and 45 ou franchement
c'est c'est
possible il y a trop de faiblesse en
fait chez les noir on voit qu'il y a
aucune harmonie entre les pièces
noires le roi en grand danger alors que
le roi blanc lui crain rien et je crois
que à la cam dam a été joué par Prague
qui continue en tout cas à jouer aussi
propre que depuis au moins une vingtaine
de coups il laisse rien au
hasard j'avais j'avais joué il y a
longtemps contre un bon contre un gar
Open et c'était complètement gagnant et
le mec continu jouer V pasonner et et à
fin la partie le mec il me dit je
continue jusqu'au 117e coup parce que
comme j'habite au 117e de ma rue et ben
je
voulais j'espère que grandous pas 46e de
sa r parce
que du coup faut espérer contre un mec
qui habite au TR rues du jambon parce
que là ça ça peut bien se passer quoi le
petit
matg j'ai fait un tournoi en Argentine
au début à mon arrivée et puis donc il y
a un gars qui arrive donc qui ve contre
une amie à nous et il arrive il dit bon
désolé je j trois coup et je vais
abandonner et le mec et donc
l'adversaire lui dit mais pourquoi parce
que j'ai j'ai pas de stylo et personne
n'en a donc du coup je peux pas jouer
donc je c cou je je j'abandonne quoi et
et lui dit non mais tu es fou quoi pas
acheter un stylo à côté il y a il y Ava
un truc ouvert quoi juste va acheter un
stylo tu reviens quoi non non mais c'est
bon t'inquiète TR cou fou quoi quel ch
j'avoue ça fait plaisir
bon
c la rondin tu vois elle avait elle elle
a 2100 Loo elle j 1400 bon il y a quand
même une grosse différence'en fous alors
non en fait c'est chiant d'avoir un
forfait mais ok de mal de pas jouer quoi
bah ouien là pour jouer bah surtout si
le le stylo et la véritable raison là
c'est très très con si un trtex ou mais
le mec il avait l'air pas clair de toute
façon bah oui à priori peu de chance
qu'il le soit en même temps c'est pas la
seule raison je pense que le mec il est
juste complètement paré
raison et
ouais juste pour répondre à la question
les joueurs doivent noter leur coup sur
sur une feuille en partie classique
comme ça les parties sont ensuite rentré
dans les bases de données accessi à tout
le
monde on ne vérifie pas si les joueurs
savent savent écrire c'est pas c'est pas
ça et du coup il s'est lev Prague c'est
levé il sait qu'il est gagnant d tout
reprend g avec une petite mine
déconfite du
Suédois c'est aussi l'avantage de Dam
c'est qu'on peut reprendre
tranquillement avec la dame et du coup
voilà on déter pas sa structure il y a
pas de contrejeu et du
coup il peut-être pas tout de suite
alors non je pense qu'on va tous
perdre parce que bah moi je 45 là non B
je pense pas que non F6 encoreéchec quoi
il va faire d F6 après c'est sûr c'est
sûr ouis peêtre faire d'abord je sais
pas ation de plus pour les blanc mais
pion B6 valeur le jour où le jour où
j'arrive à jouer 5
seraandon c'est juste deux pions au
centre surpuissant pass contre un pion
arriéré qui sert à rien et surtout aussi
a la tour qui active la dame qui active
le roi qui est faible donc c'est une
accumulation il joue pour jouer
hein d prend G 4
jouer les deux joueurs devrait devrai je
pense jouer assez vite quand même
jusqu'à la fin je les vois pas tanker
sur un coup ici B F6 tu joue comment
quand même alors je sais pas moi je
suppose que j'ai des échecs en fait le
roi il pourra toujours se cacher quoi
est-ce que je peux faire juste
échec et aller cacher mon roi en H2
ah il a plus tour H7 pour les Noirs mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait cet échec
pour empêcher les pour forcer le roi à
monter et empêcher les les échecs mais
en plus c'est que la tour peut plus
aller en F8 H8 pas dame à 1 donc dame
non dame D4 H2 et après je pousse mes
plans là là on va mat en
fait
je p p mal tout ça on on est 45 là c'est
ça là c'est sûr qu'il va il va pas
abandonner quoi il va jouer dame F6
ici alors OL je propose dame F6 E5
pourquoi E5 alors dame F6 E5 ah oui pour
pour avoir dame pr G6 c'est mat
peut-être qu-ce qu' est for colè donc là
ça forcerit dame G7
par que sur T G7 on va montrer mais il y
a mat du
couloir excusemoi je vi leat pas vu Arve
je vi de battre un adversaire en TR
coups av un
stylo c'est
ça
96 96 j'ai déjà maté en de coups je
crois en de coups au éche 960 par que la
position de départ prê
mais
bon c'estche 960 j'ai déjà perdu contre
Barou fou plusieurs parties pour ceux
qui suivent stream c'est vous dire faut
faut mieux être en fort en fait parce
que le cerveau il est trop en Brouard il
a joué roi
G7 il attendait que PRAC se lève pour
jouer son cou donc alors ouais s sûement
à cause de ce qu'a dit OL donc là il y
avait E5 qui était très fort ouais à
cause de ça et là bah on pouvit tout
échanger et
rentrer peu importe l'ordre dans une
finale de
roi qui est gagnant de manière
élémentaire ici
par exemple on a BES de plus hein euh un
P passer protégé donc en final de roi là
il a il y a pas de il y a pas de
problème donc là E5 je pense que 5
s'abandonne5 je pense que E5 E5 il va
abandonner oui mais il il a joué ro G7
il a pas joué d F6 oui
mais non mais il a pas joué il a pas
joué d F6 non non E5 E5 ce serait les
46e donc si Laon c'est Fatou c'est ça
hein c'est le sub pour Fatou allez c'est
les 1 qui vont partir parce que moi j'ai
perdu là il peut plus abandonner enfin
il peut abandonner mais c'est pas lu
c'est vra ce sera trop
tard bah si maintenant ça fait 45 he
mais bon il va pasner maintenant il va
jouer quand même alors du coup Ganon d'
ou c'était sur une position d'échec 960
donc pas la la position de base alors
même au échec normal il y a le mat de
l'bc on peut perdre n de cours c'est le
seul qui existe
h si si les blancs au tout début de la
partie avancent leur pion f et g pour
ouvrir cette diagonale et que les Noirs
poussent ce pion il y a le fameux mat de
l'imbécile et c'est matant de coups F3
un coup G4 de coups chez les noirs on
bouge le pion et dame H4 c'est le
deuxème coup qui fait mat voilà bien sûr
faut que les blancs il mettent du du
leur alors PRAC qui réfléchit mais bon
il y a peu de chance qu'il ne joue pas
E5 ici c'est tellement
tentant 5 c'est c'est je vois pas
d'autre ce qui pourrait faire d'autre
que
ouais bah écoute on la prend au début il
faut juste faire attention un conseil de
base pour pour les joueurs qui débutent
c'est éviter de toucher au pion
F parce que le pion F c'est le seul si
vous prenez la position de départ une
petite astuce c'est le seul le seul pion
qui est défendu uniquement par le roi
donc déjà c'est une raison pour laquelle
c'est une cible privilégier le pion F7
ou F2 au début de la partie et si on
l'avance on ouvre cette diagonale qui
est très très dangereuse donc on va
plutôt le faire potentiellement plus
tard après avoir roqué mais au début
éviter de toucher à ce pion à part voilà
si la
situation l'oblige mais faut faire
attention à ça il y avait une il y avait
un animateur bah d'ailleurs animateur du
club de can échec qui disait que le pion
F ça V enfant F comme faut pas le bouger
F comme
Fatou com fallait pas le bouger ouis
ouais c'est
vrai c'est
technique est connu
ouis
réfléch h
pro il est sérieux jusqu'au bout quel
autre coup il pourrait jouer je vois pas
pour jouer 5
bon
pas elle est très bien sa tour ici là la
dame aussi elle est elle est elle est
très bien tout est très bien à part tour
1 je vois pas d'autre coup euh non je je
vois pas de coup à part E5 al E5 est-ce
qu'il regarde
B55 a si oui bah je sais pas moi je dois
bien regarder quelque chose bon il y a
tour là aussi qui qui est pas mal
ouais allez pragy allez il a la main la
main qui est prête à partir il se gratte
le
masque là je
5 écran des va venir
abandonner ça les affaires
de
personne jou pas quoi
ou blâmer blâmer les règles pas les
joueurs c'est la cadence là qui fait que
peut se permettre d'encore prendre son
temps un crément qui est peut-être
excessif après le 40e CP mais bon c'est
un tournoi assez classique voilà
maintient les traditions
style quoi comme défense je comprends
pas ce défense rien je
pense je vois pas
je vois pas quel couple l' tour F5
ouais en fait il a toujours des P tour7
et damage 3 en je sais
pas je sais pas quel
coup le pousser à autant réfléchir non
je pas non plus est- qu' ve jou un comme
tour là paril
débile5 c'est vraiment coup qu'on a
envie de jouer justement ça empêche les
Dam
F6 on veut juste envoyer les pions
hein jusqu'au bout du suspense he pour
le petit sub
stou c'est clair forest ahi j'avais pas
pensé mais il a failli battre Magnus ça
t'aurait fait très mal encore ça çaurait
fait un petit se en plus ouais bah avec
les Noirs contre carassen bon c'était le
jour où tu étais censé te dire bon je TR
pas grand chose ouis je jeavais pas paré
sur ça
effectivement roi g ça c'est bien un
coup digne de toi OL il en a bien un qui
Brou ro G1 sur terre c'est toi à mon
avis franchement si tu joues si tu joues
ro G1 et que tu es ass à côté de moi olè
tu m'en fou il y a il y a il y a un coup
qui
part je te je te dis un coup qui partè
c'est un peu l'idée qu'on montrait tout
à l'heure c'est voilà de de cacher le
roi et peut-être nous-même mat dans la
colonne mais bon pourquoi reculer quand
on peut avancer au
liège à quoi il réfléchit c'est c'est
c'est c'est vraiment étrange comme
situation là par j'ai l'impr raté
quelque chose quoi bah sur 5 il doit y
avoir un truc qui bah
non parce que si on attaque le
enfin je je
vois il là joué ah il a fait dame 6 B
dis donc j'ai je l'avais dit dame 6 c un
coup candidat mais pourquoi et ouais
pourquoi cte à un bon coup de l'abandon
qui va pas réussir à gagner son Paris
bahà même moi moi je serai le plus
proche moi par j'aurais abandonné Mame
j'abandonne pas
ouais pareil
tu peux faire échec tuabandonnes pas
quand tu peux faire échec bah oui damage
4 t
F6 bizarre c'est pas bizarre c'est très
bien uname 6 hein il craint rien il
sentraille sa dame il met la pression
sur les faiblesses il va pouvoir pousser
ses pions mais euh
bon du coup euh euh il a prolonger un
petit peu euh je pense queouais il aura
abandonné plus vite sur5
mais mais ce n'est pas le choix du petit
indien mais r j'abandonne F tout ouais
tu as raison je comprends c'est un peu
humon Ragen quoi je
trouve mais c'est un bon petit coup
prophylactique du coup qu'est-ce qu'il
va pouvoir faire ici pas
grandchose problème c'est que si on veut
s'en prendre à la D on va toujours
libérer une entrée pour la
tour et c'est assez
problématique une question juste sur
tour au 7 tu joues
pasoi je bouge madame ah tout aussi qui
existe si je va C6 parce qu'en fait bon
si je G4 je su envie de te dire oui oui
c'est vra que j'ai ça pas con
ouais ça échange les pièces tu manges la
mienne je mange la tienne bah ouis
échanger les pièces c'est un une façon
de gagner ici pour les blancs h la
finale pour le coup il abandonnerait ici
je
pense peu de chance
que qui joue
ça
donc donc il a dû voir ça Prague sur
tour 7 tour à
ah ouais après c'est c'est toujours
aussi dur pour lesir de trouver un coup
hein échec
mais la position est perdue donc fa éche
pour faire éche
ouais ouais bah écoute Gan d' si tu
avais regardé le match de championnat du
monde je pas c'est le cas mais là tu
aurais vu deux chaises l'une face à
l'autre pendant les tr/ du match c
encore pire que
ça c quand même bizarrep qui aimait
vraiment beaucoup réfléchir depuis
l'écran de la salle de repos et pas
devant les Ch cétait quand même spécial
comme
attitude
je crois que c'est pas au même
endroit est-ce qu'on peut regarder un
petit peu déjà les apparimentss de de la
r TI en attendant je peux te les donner
si tu veux les appar tu peux nous dire
ce qui va se passer donc demain on vous
rappelle sera le premier jour de repos
du tournoi et donc on sera de retour
jeudi pour la ronde 5 alors quel queles
fiches on
a
alors petitte seconde ouais vas-y vas-y
en attendant je va remettre vite fait le
classement tout à l'heure mais on a on a
VI qui est seul en tête toujours avec TR
points sur 4 le joueur indien donc et
derrière bon le T est très long bien sûr
rien n fait on a 5 joueurs à sa
poursuite Carl MAM rapport eten van
forest
on a car DAAC la moyenne avec 2 sur 4 et
puis Prague qui devrait passer à 2/ 4 à
son tour et puis donc grandellus qui
fermerait la marche avec 05 il serait
quand même bien détaché puisque
l'avantdernier aurait un point et
demi voilà pour le petit point
classement on va retourner sur les
Chiquet parce que il y a eu un coup
dommage 4 il a fait échec il a fait
échec PRAC se rassoit il va bouger son
roi où il va le mettre en G1 je pense
plus en2 il y a G3 faut pas le mettre en
F1 c'est le seul moyen de perdre la
partie non g il a plus d'éche ça a l'air
d'être plus simple plus fiable ouais et
alors du coup
ouais si tu veux je peux te donner ouais
pour pour donc on va avoir doubbof
chanlan ok doub qui va essayer de gagner
avec les Blancs voilà on va avoir
aussiana
intéressantou n voilà on va avoir gu
blanc contre
ok un peu essayer cette fois vasy ouis
on a dou qui va essayer de remuer notre
ami euh on a là là on a une partie hyper
intéressante que j'aime bien euh c'est
Van forest avec les Blancs contre
mamedarov
ok ça devra envoyer ouais c'est une
partie qui qui qui qui peut promettre
parce que c'est des joueurs qui qui qui
aiment bien les positions tactiqu
ouvertes et qui joue clairement pour le
gain avec les deux couleurs donc ça peut
être vraiment intéressant euh ensuite on
a grandéius avec les Blancs contre
Carlsen donc euh grandéius qui va perdre
probablement sa partie là qui va être re
un demi sur qu il va faire la Sure
demain demain aprèsdain il va essayer de
faire nul avec cl blancs je pense contre
Carsen à carennul les Carlsen mais bon
même Carlsen avec même avec les noir
Carlsen il est dur à annuler oui mais
oui oui mais après si joue vraiment à
fond pour l'annule ça peut ne pas être
si facile de déséquer la
positionement clairement et euh et
ensuite on va voir rapport contre Prague
avec les Noirs ok donc partie
intéressante aussi moi un programme
sympa
un programme sympa et ganundorf ont
parlait de du match Carlsen nepo match
de championnat du monde qui s'est
déroulé du coup euh bah l'an dernier fin
2021 en décembre et du coup c'est match
de parti lente et quasiment toutes les
parties hein d'ailleurs il y avait ce
cette histoire de siège
vide do pouvoir retrouver si ve chercher
dans l'historique de chesscom fr c'était
streamer une vidéos des extraits du
match
Carlsen contre
nepoi alors il a réfléchit quand même ah
ça y est il est parti il va bouger son
roi il va le mettre en E2 il ne t'a pas
écouté et c'est officiellement le 47e
coup il y a peu de chance que qu'il
abandonne sur
roi2 du coup il va dépasser nos Paris
respectif bon il va il va attaquer le
pion G2 il va faire dame G5 ou dame G3
je pense
que on a peu de chance de se tromper
ici encore 24 minutes grand qui est
quand même assez terrible en un
sens imagine bizarre qu'il pas joué
c'est bizarre qu'il a pas joué au 5
avant quand même que c'était quand même
bah ouais j'ai pas compris ça av l'
quand même bien plus simple ouais parce
que là du coup les noirs sont un petit
peu actives contre les dame G3 ro F1 il
va falloir un petit peu faire attention
quoi ouais c'est ça c'est peut-être
juste par esprit de
contradiction pe ouais je pense que il
écoute le live et qu'il a pas envie de
de pas envie que Fatou reçoive des subs
gratuits fa travaill pour avoir des subs
Fatou c'est un peu ça ouais marking by
c'est ton ton chat qui joue avec un
oiseau une souris morte c'est
ouais c'est ça ouais exactement il joue
avec la nourriture
là après je pense qu'à la place de
grandellus beaucoup de joueurs du
tournoi aurait abandonné je sais pas ce
que ce que ce que tu en penses
mais à mon avis c'est une
position qui a pas grand intérêt quand
même de la continuer
surtout vu la cadence encore une fois
non mais c'est clair c'est un jouur
quiabandne pas si facilement peut-être
grandélius et puis sa situation
comptable fait qu'il a envie de se
battre je fais des paris avec toi c'est
plus simple de travailler ah ou ça je
peux te dire que je pense que quand
quand je vais dans le sud je n'ai jamais
à payer la moindre boisson puisquil
suffit de toujours parier avec Stouff et
tu es certain que tu as pendant un
séjour
entier avoir nourriture et boisson à
volonté au crédit de Stouff hein si bon
généralement du coup je je fais comme si
le Paris n'avait pas eu lieu
mais mais dans lesffet mais les combien
de resto je t'ai payé aussi euh bah j'ai
perdu moins que tu aurais dû mais
bon arrête P des det non ben non en fait
je culpabilise si sil y en a trop
donc mais c'est sûr après vous m'excluez
des paris aussi j'ai pas le droit à
chaque fois c'est quement justuste mais
pourquoi on t'exc Paris bah je sais pas
généralement genre des duel quiz des
trucs comme ça à chaque fois j'ai pas le
droit ah oui ok trop fort à je quoi
Paron va par avec c'est pas très pas
très
faire mais il me semble qu'on avait joué
à Saint- Sébastien on avait joué la
vaisselle au duel quiz et on avit fait
un tourno duel quiz j'avais fait le
tourno de ma
vie c'est
Barb je crois que j'avais gagné le
tournoi je CIS pas nimporte
quoiisavais et j' fait 1 avec toi
tuétais fou tuis au hasard 10 fois sur
10 oui évidemment que je chatte mais
c'est comme ça quoi mais mais j'avais je
crois que j'avais 2 0 à Julien 2 € et 1
avec toi je crois que c'était un truc de
fou peut-être et j'avais é chappé la
vaisselle ça c'était quand même je me
souviens de pas avoir fait la vaisselle
du sjour mais bon
oui mais bon toi tu faisais la la
vaisselle mais moi moi j'étais voué à la
faire tous les jours la BS parce que si
on joue à duel
quise c'est quand même pas favori quoi
après il y a Barbara donc bon il y a
toujours euh il a toujours un petit peu
de challenge c'est pas
discrimination et en tout cas ça fait
pas jouer notre ami grandius toutes ces
histoires
ouais pourtant il y a dans une
situation où il a le choix entre un coup
qui perd et un coup qui
perd on se demande bien lequel il va
choisir c'est assez bizarre quand même
la
transformation va avoir petre damage de
RO F2 dame G3
il encore ça va encore un peu
alors vraent abandon
clairement compris il réfléchi un petit
moment il pas joué pas du tout compris
pouro du coup il vair ro F1
j'imagine
par tu ro F1 dans H4
euh ben là j'ai j'ai j'ai moi j'ai ro G1
mais faire avant aussi oui mais je peux
aussi faire dame 5 et mais attention que
dame 5 après je peux pas trop trop faire
tour à 8 parce que il y aurait du Dam ah
non j'aurais toujours damage 3 ok en
fait ce qu' peut faire aussi intéressant
regardez c'est intéressant damage 4 ro
F1 je pas si tu peux jouer les cours
euh ro F1 pardon tu Besin de jouer ouais
F dame H4 dame5 en fait si la tour vient
en F6 bah je fais tour A7 et ça va et en
fait ouais et du coup h et maintenant
ici je pourisêtreer tour V parce que du
coup
euh BL SM et surtour dam h 1 J F2 dam H
4 g roi E2 plus d'échec voilà et même si
mon roi était en G1 dame1 roi H2 dam H4
j'aurais toujours dam H3 en des idé
avec jeche un petit peu mais du coup il
fait ça pour parer le mat et peut-être
qu'on envoie le pion d pour faire une
mais pareil c'est un peu long c'est un
peu la dame D8 là dame8 aussi qui peut
ou oui mais bon ouais mais mant ah mais
bien sûr que c'estant mais tu t'es quand
même compliqué la vie quoi
ouais dame H8 roi H7 dame
oui après moyen de pouir gagner c'est
mais pourquoi mais j'ai l'impression que
que que E5 à la place é quand même
tellement plus simple ouis on va voir et
j'ai vraiment du mal à comprendre
pourquoi il a pas joué au
5 la partie
al un excellent nageur passage plongeur
je sais pas c'est plutôt des gros plouf
mais nageur ça c'est
sès V non je n je
pas je n plutôt
bien alors F1 donc a été joué
hein on peut s'attendre à dam H4 quand
même parce que a rien d'autre à faire je
vois
pas après c'est c'est illusoire quand
même bah ouais mais bon après il se B
lui il a le droit oui oui il se bat un
peu contre lui-même mais euh
ouis pr il est comme là il joue il est
content il profite
de plaisir de la vie de torturer grand
oui bien
compris le double sens est tout à
fait la plonge c'est Plô la
spé ça c'est la grand Laé de
liècheèche dès que tu viens chez moi oh
t'inquiète pas je fais la vaisselle
importe mais c'est bon je vais la faire
la vaisselle non t'inquiète pas je la
vaisselle bon du coup d'accord je suis
content donc on remenace d'un machin ce
qui fait que là on a soitame de souou
soit R1 quel cas il nous aura juste
offire un petit tour de ici là gratuit
de RO ro ro là pour rien pu qu'il aurait
pu jouer ro g direct
donc on peut supposer son idée c'est
plutôt celle de Stouff mais il a le
droit de changer la vie hein R est très
bien moi j'aurais jou r r en fait il
aurais pu le faire au coup d'avant enfin
avant de faire tous ces échanges là
quand ilamche il a fait ro
de directement on arrivit là donc là ça
aurait pas trop trop de chance de jouer
r maintenant même si c'est clairement un
des meilleurs coups là il y a deux
grands coups là soit tu fais ro G1 soit
tu fais dame 5 VO pas d'autes coup
tout de suite ça doit être faire
attention ah parce que là je d
encore ou tu peuxouer c'est la même
idée IDE deouer
d c'est la M
IDE ah j'ai peur que les traumatismes
nombreux pas encore là pour nous
répondre est-ce que oliè dans le chat
est-ce que olè peut nous répondre déjà
pour vouloir jouer ragin dans la
position de tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est encore pire que de vouloir faire
la vaisselle ou alors les deux les deux
vont bien ensemble mais c'est que quand
tu es comme ça là tu as envie de faire
au quoi tu as pas envie de jouer r Kevin
nous on chumme pas Kevin hein tu vas
bien regarde regarde bien qui gagne là
regarde bien qui gagne c'est qui qui
gagne là Kevin hein je pas savour on
savoure ensemble
de de V forest là contre Carsen mais ça
a dû le chauffer un petit peu
hein oh pauvre Liège qui est encore là
martyrisé il faisait la vaisselle au
liège c'est pour ça qu'il était pas
là B pour le sub ouais mais là c'est là
c'est vraiment là c'est vraiment fini je
pense par contre un moment que qu'on le
dit du ça y est il s'est libéré Kevin
presque pouvoir l'inviter sur le
stream ça serait beaucoup trop de
prouesse technique pour le coup là mais
euh mais sinon ça aurait été avec
plaisirah tulè tu enlèves la caméra de
Prague tu mets tu mets Kevin en gros
ouais beaucoup plus intéressant
effectivement avec sa petite larme mais
moi je je penser en gardant bien sûr
toute cette configuration magnifique de
voir Prague terminer le travail en
direct mais bon il prend plaisir j'
l'impression cette partie mais tu sais
qu'en en en trois événements que je
stream comm avec Kevin trois fois on
fait à chaque fois dé pararis à chaque R
de plein de choses et c'est la seule
fois que je vais réussir à lui gratter
un sub quand même ah c'est parce que je
t'ai porté chance aujourd'hui peut-être
incroyable non mais je veux dire j'ai
des occasions dans dans chaque tournoi
dans chaque partie j'ai jamais réussi et
là bon il a encore gagné je essayer de
pas trop pas trop
le mais
normalement tu auras le droit la tête de
Kevin dès
samedi quel jour d'ailleurs ou avant sur
sa chaîne d'ailleurs
évidemment on est mardi
est M ça sent la gave de il y a pas de
gave dans cette position ça le
problèmeable mme pas I a les noir c'est
pour dire oh attention
pas tu mas V gag des
trucs que
ça oui bien
s
maisonon c'était un un papi qui avait
pas joué de qui avait 22 mais qui avait
pas joué depuis 10 ans peut-être en
partie
officielle bah c'était pas c'était pas
Prague quoi
ouais ok c'était il avait la 6antaine
d'années il avait pas joué depuis 20 ans
en compétition et il avait 2200 h et il
les les par il me joue un truc hyper
solide un système de il propos à tous
les coups et moi je force je force je
force j'ai fini par gâer en finale et je
suis perdant
j'ai gagné une partie avec tourpion
contre
Dion j'ai même pas gagné autant
tu en fait j'ai un pion qui une de la
dame et à chaque fois il me clouit le
pion à D jamais faire un jour il a mis
le roi entre l'tion entre l'tion et sa
dame et du coup il y avait au milieu et
du coup j'ai faire j'ai ass en direct à
la dernière ronde en plus pour choper un
prix et pendant ce temps par c'était je
doubl noirs contre un grand maître on
avait le mêmeo et donc lui il jouait
contre bah le bon client qui avait pas
joué depuis 20 ans aux échecs quoi voilà
il cette manière
scandaleuse donc j'avoue que j'avoue que
la j'avoue que c'était un petit peu
j'avais pas mal pas mal eu eu de chance
dans ce tournoi j'avais j'avais deux
augles je
crois deux aveugles ass et
ouais vra aveugles en fait d il se moque
de nous en fait c'est juste il fait dame
F6 abandonne oui prise prise ah il va
amener son roi en E5
ok ah tu es en train de freeer un peu là
stouf je sais pas en terme de connexion
où tour est est qui va bientôt falloir
recharger je crois d'ailleurs ça fait
longtemps qu'on a pas fait de pause
aussi de pie
ouis on est en train de te perdre et du
coup on a vu que l'échange de Dam s'est
produit euh h il aurait pu faire ça
quand même dans des bien meilleures
conditions pr avec son pion déjà en5 et
là la seule chance micro chance pratique
des noir c'est de créer un blocus un peu
contre ces pions passés trouver du
contre-jeu parce que le roi est quand
même bien avancé
h mais du coup euh bon c'est bien sûr
complètement gagnant quand même parce
que la tour peut passer par derrière
elle peut aller gratter peut-être des
pions ou aller soutenir l'avancée de
ceux-l mais il prolonge encore un peu le
plaisir quoi c'estàdire que le fait de
pas avoir jou 5 un peu plus tôt comme on
vous l'a dit plusieurs fois il s'est
compliqué la vie pour pas grand-chose
pour pas
grand-chose j'ai déjà joué contre un
mancho brutal chess mais c'était une
seule main donc du coup ça l'a pas
spécialement handicapé à vrai
dire le suppléant est là au KO où
exactement je vais appeler Kevin en
renfort il va il va remplacer stouf et
du coup la partie va tourner et PRAG ne
va pas
gagner St il doit être en train de de
repayer avec son téléphone là pour
rechoper un peu une heure de forfait
internet
supplémentaire je l'entends bouger mais
toujours pas son image devit pas tarder
à
revenir en attendant PRAG ça est monte
son
roi de joueurs devrai la jouer assez
vite quand même cette finale je
pense mais on pourrait on pourrait
atteindre le 60e ici et et profiter du
savoureux 3e rajout temp alle roi 5 un
tempo al est-ce que tu peux parler cou
pour voir parce que je t'entends
bouger mais ton image est toujours ah il
est de retour je
crois il est de retour parmi nous ouais
j'arrivais pas à
me j'ai pas réussi à à à repayer
j'ai des problèmes internet du coup tout
à l'heure partage de connexion mais que
jeille à chaque fois des tu peux
finir enant branché peut-être je sais
pas ce que j'ai fait je subranché le
cble j'arrive pas à payer en fait il
refuse je pense P trop de sub à toute la
planète Terre et que du coup ton compte
en banque est broc je crois qu'on a
l'explication il a pas besoin de
chercher bien loin mon avis ça me coûte
cher de commmenter ce
tournoi négatif en
fait belle
perance de travailler 6 he par jour pour
perdre de
l'argent du coup je s pasasch des dames
ça j'ai vu nouveau pronostic sont
ouverts pour l'abandon et est parti sur
le
62e au 52 non mais là ça va arriver quoi
arrêter comme je disais il aa avoir même
finale avec le
P5 ouais c'est ça que je comprends pas
ou oui il va aller en D3 mais
D4 il est pas propr
honnêtement il va se retrouver à jouer
un truc comme
ça gagnant mais ilve dans un truc où il
y a B de chaque côté certes ça gagne
facilement ouais mais çaz facile ça se
voit quand même visuellement que ça va
très très vite je je suis d'accord mais
bon vu la position qu'il avait c'est
vraiis il a un pe peu galér quoi
ou c'est un peu dommage quand tu vois la
partie qu'il a fait tu te
dis la réison finale un petit peu un
petit peu gâché tu l'impression
ouais donc moi je vais dire allez
50 1 2 3 4 alle allez
58 on est à quoi là
52 62 c'est que trop lo ça paraît
beaucoup oua même 58 c'est peut-être
beaucoup mais
ouais moi je dire 57
je pense c'est plus
précis tu te gardes la rond 56 en plus
au cas où donc c'est pas mal je faire
comme jeu des boîtes j'ai 10 56 est-ce
que est-ce que tu est-ce que tu reprends
ton coup je te laisse 57 je prends 58
euh ok ah ben non parce que a dit 56 du
coup là je joue plus que le 57 pile quoi
donc c'est pas terrible
oui ben moi j'ai fait 57 donc je te le
laisse non ok je reste sur mon 57 après
je vais avoir trop de regret si je
change de boîte et je me retrouve avec
la boîte où il y a ou ouais mais bon toi
tu es quand même la boîte ou il y a une
crevette dedans et oui allez c'est parti
à tempo il a jouer à jou tempo ro C4 ah
c D4 il a pasion
ais mais il est malin parce qu'il veut
sur roi D3 du coup prendre la colonne et
bloqué avec son roi du
coup c'est c'est bien plutôt mal he du
coup il revient ah ça c'est ça c'est
mauvais pour toi sa la répétition qui
part là il ouais il a répéter une fois
c'est très mauvais pour pour ton pas
mais il vient de répéter quoi c'est une
blague il ça y est j'ai enfin la nul
Prague ok je vais pouvoir il surpris
grandus al s'il fait nul j'arrête de
commenter non mais il va pas faire nul
mais juste il avit ça pour gagner du
temps se rapprocher du 60e j'aurais
j'aurais pas mon sub c'est fini là là
c'est non mais là c'est incroyable en
fait ce qu'il a fait euh al la
répétition qui met'est quand même fa
tout très
bien bah ouais j'ai bien fait de garder
mon 58 parce que du coup
du coup moi je suis pas content il a pas
tour attention ça fer TR fois
tour
Jer coup il va jouer quoi il va jouer
son ro il passe quoi sur T
là
pasiz fA
ou il raison
pere compli tellement la vie Dansette
partie
hucants c'est un pe chiant qu c'est
gagmeten
i oui oui
mais
ouiandme bien gagant mais heureusement
que c'est encore bien gagnant mais
regarde galère gère de ouf quoi le sub
qui
tremble
allez PRAG c'est étonnant je franchement
il avit une
t position tellement écrasante et puis
surtout il avait été hyper facile depuis
le début quoi non non jeis d'accord la
réation elle est un petit peu un petit
peucevante vraiment la fin je par
juste finale de
tour mais mais ok bon ça reste maîtriser
quoi il y a jamais de contreje
les
forces du coup je pense qu'il va jouer
tour bien est-ce que D6
gag il se fait bloqu c'est pas
terrible je pense
c'est peutêtre est-ce que c'est pas le
seul vrai coup parce que bon tour on a
vu que CIT répétition après ESS de
ramener son roi direct al c'est ce qu'il
fait il fait roi D3 en disant que si tu
prends la colonne c'est pas grave il ro
D3 oua il tour à 7 qui va partir à tempo
je
pense du coup du coup c'est Fatou qui va
gagner le
Paris ben ou pas non mais il sera la
plus proche bah c'est la plus éloigné
donc évidemment bah oui mais cétait pas
écrit à priori
là tour à 7 il y a pas d'autres coup on
va prendre la colonne ouverte on va
s'activer si jamais il joue pas tour à 7
c'est les blancs qui vont jouer tour 1
et ce sera
fini c'est forcé
et dans qu coup il va récupérer donc
j'arrive jamais à me rappeler c'est 15
ou 20 minutes supplémentaires 15 15
minutes
supplément alle tour à 7
jouer devrait avoir je pense roi C3 ou
roi C2 je pense pas que ça change
grandchose
rapidement et ro C3 je crois qui a été
joué à la caméra
voilà et donc l'idée de Prague bah ça
vaêre on va voir ce que fait les no mais
soit de s'activer comme ça soit de de
contrôler les entrées de la tour avec
son
roit peut-être il peut passer par là-bas
donc on aller manger ici ou pousser
selon ce que ce que font les Noirs parce
que si la tour s'en
va peut-être que maintenant on peut
jouer D6 tout simplement ou le roi il
peut plus rattraper le pion t rest donc
ça force la tour à reculer et on fixe la
tour ici et donc là maintenant c'est
hyper facile il suffit de passer le roi
montrerin parce que faut bien comprendre
qu'on peut pas manger ce pion avec les
Noirs là cette finale elle est gagnante
très facilement pour les blancs même
s'il a une égalité matérielle VI un pion
passé protéger contre un pion arriéré
qui qui est bloqué qui peut rien faire
donc là ça ça gagne tout seul euh sans
calculer qui un plus il y a rien à
calculer on voit juste on contre les
pions et on voit que voilà juste il y a
lui contre lui donc c'est un un plot qui
est bloqué contre une fusée et ici c'est
terminé
h donc dans cette position la t peut pas
non plus trop partir à cause de ça
peut-être qu'il va faire roi D6 du coup
pour bloquer moi je pense qu'il va jouer
ça mais
ouis sur roi D6 Mo j'ai envie de jouer 3
B3 oui oui je pense et après je partira
avec ma tour en H et c'est ça et H6 ça
va gagner facilement ouais mais bon il
aura il aura mis le
temps h du coup c'est je CIS qu'on a pas
fait du tout de pause depuis plus d'une
heure donc
euh pour faire plaisir à chesscom on va
devoir lancer une dernière
pub et du coup on reviendra pour le
dénouement d'ici quelques minutes euh
voilà on vous dit à tout de suite vous
allez le courage de rester jusqu'au
[Musique]
bout
le retour et donc on a eu un coup
pendant cette pause stouf euh G5 qui a
été joué par
grandéius G5 donc du coup on imaginait
roi
B3 rentr
et et on veut partir de l'autre côté et
ro B3 a été joué instantanément cette
fois par
Prague il la cadence donc il lu reste 4
minutes 40 pour arriver au 60e coup pour
jouer encore deux coups
derrière et le problème des Noirs c'est
que ils ne peuvent pas qu' serait pas
loin en vrai d'avoir un
[Musique]
blocus si cette colonne h était aussi
fermée imaginons il y a un pion noir en
H4 blanc
H3 pas si facile de progresser pour les
blancs euh il y a sûrement moyen tu peux
tu peux percer hein mais bon mais là
voilà c'est beaucoup plus facile parce
que si on part là-bas bah les blancs
vont prendre la colonne A et si on reste
dans la colonne A on peut passer par la
colonne h
euh donc normalement c'est vraiment plus
qu'une affaire
de de quelques coups ça fait longtemps
qu'on dit ça mais cette fois-ci on voit
pas comment ça pourrait se prolonger
beaucoup beaucoup ça semble se préciser
donc 58e coup donc si maintenant ah ça
serait beau mais sera un gros vol c'est
Mo 58 toas 57 c'est vrai ah oui c'est
vrai c'est
vrai 59 ça me va encore 60 ça serait ave
donc bon j'ai encore une petite
marge
je sais pas trop à quoi il peut
réfléchir bah roi des 6 mais bon c'est
un coup de merde il y aura t
là-bas si je fais des des flèches ici ça
marche
ouais non non non B on attend on attend
l'abandon comme vous depuis un petit
moment si vous avez survécu à cette
dernière pub d'ailleurs
ouais mais il réfléchit ça y est il a
pris un pion dans sa main il nous fait
une faus grandellius il essayé de
recourrir son son pull avec sa veste
mais c'est pas
suffisant je pense que il a cours de
tactique là cours de
ressources tu as dit des choses en
cachette stou tu vas perdre 20 sub et G4
qui part le contrejeu des Noirs
attention ouais c'est sûrement
le le meilleur coup pratique si tentz
qu'il y a un coup pratique dans cette
position et du coup PRAC va peut-être
réfléchir un petit peu sur G4 est ce que
je mange priori je pense pas hein est-ce
que je pousse le pion d ou est-ce que je
passe par derrière tu pourrais même
manger ça serait gainciile en fait c'est
sûr il peut manger aussi parce que tu
manges euh tu manges prend des tour D7
G5 ou Mme tour des5 tour des5 oua tu ne
montes pas le roi et maintenant fa une
barrière enfin je sais pas tout gagne
j'ai l'impression même moi je la gagne
en Ultra bullette contre les contre tout
le monde ouais donc PRAG fa qu'il a
gagné et prend G4 ça gagne direct c'est
vrai tu as raison de gagner d de gagner
par que même D6 tour D7 et4
aussi attaqué par les moustiques quoi
terrible
c'est d D6 allez il a poussé il a envoyé
le en des alors tour D7 va être joué
prise pr il a pris F3 on l'a vu on l' vu
on l' vu il a pris F3 ok donc il va
reprendre F3 et maintenant tour D7 on
est déjà au 60e
coup on a le retour de tvermont Arnaud
qui sont là pour le coup de grâce non il
a joué roi E6 mais il est sérieux là ah
il va abandonner au 61e je il va pas
donner raison à fat il va abandonner un
coup avant pour pas qu'elle est un petit
perfect parce que là D7 c'est abandon
c'est la finale de roi qu'on vous a
montré tout à l'heure D7 pour prend D7
alors là juste Prague je pense il
revérifie vite fait de trois checks dans
sa tête la finale de roi est-ce qu'elle
gagne bien oui
il y a pas de blocus miracle et donc D7
il va
abandonner je pense qu'il va jouer la
finale de roiou ou pas sera un pe honnêt
ser je sais
pas ça serait vraiment là du jusqu'au
bouhisme un peu masochiste même de
continuer ça tu sais que tu as perdu là
plus que
jamais pr il a le poignet qui est prêt à
partir et des qui est joué la petite mou
de
grandélius il hésite j'abandonne ou pas
il hésite entre manger le pion et
abandonner je pense bah il a pas
d'autres coup c'est les deux
coups gentil mais il a pas d'autres coup
que ça mais c'est marrant du coup ah il
mange le pion non mais c'est pas
possible quoi il va jouer jusqu'au mat
en fait il pense qu'on adversaire c'est
un enfant qui s'est pas maté avec CIS
d'âes enfin je sais pas c'est B ben
c'est un enfant ouais mais bon c'est
manque de respect là de jouer ça c'est
ouais bon il a la jou un peu quoi mais
euh oui oui
ok mais là ça va être fini là ok c'est 6
5 abandon peut-être il abandon 5 ouais
effectivement là il va il va bandner sur
5 on va avoir droit du coup ça fera 64
coups en même temps pourquoi abandonner
maintenant tu n'as pas abandonné hier
gen il y a quand même euh il y a quand
même tu vois euh un certain prestige de
jouer un tournoi quel que celui-là
surtout pour un joueur comme comme comme
brandelius hein qui bon un des moins
forts du touris quoi donc il a intérêt
quandême se tenir un caros s'il veut
être invité un jour hein donc tu peuxter
mais lui il va toujours être correct he
bien sûr il y a vraiment des attitudes
correctes il réfléchit
hein et euh et donc là après le 5 là ça
abandon il a quand même du mal à
accepter l'arrê alors pourquoi ça
abandon donc le roi est obligé de
reculer et ça y est il fait un petit
check du point donc ce sera 64 coup
peut-être qu'il avait atteindre il
voulait atteindre 60 64 64 cas ou qu'il
habite comme Laou
64és je crois qu'il a marqué nul sur
le a rechangé d'arrière
trich pourquoi ça gag c'est que le roi
le roi quand il va aller manger ce pion
là nous avec les Blancs on va manger les
deux pions et donc on se retrouve avec
celui-ci qui va filer à dam tout
simplement voilà c'est ça comme le
nombre de
cases bon du coup demain est-ce qu'on
rend dans les appariments demain c'est
de REP ah oui pardonès tu peux venir ça
te fait plaisir de stream demain tu peux
stream hein écoute alors euh donc oui
donc demain journée de repos les gars
par contre on se revoit euh jeudi à
partir de 14h heure française pour
doubov chanlan ipenko carwana DIY vidit
Douda kyakin van forest mamedarov
grandelus Carlsen et Richard rapport
contre le prodige indien
pragavanda donc d'ici là euh portez-vous
bien oui merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi euh d'avoir été
et euh yes à très bientôt bonne soirée à
tous et à très bientôt ciaoevir à tous
Ciao